Ну що, починаємо наш останній модуль. В навчанні Академії МСММ, як ви бачите, не всі дійшли до кінця. І це теж дуже сильний і вагомий показник того, що як і у житті.
І це не погано і це не добре. Ми вже навіть на третьому потоці враховуємо бізнес-моделі з фінансистом саме відсоток людей, які повинні відійти. Тобто навіть це враховується зараз у математики, анал
ітики фінансиста.
Бо бухгалтерія, ви знаєте, вони працюють з теперішнім, з урахуванням минулого, а фінансисти – це ті люди, які працюють з теперішнім, з урахуванням майбутнього, щоб прогнозувати розвиток того чи інш
ого елементу розвитку бізнесу. Це є коучинг і психотерапія, різний вектор, так і у житті. На будь-який напрямок є завжди різний вектор.
Тому цікаво дивитися про те, що колись я говорила, мене запитувала Юлія, а як, чому у вас успіх і так далі. Я просто довше всіх. І тут історія про правду. З мого першого потоку жодна людина не продов
жила навчання і викладання, чи робота у психології, у інституті.
З другого, на магістратуру, вже йшла більш свідома аудиторія, і друга, вища, чи магістратура, це все ж таки такий напрямок більш серйозний, там десь приблизно 20-30% напевно працюють у напрямку псих
ології, але все одно 20-30%.
Тому кількість людей, яка відпадає по дорозі, вона дуже велика. І це теж ок, бо це для тих, хто йде, йде, йде, відкриває наступні двері.
Що, у нас сьогодні останній модуль, він буде сьогодні із практичною частиною, але ми думали, що дати вас вже минулого разу я дала всі модулі з МЧП, ви можете їх додивитися, якщо це потрібно, а можете
не додавлятися, у вас вже дуже великий бекраунд від кожного викладача для того, щоб у вас була функціональна система і ви вже це мали перед собою і так далі.
Але сьогодні я додала таку більш творчу, більш легку імпровізацію, що можна робити, коли у людини нема запиту, і попрацювати з собою стосовно вашого шляху на майбутнє. Це такий момент. Васінька, зар
аз дам.
Хотіла окремо сказати вдячність Василю, окрему вдячність хотіла б дати Маші Краб і Аліні Вілідіни за те, що ви прямо амбасадор бренда MCMM. Ми, якщо що, вас бачимо. Ви не даєте нам змоги, вас не бач
ите.
І це теж про проявленість і про змогу говорити про себе гучно і так далі. Дякую за таку підтримку. Це дійсно дуже цінно.
Сьогодні ми першу частину проведемо, перші 20 хвилинок, з Анастасією Сеоцього проєкту і людиною, яка створила його як методолог Нестерцій і створила пазлік до пазліка.
Людиною, яка здобула дистрибюцію з Віктором Яломом, Ірвіном Яломом з цією американською платформою.
Людиною, яка оптимізувала процеси, дозволила навчання зробити по 500-700 гривень, а не про 2-3-5 тисяч гривень.
Це теж дуже великий її вклад.
Людина, яка все одно крок за кроком розвиває, слухає, воює з кордонами, вміє відстоювати себе,
але веде за собою систему, знаходить спільну умову з викладачами, спільну умову з умовами і так далі.
Проект складний. Якщо б мене запитали зараз, чи почала б я його рік тому ще раз,
бо це ж для нас такий дуже сильний екзамен. Почала б. Почала б однозначно, але можливо б шукала б гранди
і не починала б своїми рухами і силами, бо це дуже складний проєкт.
Тому я нами пишаюся у цілому, що ми це створили на українському ринку і наскільки ми адаптували, переадаптували систему зараз вже до третього потоку і ми все одно дамо можливість вам десь добирати ці
чи інші для себе можливості, довчитися і так далі.
Ну що, будемо починати стосовно чому Настя тут, тому що ви запитували, що буде далі, чи є щось далі і так далі. Ми поки що, поки що зробили вже MVP того, що 100% буде в MCMM Pro, це 15 хвилинок, зар
аз покажемо.
Але тут історія про те, що якщо ми щось не додали, дайте, будь ласка, нам в рекомендації, що б ви хотіли б там ще бачити. Бо ми живий організм і за рахунок того, що ми якраз не гіперстрога академічна
система, а саме люди, хто спілкується з вами, а що вам хочеться, це дає можливість нам створювати неймовірні продукти, підсилювати їх.
Ми слухаємо, ми відчуваємо, ми гнучки, ми адаптовні, ми нерегідна інертна система, як більшість напрямків, у котрих дуже великий склад людей і вони не можуть повернутися різко.
Ми можемо дозволяти собі маньоври. Тому таким чином ми будемо рухатися.
Так, поїхали. Що ми придумали швиденько з нашими можливостями далі? Ми вирішили зробити MCMM Pro. По суті, це буде група по підписці на рік, на півроку, на рік, для того, щоб взаємодіяти далі.
Першим, можливо, сильним елементом і корсю це є те, що ви будете на очах. А ті люди, хто на очах, ми все одно взаємодіємо, що створюємо, що створюємо, що створюємо. Вже ж там будуть не всі, бо не вс
ім це потрібно, це повинно йти зсередині, чи потрібно, чи не потрібно.
Що буде доступно у цій можливості і так далі? Бути слухачем третього потоку усіх моїх менторських сесій, бо вони все одно будуть змінюватися. По-друге, продовжувати практику. Ми змінили групові суп
ервізії, ми додали супервізії по трійкам.
Вони будуть платні, але будуть по собі вартості того, що ми робимо проєкт з супервізорами.
Ви можете довчитися, добрати, дійти, все, що вам необхідно, якщо це потрібно вам.
Це не обов'язковий елемент, але це можливість.
Далі, бути запрошеним експертом.
Ми все ж таки вирішили, що у цю групу ми відповідальні.
Ми будемо запрошувати в МЧП, МСМ, Мастер Хаб, інші продукти, створення продуктів.
Зараз подзвонив Дзен Ігор Дідник, у нього, хто знає, один з дуже великих українських YouTube-каналів, срібна ось ця кнопочка, вони дістали за роки-півтори цього каналу, і вони є дуже сильними забудов
никами в Україні проєктів Дзен.
І вони просять 2-3 людини, котрі будуть збирати епку, стередини, коучів і так далі, на платній основі і так далі. Тому в нас все одно є постійні замовлення і ми стаємо все більшими і більшими на рин
ку. Юрчик, я тебе туди, якщо що, порекомендувала стосовно бачення Клодоу і так далі. Тому все, що ви робите, все, що ви говорите, воно почути на всяк випадок. Тобто ми чуємо, ми бачимо, бачимо тих, х
то проявляється.
Далі, у реєстрі випускників ми вже його створили, ми ще його не пушили рекламою, але ви повинні розуміти, що те, що я говорила на старті, воно, що сказала, то й зроблю. Ваша популярність, ваша значим
ість, ваша вага на ринку відіграє, наскільки ми стаємо мощними у вазі самі як Академія.
Те ж саме навпаки, наша вага на ринку дає вам більш сильну вагу того, що ви і хто ви є на ринку. І це дуже сильна історія співавторства. І хочу сказати, що командні ігри все одно вдовго мають найсиль
ніший накопичувальний потенціал, ніж гра в одинака і так далі.
Далі, менторські сесії. Один раз в місяць буде Льоша, один раз в місяць буду я, один раз в місяць ми, скоріше за все, будемо давати вам якогось фахівця профільного, чи створення продуктів, чи просув
ання, але такий прям консалт під капотом.
Плюс в мене, моя підприємницька сильна оточення, воно має дуже великий бекграунд різних можливостей. Ми будемо формувати запит, що саме необхідне, бізнесове запитне просування, і будемо знаходити
людей, які можуть вам цей запит закрити.
Стосовно доступу до МЧП, це 100% так. Далі, у вас він залишається безкоштовним, він оновлюється і буде оновлюватися. Далі, Мастер Хаб, усі продукти, а ми кожного тижня оновлюємо новий продукт з акред
итацією, американською, джеємбалів і дуже сильним на інформацію є безкоштовними для всієї групи MCMM-про.
Рекомендації того, що ми рекомендуємо своїх і тих, перед ким ми будемо в обов'язках. Ви зрозумієте такий момент. Тут кожен потік буде додавати 35-40 людей. І ця група – це просто група людей, які у
надивленості. Там буде більше плюшок. І офлайн-евенти будуть в доступі, і знижки на все будуть на постійній основі, бо це постійні наші, це як діти.
Все, пір-то-пір ми будемо організовувати обов'язково всередині, будемо організовувати баді по дві людини з відгуками, зі звітами і так далі. Тому у цілому ми створили зараз MVP того, що ми 100% можем
о дати, а потім ви знаєте, що ми намагаємося дати більше, ніж ми можемо, але ми не можемо сказати більше, ніж взяти як обов'язок.
Тому ми створили ось цей момент, річну групу, дивимося, як ми відпрацюємо, вартість ви бачите, якщо це буде актуально, це не на зараз, це тільки після випускного вашого, якщо буде актуально, welcome,
ми цьому будемо тільки-тільки разі, why not, ми все зробимо і так далі.
Тому ось такий проєкт зараз у розвитку, для мене найсмачнішою історією все одно є Мастер Хаб, він буде дорожчати по ціні, ми зараз з ним пінгуємо ринок, тому дуже велика рекомендація звернути на це
увагу.
Стосовно Мастер Хабу, поки ви студенти, ви вчитеся, а вже ж там безкоштовно, бо це наша ще одна плюшка вам, і нам хочеться постійно щось вам давати.
Після завершення навчання вже це стає окремою платформою. Не забувайте про неї, бо ми привеземо на український ринок дуже великі імена і дуже велику систему.
Настя, ти хочеш щось додати тут?
Я хочу сказати, що я вас вітаю. Ви всі дуже криті. Я хочу сказати, що, нагадати точніше про те, що в нас є анонімна антета зворотнього зв'язку.
Також я працювала з деякими з вас, вже зізвонювалися, ми збирали зворотній зв'язок.
І ми до цього дійсно відкриті, це дуже класно, хочеться якісно підвести ітоги пройденого періоду.
Тож, будь ласка, проявляйте активність, ми ще вам напишемо таку інструкцію про те,
як з нами зв'язатися, зв'язатися зі мною на кінцевий такий дзвінок.
Ми з вами званувалися вначалі, на початку, і можемо зробити ще один дзвінок для того,
щоб звірити ваші точку А, точку Б, зібрати зворотній зв'язок і так далі.
Очікуйте, будь ласка, на ці повідомлення.
Всім велике-велике дякую.
Дуже класно було з вами познайомитись, працювати, це дійсно було дуже кайфово створювати разом із вами пліч-опліч цей проєкт, крок за кроком. Дякую вам.
Я хочу додати, що тільки за рік, коли ви почали з нами бути, ми здобули віктора Яла. Ми тільки за цей рік ви бачили, що 6 червня я виступаю в Кембриджі онлайн, офлайн в Кембриджі я виступаю у жовтні
і їду туди з командою.
В Оксфорді ми виступаємо, теж, здається, листопад. Потім ми їдемо на Давоську конференцію представляти нашу компанію. Тобто те, наскільки ми вийшли на міжнародний ринок тільки за цей рік, це неймовір
но потужно.
Тому усі зв'язки, оце там можна буде обговорювати. Научний піар, научні керівники, до кого я йду, де ми пишемо, лабораторії у Варшаві, де можна робити дослідження стосовно ваших епок, якщо ви будете
робити і так далі.
У нас неймовірні потужні зв'язки з'являються все більше і більше. Ми машина, котра йде вперед і будемо йти 100% постійно. Тому тут спільнота невелика і все більше і більше. Якщо ви бачите, у цілому
політика, я відходжу від ринку, контакту з людьми, у мене все менше і менше на ринку і буде 100% ще менше і так далі.
Тому там ми будемо давати весь інструментарій, головне запитувати. Найглупіше питання, ви знаєте, що це не задане питання, тому ми будемо давати все, що стосується научного піару, українського піару,
просто щоб ви розуміли, що ми дійсно працюємо над академією і над іменем академії, ви перші, хто в нас повірив, тому ви будьте впевнені, що усі наступні потоки будуть дорожчими, щоб вам було приємні
ше.
Те, що я вклала зараз у 2 роки 100 тисяч доларів у піар, у научний і український піар, це без друкування статей у Forbes, Village і так далі. Тобто зараз напрямок величезний, величезний компанії, іму
ні і так далі, він тільки буде за 2 роки дуже масштабно збільшуватися.
Ми все одно не зупинимося. Тому ваша інвестиція, вона окупиться ще мільйон разів, але вона не може окупитися, якщо ви не вкладаєтесь на 100% у свої 50%. Ми, як компанія, будемо допахувати. Це, скорі
ше, група бути на очах і бути у співавторстві, моментів спілкування і так далі.
Поїхали далі. Для всіх випускників, те, що буде для всіх, вам не обов'язково йти у цю групу.
Ви знаєте, що я не продажник і продавлювати вам цю групу не буде.
Буде там п'ять людей, значить ми будемо працювати з ціма п'яти людьми і для нас це ок.
Все. Далі буде наступний потік, і так ми сформуємо якусь там спільноту.
На сьогоднішній день для всіх випускників присутність в реєстрі асоціації ментор-коуч, майн-мастер,
ви не завжди там і ми будемо слідкувати за вашими успіхами.
Все одно ми подумаємо, як нам робити, можливо, один раз в рік якісь дзвони, запитувати і так далі.
Не для того, щоб пропонувати вам щось допродати, подивитися, як ви розвиваєтеся,
дивитися лонгітюдно, як лонгітюдні дослідження, дивитися, як ви розвиваєтесь.
Далі, безкоштовна участь у професійній спільноті, мастер-кап, там теж буде дуже багато активностей,
тому там Настінька все розповість.
Безкоштовне навчання та сертифікація Віктора Ялова з проходження курсу поглиблення самопізнання,
Це все одно за вами залишається. Якщо ви не пройдете, навіть поки ви навчаєтесь, продіть потім, бо там чотири дуже сильні лексії всередині, як вести консультування.
Все ж таки це такі мостодонти, цікаво подивитися і потім взяти собі теж сертифікат, диплом і так далі.
Доступ до платформи та запису навчання на рік залишається ще рік. Передивлюйтесь, повертайтеся, зробіть собі базу знань, зробіть собі ті техніки, котрі необхідні.
У вас є доступ, ми залишаємо більше, це дуже великий об'єм, воно все їсть, їсть, їсть і так далі. Далі, можливість придбати додаткові години практики. Дивіться, це стосується супервізії. Ми все одно
будемо докручувати і так далі. Зараз ми дуже сильно змінюємо супервізійні вікна, щоб тет-а-тет людина могла пропрацьовувати свої навички і так далі.
Тому, якщо ви захочете просто продовжувати практику, набити, набити, набити, походити на мої, набити свої навички, попрацювати з супровізорами, дійте. Тобто, ми дамо можливість просто купляти години
супровізії і так далі. Було б бажання. Це знову ж таки про відповідальність.
Відповідальність. Ви знаєте, я вчора з чоловіком розмовляла про те, що гроші дітям не іграшки, любов дітям не іграшки, любов відносини дітям не іграшки. Все, що стосується великих перемог, воно завж
ди про відповідальність. У відповідальності є ось цей корінь відповідь. Ну, ось це головні новини.
По-друге, ще раз повторюся, ви можете дати ваші побажання, чого ми там не зробили, чого ми ще не додали. Тобто, можливо, ми чогось не побачили, але ми за те, щоб ми побачили, якщо це буде по нашим
силам.
Випускний. Знаєш, що дуже багато людей хотіли зробити випускний і хотіли побачитися офлайн у нас тут. Одразу скажу, що є у нас сімейний ресторан, ресторани по Києву, тому ми будемо зустрічатися в Мі
ністерстві піци у центрі Києва.
Якщо ви захочете зробити, ми там робимо закриті івенти, якщо ви бачили на презентації книги, як ми це робимо, жива музика, свічки, закритий зал з красивою червоною тканиною, це так помпезно, там в
нас є вже авторські коктейлі, бо це сімейна історія і теж відноситься до мене, тому там зробимо все по собівартості і так далі.
Якщо хочете, з радістю приїду я, приїду мій чоловік, приїду вся команда, яка тут у Києві, поспілкуємося, відпочимо, понасолоджуємося музикою, ми вміємо це проводити, не потрібно робити якісь оплати
залів додаткової і так далі, ми зробимо все красиво.
Тому, якщо це актуальна, Вікторія Boy's The Head of Product, додатку TEA, вона теж це організує. Тільки нам потрібно розуміти, скільки людей. Вона порахує собі вартість просто красивого столу. Там
дуже, неймовірно, вкусна кухня. Якщо захочете щось авторське, щось унікальне, зробимо ще. Можемо там на кухні творити все, що нам потрібно. І зробимо там красивий івент, все вирахуємо і так далі.
Потрібно тільки розуміти, хто планує бути у Києві, зробимо красивий, інтелігентний, такий смачний вечір, посидимо, поспілкуємося, пофотографуємося, тобто зробимо все, що ви захочете. Тому тут ми теж
підхвачимо, у нас дуже багато можливостей по Києву, і не тільки, головне, дайте нам ціль.
Настя сказала, що в нас є все для того, щоб організувати. Скажи мені, Настя, тут буде у них якась інформація, що потрібно групі, щоб вони знали?
Ви спочатку дайте, будь ласка, сказати, кому взагалі цікаво, хто в Києві, чи готовий приїхати, щоб ми розуміли плюс-мінус кількість людей.
Ми зробимо такий розрахунок і окремий пост про те, скільки орієнтовно це буде коштувати.
І після цього ви зможете підтвердити або не підтвердити, і ми будемо вже організовувати або не організовувати у Києві для вас випускний.
Аліночка, зроби, будь ласка, якесь повідомлення з можливістю там написати, хто точно планує, але напишіть, будь ласка, дати, щоб у людей була дата.
Давайте не сьогодні, а завтра подумайте, напишіть точну дату, коли це можливо.
Це п'ятниця або субота, бо усі ж їхати повинні якось.
Ми подумаємо, ми вам напишемо декілька варіантів дат, які взагалі будуть можливі,
щоб ми встигли все організувати і так далі, а ви оберете, коли вам буде зручніше.
І потім, будь ласка, ставити плюс, це теж відповідальність, що ви берете відповідальність і розраховується на вас.
Це теж такий момент, все, і ми вираховуємо вартість красивої вечері,
все по домовленостям, музиканти по домовленостям, у нас все не зв'язне,
але дуже красиво, естетично, ми це робимо і не перший раз.
Тому і це ми візьмемо на себе, зробимо дуже красиву вечерю,
дуже красивий такий випускний, щоб вам воно запам'яталося,
організацію організуємо, головне, щоб ви зрозуміли, хто буде.
Так, ось ця головна стартова інформація. Так, дивлюся чатик наш і Васінька, потім тобі даю. Вчора був вже перший дзвон, як дати випускну приблизно в Києві я буду. Все зробимо, я з чому і сказала, ми
зробимо дати, зробимо там, давайте, наприклад, 2-3 дати, ви проголосуєте, потім від цієї дати ми зробимо, запитаємо, скільки людей буде,
І потім одразу викатимемо, а я, Настінька, надо буде Вікторії написати по даті, щоб вони зі дзвонилися, узнали.
Це ми зробимо окремо, все зробимо, все організуємо, зробимо красиво.
Ну, все зробимо красиво, все. Тут не хвилюйтеся, все буде.
Все, це головна інформація. Цікаво було, корисно?
Вась давай починай говорити поки що а далі я чекаю поки напишуть Настя тобі дякую що ти була поруч
тут може з нами побути якщо в тебе є час але я знаю що в тебе часу нема тому можеш ти спати
все відпочивай моя хороша так так так все да я поговорю по телефону і я ще раз руку піднесу
добре що я не знала дякую давай так Настя все з тобою завтра там все по плану все іди
Сонечки мої, на сентябрі 100% ні, 100% одразу ні, дуже велике вікно планування, на сентябрі буде гроші секслада, я останній раз буду проводити лідерський кемп, в жовтні я буду у Лондоні.
Все. І, скоріш за все, після жовтня я трішки буду змінювати взагалі доступ до себе як таковий, тому це буде на юнь, на червень чи на липень, як і закінчується навчання. Це не обов'язковий елемент. Т
еж зрозуміти, що ця вечеря – це не обов'язково. Це можливість там побути.
Ви все одно хотіли б це зробити без мене чи зі мною, просто ми запропонуємо вам можливість це зробити дуже якісно, дуже естетично і красиво, бо ми організуємо до діталей увесь івент, і подивлюся, які
дати у цілому вільні, і запропонуємо ви оберете.
Все, ось це була стартова історія. Поїхали, давайте 15 хвилиночок на питання, як ваші справи, як ви. Дайте трішечки контакту, бо контакту дуже хочеться.
Все ж таки, я все одно буду за вами сумувати. Ви все одно зробили неймовірний крок для нас, і ми ще, особливо в вашій групі, будемо винні у доброму, доброму сенсі. Ми беремо цю вину дуже коректно на
себе, і ми хочемо ще додати і додати наступного кроку те, що ми ще не договорюємо, але ми будемо вам корисні, і ми будемо хотіти бути вам корисними ще довго.
Тому будемо допрацьовувати. Як ваші справи? Втомлені, невтомлені? Що у вас сьогодні, вчора відбувалося? У вас був такий дуже сильний слот. Бачила, як там влада борозянська вас підтримувала цариця. Т
ому скажіть, будь ласка, як ви?
Сонечко моє, давайте, Кристи.
Давайте скажу. Я дуже рада, я дуже счастлива, що я прошла такий довгий, длинний путь.
І це обучення, я вам неоднократно писала, превзошло всі мої ожидання.
То есть по тому, як вся команда топить за студентів, якась база спеціалістів, преподавателів.
Тобто, що ви дали і кого ви дали, вони були більше заинтересовані в нас, в нашому рості, в нашому успіхі і це невероятна підтримка, пушті.
Я виходжу з такою дуже великою уверенністью.
Ви помните, у мене я не було, у мене був самозванець, зараз зовсім іншого стану.
Я, знаєте, вот эта фраза, як «Атлант расправил плечи», я выхожу довольна, счастлива, чувствую себя экспертом, жду вже, коли можна буде добавити всі ці дипломи, сертифікати.
Короче, я щастлива, я все поздавала, осталось, я вже, був щучить такой стресс, мені хотілося вже все здати і віддохнути.
Я рада, що все це сталося, я благодарю вас за все, за чудесних людей, которых тоже я здесь встретила, то есть неимоверно.
Вистина, мене касательно вас, ведіть соціальні сети активно, з верою в себе, оно все имеет накопительний потенціал.
Просто не сомневайтесь, не сомневайтесь, не сомневайтесь, не смотрите на количество подписчиков, отучите себя от этого, не служите подписчикам, не служите количеству, служите качеству, а качество
всегда придет, а качество потом и перебьет количество, вот в чем парадокс, в качестве денег, в качестве клиента и так далее.
і я смотрела, вчора хто-то делав стольку у Слади Березянської,
до вас пройдуть ваші клієнти, ваші, самі ваші, не чужі, самі ті, хто будуть вас обирати,
тому у вас ще невероятна внешність, невероятна подача,
тому этим не пользоваться грех, просто щоб ви це себе знали.
Кристина, здесь точно вперед.
Благодарю.
Не за що.
Як ви, хороші мои?
Уляночка.
Добрый день, всіх вітаю.
Мені б дуже хотілося, знаєте, чим поділитися?
Я годину тому робила останній анамнез для дипломної роботи
і відловила себе на такій штуці.
Відкрила перший анамнез і четвертий.
І така читаю перший, думаю, блін, щось не те, треба переписати.
Тобто оце включилося, щось не те, перероблюємо, начебто це погано.
Але потім, чого в мене не було у все мого життя,
я зупинилася і сказала, ні, то не погано.
то добре, то було добре, тому що я по цьому анамнезу бачу вже свій прогрес.
Як я нащупую, як працювати, що питати, як питати.
Тобто, це навичка не знецінювати свій досвід.
Те, що ви нам казали на початку, не знецінюйте свій досвід, а пишатися їм.
Раніше цього не було, а саме в академії з викладачами, сокурсниками я почала ось це собі забирати і думаю, так, не ідеально, але переписувати не буду. Відправлю, так і є.
Не потрібно переписувати. І ми у цілому не про в'язницю. Ви ж зрозумієте. І у вас такий авторський почерк, такий авторський стиль у кожному. І наша задача – підсвітити стиль ваш, який буде відрізняти
ся від всіх.
Але при цьому дати ось ці рамки екологічності, це потрібно. Ви навіть до слова екологія всі, всі відноситися по-різному, навіть не зважаючи на те, що перша сесія була про екологію, перші модулі, перш
і, другі модулі, вони дуже сильно були про екологію.
від Худякова, від Девлади, від Лани, ми дуже багато говорили про екологію, але навіть екологія, це різне, тому ваша задача знайти свій авторський почерк, не забувати про бажаність психологічної вищої
освіти, це бажаність, це не обов'язково для коуча, але я все одно буду говорити, що це бажано, бо це ваша безпека на майбутнє, це чий безпека, але у цілому не переписуйте, пишайтеся,
Ви навіть можете у четвертому написати, дописати. Я знаю по скріптам додати, бо ми тут читаємо, ми дійсно читаємо, ми не ті викладачі, які не читають. Тобто ми вчитуємося. Тому ви можете написати,
дописати. Юлі, Настя, хто буде читати. Дивіться, перший, я розумію, що він гірший, ніж четвертий, але подивіться на динаміку, як я росла і навіть дивилася на це.
Це вже буде, я рефлексую на свою роботу і бачу. Я спеціально їх не переписала, бо дала собі можливість це підтвердити.
Дайте це, ви навіть коли робите це, це вже камін'аут. Наша ж задача була тут, я не хочу, щоб цей рік він був про коучинг і менторство.
Це було вторичною KPI вигадою цього проєкту. Для мене була історія збудувати лідерів, лідерська програма, підтримки себе, підтримки своїх навичків, ефективної комунікації. У вас тут така кількість
навичок, яку ви пройшли, це дуже сильна школа, яку ми не отримуємо, коли ми діти чи юнаки, коли ми можемо отримати її, коли ми дорослішуємо і подивитися, як ми функціонуємо, як один живий організм і
як ми впливаємо один на одного.
Тому тут дякую за фідбек, це вже є терапевтична така історія. Це класно.
Дякую, дуже дякую. Вась, говори вже.
Так, дякую. Державна робота, вона є державною роботою.
Дивись, ну найперше дуже дякую. Я оправдав свої всі очікування на 1 мільярд відсотків.
І прям, знаєте, можливо, вже записував тобі в дірект фразу.
Ти прямо казала, коли була оцей зідзвон 15-ти чи 30-ти хвилинний, казала, ну ти подивись, гроші тут будуть в кінці, ось типу, бо я так зразу, що віду МСММ і зразу будуть гроші, так?
В принципі, в мене гроші з'являлися поступово і завдяки МСММ і не тільки, ось, але зараз в кінці, типу, давай починай говорити людям фразу на землю, гроші будуть зразу, тоді вони зразу і притягнутим
уть гроші, тобто, якби ти сказали швидше, ну це так іронія, але тому для мене це кайфове навчання.
Дуже так цікаво. Поки ти не говорила
про прокшку, мені хотілося тебе
попросити, щоб
врахувати фактор, що дослідити
МЧП під час навчання
МСММ мені особисто
було нереально.
Тому мені, якби я не йшов далі в про,
для прикладу, мені було б цінно мати
ще якийсь час доступ
до МЧП,
щоб дослідити. Друге, ти говориш,
що щось, чуть-чуть
з МЧП ти ще не взяла, ідіть
МЧП тут дивляйтесь.
Я кожний раз написала
там, Аліна, вам список того,
що ми не проходили, але там вже
нема технік, там дуже цікаві
смислові конструкти, які ви можете
використовувати, бо все одно
я актер розговорного жанру.
Та нужно понимати, що я дуже добре працюю
з інформацією, яка актуальна людям,
яка така подобається.
Тому там можете дуже багато
виписувати
обертів,
сенсів, того, що можна
Тому це можна. Дивись, стосовно МЧП, скоріш за все, ні. Тут я дам одразу відповідь. Чому? Тому що це і є ще одна плюшка для прошки. Тому річна програма коштує теж 900 доларів, якщо рік. Тому це і є.
Прошки отримують і хаб, і це, і це, і це. Тобто сама вартість прошки закриває декілька продуктів і так далі. Тому це і є цінність.
І по суті МЧП ми ж теж дарували, ми теж дарували студентам, як і ось цей продукт хабу, для нас це було дуже важливо дати ще більше, тут вже хто вивозить, хто не вивозить, але це, скоріше за все, буде
всією вишинкою для Порошок, чому їм це робити, бо якщо ми звідси це витякуємо, ну розумієш, а навіщо тоді про?
Дивись, ти ж не почула основну фразу, поки я не почув пропозиції про.
Далі, коли я побачив пропозицію ПРО, я просто тобі озвучив, що мені без ПРО би хотілося. Ціна ПРО мене задовільнила, я готовий оплатити вже, тільки не всю суму, з задоволенням, я з руками і ногами
готовий йти.
А після вашого завершення? Дивіться, це прямо стартує тільки після, на дату вашого завершення. Вам ще рано, ви ще в процесі.
Окей, дуже випускний би хотілося, хотілося б, щоб був вибір дат, ви то, в принципі, це і сказали, щоб це, ну, я готовий тільки вибір, дата співпадає, зразу кидати завдаток, зразу грати в цю гру, і
такий один маленький фідбек, який, в принципі, для мене був, вийшов дискомфортним в цьому навчанні,
Я, в принципі, це вчора, не вчора, а після вчора, чи коли там була влада, я їй це сказав.
Влада класно дала відповідь, пояснила і т.д. і т.п.
Ну, тобто, ситуаційна задача яка?
У нас є одна інструкційка, яку нам скидають по транзакційному аналізу, загальну, так?
І влада по зовсім іншій презентації на відсотків 40 наповненіші веде саму презу.
І щоб нам залишити собі документальну презу, нам не то, щоб потрібно бути включеним тут в процес, а встигати робити скрін цієї прези.
Мені це було максимально некомфортно. Я розумію, чому Влада це робить. Вона дає більше для тих, хто є онлайн.
І вона мені це і відповіла. Тобто, що вона заставляє нас більше писати, більше цей.
Але чотири дня підряд сидіти в системі писати – це розйог мозку.
І для прикладу, теж мій фідбек, останні чотири, напевне, модулі, я після ТА коучинг просто хотів прогуляти, просто піти в сауну, вилежатись.
Тому що ТА настільки працює над головою, що знаю, що часу нема, але після нього б нічого не хотілося.
Це мій фідбек і Влада цим і пояснила, що тоді вона стимулює нас більше бути включно, більше брати це.
Це такий дискомфорт, який в мене був. Я розумію, у владині там трошки будуть і права, як індивідуальна, я забув, авторські права і все решта. Але це фактор, який з тобою ділюється просто як факт.
Дивіться, це як в академії будь-якій. Є викладачі з різними характерами, з різною подачою, з різними сенсами, темпами, конфліктністю, лояльністю. Вони ж розкриваються теж тільки упродовж року, не пер
шого місяця, не третього навіть. Тобто тільки коли витоку.
І влада сильний спеціаліст, сильний транзактний аналітик, вона практик з дуже величезним досвідом і дуже складними кейсами з БООНКО.
Ну, тобто в неї дійсно дуже сильні кейси. Є такі, які вона витягувала, які захоплюють до мурах.
Але тут історія про те, що в неї є стиль, як і у будь-якого викладача.
Тому ми можемо, ми ж допомагаємо з презентаціями, але ми не можемо змусити людину говорити по презентації, так? Тобто це вже її, тим паче вона відповіла.
Ні-ні-ні, питання інше, питання чуть інше, дивись, нам скинули методичку, а вона по іншій презентації вела, глибшій, і нема доступу до цієї.
Я, в принципі, для мене відповідь закрита. Вона відповіла професійно, піддертися неможливо, це її стиль.
Тут історія про те, що у вас є ще рік на записи від влади також, і якщо ви розумієте, що якісь факультативи ви пропустили,
ви спокійно собі берете і передивлюєтеся, бо ось ця база, вона залишається у кожного випускника.
Тому у вас є база додивитися, просто зробіть це у своєму темпі для того, щоб не втратити.
Тим паче, ви ще отримуєте від транзактного аналізу теж оцей сертифікат, скільки годин ви транзактного відвчилися, і це теж документ повністю для транзактної школи, якщо будете йти поступати тоді, він
дуже вагомий, там буде мати значення при захисті і так далі через 4 роки. Тому, якщо захочете, можете туди йти.
Але у цілому потрібно розуміти, що тут напрямок ось цих п'яти денок, він складний у цілому. Він про себе і говорив спочатку, що ми будемо один раз на п'ять днів, чи як вища друга освіта, понедельник,
середа, п'ятниця, вечірні години. Ми так з'їдали б ваші вечори кожен рік підряд. Це дуже багато для дорослої людини. Це неможливо, бо у кожного є сім'я і так далі.
Тому ми були змушені зробити факультативи. Я зараз взяла дві програми в Києво-Могилянке по стратегічному плануванні і по формуванні, як працюють системи, бізнес-системи, людські системи, дуже цікаві
напрямки.
І там усі навчальні модулі вихідні, п'ятниця, субота, неділя, чи субота, неділя, повні дні. Тобто все доросле навчання, воно побудовано, таке сильне дата бути.
Що ми йдемо після роботи, після дітей, ми йдемо і добираємо ось ці знання. Класно, якщо у когось там вільний графік, і він там поїхав, ой, прикольно, вихідні займов.
Для більшості це, правда, екстра досвід і зусильний для того, щоб отримати знання.
У вас є запис. В Києва-Могилянки запису нема.
У вас є запис. Рік. Не забувайте про це.
Дивись, я просто тут поділився.
Без цього я все усвідомлено розумію.
Просто те, що було. Тому для мене це кайфово.
Я все одно вмію і хочу обходити систему. Це інша вже штука.
але гра триває тому дякую за цей ахуєний рік от по-іншому я скажу це тільки початок ми почнемо
розвивати все далі і далі поїхали далі Аліночка
Я ж не можу не виговоритись, я не договорила протягом цього року, я хочу подякувати їм, я правда хочу від усього серця, від усьої душі,
Взагалі, ви знаєте, як багато навчання проходило до, і я завжди говорю про те, що такого навчання, такого підходу, такого об'єму, такої душі, як МСММ, немає ніде.
От правда, просто ніде, немає. І ваша любов кожного кладача, кожного спеціаліста, вона прям відчувається.
Вона через ваші підходи, через весь той матеріал, який нам дають, суверізій, правда, окрема любов.
Ясно, кожен вибрав собі, напевно, того спеціаліста, який більше підходив.
Але не знаю, я на кожній супровізії виходила просто з таким багажом, що це взагалі.
Ну і я не можу не сказати про внутрішні трансформації, тому що за цей рік, я чесно, я виросла значно більше,
ніж я за скільки я вчуся, скільки літератури я читаю, а це просто маса.
Але цей рік він став для мене просто таким карколомним, переломним.
Я 11 місяців після абсолютно інша людина, за що я вам безмежно буду вдячна завжди.
І далі буду вашим амбасадором, я буду завжди рекомендувати дійсно спеціалістів,
які відповідально відносяться і навіть більше тут відповідально навіть і так буде знаєте трошки
заменшено сказано я дякую вам і думаю ми йдемо далі з Богом з Богом ми йдемо усі разом далі
що я думаю дуже-дуже довгий шлях тому ми формуємо у цілому в Україні дуже сильну коучингову
спільноту менторську спільноту відношення і все одно я дійсно вірю що ось ця школа вона ж
буде набувати, ще ми допрацьовуємо,
ми допрацьовуємо, зараз ми сидимо з методологами,
що ми не добачили, що змінити і так далі.
Вона буде випускати на герунок дуже сильних фахівців,
і ця акредитація, вона буде рости у своїй базі.
Це найголовніше. Тобто, це найголовніше.
Ви будете все одно продовжувати рости,
тому головне – діть у поглиблення своїх знань і так далі.
Так, Уляночка, побачила, для якого числа буде доступ до МЧП?
Я зараз запитала у команди, коли у вас офіційне завершення і так далі.
Зараз я все відповім або відповім у чаті і стосовно дат вже написала.
Тобто я вже всі задачі паралельно, як завжди, в моменті, якщо нема проблеми, є задача, вже стоїть.
Поїхали далі, давайте попрацьовуємо трішки.
Дивіться, що я зробила на сьогодні.
Це імпровізація, вона дуже легка, але я хотіла б, щоб ви теж на неї звернули увагу.
Це метафорічні карти. Це МАК. Не обов'язково їх купляти, не обов'язково їх брати. Я їх обожню, коли якраз запити нема і чи коли вам потрібно не через медитацію, а через візуальний ряд витягнути ті чи
інші питання з людини.
І метафори, вони дійсно дуже сильно допомагають. В мене є один сайт, я просто вбиваю MacOnline, я вам дам, якщо захочете, поділюся своїм, захочете окремо, там, де є і техніки, і дуже цікаві карти, і
це, якщо ви можете і онлайн, і офлайн грати в це, чи зробити для себе вибірку якихось карт і так далі, коли людина у відкриту обирає так далі.
І дуже цікаво розкривається дуже швидко. Це як, пам'ятаєте, Сніжана давала приклад про стихії, вода, сонце, ось ця історія. Потім про метафори, пам'ятаєте, по Фреду ми робили точечка, квадратик, пол
осочка, чи по метафорам ми робили різні техніки, навіть ось ці завершення, там де було 16 букв і зробити одне, це все метафори, це все, що працює з безсвідомим і так далі.
Далі, зараз ми зробимо декілька дуже швидких технік, я просто покажу, як це може бути.
І чому це цікаво, і дуже рекомендую робити сесії цікавими.
Повірте, ваш основний інструмент – це не техніка, ваш основний інструмент – це ви.
І вам буде вистачати можливості працювати з вашими клієнтами.
По-друге, знаєш, що ви поки в одній групі користуєтесь багато людей Клодом у Юрі стосовно вашої роботи і так далі.
Якщо у вас є дозвіл від вашого клієнта, позавантажуйте, подивіться на супервізорів, як ви працюєте, який бік ви забуваєте.
Це теж розширює бачення. Дуже велика рекомендація.
Сьогодні я працювала з Дзен-проєктом, з істрочниками, вони роблять епку.
Я говорю, ви робили Дзен-мудреця на основі чату GPT, а зараз штучний інтелект і агенти.
Ви, говорю, втратили можливість, вам потрібно було рік тому його завершити і віддати ринку.
Зараз потрібно перероблювати.
Тому на ринку з'являється велика кількість інструментів.
Не нехтуйте штучним інтелектом, дуже швидко йдуть зміни у всіх напрямках.
Я знаю, що технічна база для коучів зазвичай не дуже приємна,
бо вона більш складна і не хочеться в неї лізти.
Але повірте, все, що стосується цифровізації, воно буде наступати на п'ятки.
Те, як розвиваються епки, те, що відбувається на європейському і американському ринку,
ну дуже сильна течія.
Тобто навіть клод, як він вірвався зараз у все.
І плюс, я кайфанула навіть при своєму досвіді від супервізорів,
які аналізували, на який бік подивитися, що я втратила як елемент,
чому я пішла у маму, можна було додати тата і так далі.
Тому розширюйте все це на навчання, це не на те, щоб користуватися чимось,
щоб потім не працювати і не думати.
Навпаки, розширюйте базу прикладів у своєму житті.
Далі, метафорічні картки, це не про вгадай зміст картинки,
Ви не інтерпретуєте карту, ви чуєте людину, крізь неї карта – це проекція психіки.
Ви не інтерпретуєте картки, які ви даєте, і зараз ми про це поговоримо.
Я прослухав, ти рекомендувала якісь скіли супервізорів, тобто аналізу сесій.
Я казала, що я у Юри взяла, ми дивимося зараз у Клоді, завантажила декілька сесій
І запросила супервізорів з різних підходів, де можна було подивитися на мою сесію, подивитися, на що я зробила більший акцент. І я насправді за останні два тижні зробила ще більшу еволюцію у своєму
консультуванні, ніж раніше була, за рахунок того, що я почала бачити себе зі сторони.
Бо для мене зараз піти до супервізора, я ходжу, але мені рідко, у мене є там дві людини, котрих я капець, як поважаю, хто може мене розібрати, але там і ціна така, яку я дуже сильно поважаю, але у ц
ілому мені іноді не вистачає дуже багато суб'єктивного досвіду, в мене теж він дуже великий.
І тут я отримала настільки, я думаю, я говорю, проаналізую, як Іцкаха Адізіс, проаналізую, як той, проаналізую, як психоаналітик такий та такий, проаналізую, як Віктор Ялом, проаналізую на базі того.
І я отримала декілька супервізійну базу різних підходів, щоб отримати себе. Я не можу це купити у реальної людини. Тому я така, воу! І я декілька сесій зараз просто їх станула, хоча я даю дуже висок
ий результат клієнту.
Юрочка, бачиш, зараз там дуже високий результат клієнту, але так це стало для мене дуже цікавою школою подивитися ще з іншого боку, і це розширює теж навички, тому я у цілому говорю про те, що вч
иться, вчиться у будь-якій інформації, у посту в Інстаграм, якщо це написав, не знаю, Тоні Вайт, як я вам давала, пам'ятаєте техніку в Фейсбуці, він просто виставив свої пісюльки-етруків, ну то есть
все.
тобто ви знаходите інформацію будь-де, будьте учнями у будь-якій ситуації. Юр, давай.
Я трошки поясню, стосовно Клоду, там справа, чому він так добре розуміє.
Те, що я казав, що ти ставиш мозок людині, він дуже добре розуміє Юлю, тому що я згодував її книжки, її підходи і так далі.
Настрою підходи, що він розуміє все, що вона хоче, і будь-який запит, який вона дає,
оце магічний промт, що ви казали, що супертішкі промти.
не треба супертяжких промтів, коли він розуміє вас як особистісті.
От якраз оце я зробив, що він дуже добре розуміє Юлі як особистість і може видавати з її контексту відповіді, які вона хоче бачити.
От, так як вчора ви бачили на ораторському, що я сів просто за 2,5 години і опакував по факту експерта з нуля.
Тут того використовуйте, точно це користуйтеся, але моя вам щира рекомендація – персоналізуйте його під себе,
А тоді потребуєте неймовірне підсилення.
От, всім рекомендую.
Дуже дякую, Юлі, за фідбак. Дуже приємно чути.
Ну, там ми з тобою ще працюємо на цієї теми,
але в цілому це дає дуже сильний фідбак теж того, чого не було.
Тобто побачити якусь точку зору.
Бо чат GPT, він аналізує теж історію.
Дам свою фізку, якщо це подобається чи не подобається.
Але, коли йде, наприклад, консультація, а вже ж ми запитуємо, особливо там, де ваші є хлопці, дівчата, з ким ви дуже давно і так далі,
коли людина розповідає кейсь кейс, у чаті GPT, якщо він вже напрацьований з вами, ви ставите голосове, він слухає, слухає, слухає,
ви зупиняєте ваш діалог через 10 хвилин, він теж дає аналітику слабких і сильних місць, бо він вже навчаний в вашій системі.
Тому у цілому користування, розширення бази – це теж дуже цікавий елемент.
Я не можу це рекомендувати, бо це полегшення, коли нема навички,
це полегшення своєї роботи, ви ж розумієте.
А ще буде хтось хітрити і не запитувати дозвіл.
Але у цілому ви і можете це робити.
Більш того, так дійсно, Сніжана сказала про екологію, це класна історія.
Запитайте обов'язково, більш того, якщо вам потрібно.
Ми розробили зараз дуже сильною командою юристів контракти, які ми даємо на підписання,
контракти, які ми даємо перед тим, як ми даємо отзиви, контракти на те, як виплачуються і так далі.
Тобто, ми дуже сильно розробили юридичну базу стосовно мене, якщо потрібно, я дам усі рибки.
Якщо потрібно, може взяти, у мене прямо, ну, ми платимо багато за юрсопровождення, тому якщо потрібно напущити задачу.
Дадо, не надо вам це? Дадь?
Одну секунду. Тоді я одразу говорю.
Ребята, юридичні договори моїх, підписані з клієнтом, і на отзіви.
І які є ще у мене договора, які ми зараз создали по оплатам, по всьому, що ми делаємо касательно клієнтів. Дайте всі рыбки студентам МСММ, першому потоку. Пожалуйста, і відпишіться, коли далі. Там
дуже сильна база, тому ви можете брати, допрацювати зі своїми юристами, це буде все одно дешевше, ніж писати заново. Але у цілому прочитайте все, там дуже адекватно абсолютно все.
Це нехай буде теж. Стосовно клода і всього іншого, там просто цікаво те, що ви дійсно можете допрацювати оцей вау-ефект вашому клієнту.
Ви можете допрацювати голосовим п'ятихвилинку, про що була сесія. Ви можете допрацювати слайдами те, що він розповідав.
Ви можете допрацювати основні інсайти. Ви можете дати мініфільм. Ви можете дати все.
І ось ця історія вже ж різним клієнтам комусь це потрібно, а для когось це прям такий супровід.
А вже ж Україна дуже заширене в клієнторієнтованості і навіть десь це занадто.
Не обов'язково це робити. Головне, щоб вас поважали і вашу силу поважали. Ось це головна мета.
Але в цілому, розумієте, що в залежності від вашої творчості також і включеності в професію,
ви теж запускаєте дуже сильне сарафанне радіо.
Коли люди не проходять, я був там, я був там, а тут нічого собі.
Як Аліна говорить, я була там на навчанні, там на навчанні, але тут.
І все. І вона ще буде говорити і далі, і далі, і далі.
Все. Ось тут та історія, яка показує вас, і вона буде передаватися у цей захвит і так далі.
Так, любі мої, до якого числа буде доступ до МЧП?
6.06. у вас буде останній екзамен, тому ще місяць ми даємо на МЧП,
я зараз вже написала, тобто у вас місяць після останнього екзамену
навіть буде вільний на МЧП, дивіться спокійно, вам там вистачить часу.
Добре? Це на всяк випадок.
З 6.06, 7.06, ні, не хочу 7.06, 7.06, давайте з 10.06 відкриється МЧП MCMM Pro.
Десяте просто з число фарта, пусть буде десяточка у нас.
Все, це Юлія і астрологія. Я не вірю, але буде десятого.
Все, що стосується випускного, то в нас будуть дати на всяк випадок.
Теж проговорю. Буде п'ятого, шостого варіант червня.
Буде дванадцятого, тринадцятого.
Ну, скоріше за все, ми будемо брати п'ятницю.
Буде 19-20-го, це тоді, коли ми зможемо зробити.
Ось ці три дати ми дамо, по одній даті дамо, і там будемо обирати.
У вільній проголосуйте ті, хто збирається бути.
Головне, щоб ми обирали.
По більшості будемо обирати без яких компромісів.
Там, де буде більше плюсиків за добу, за дві, там ми і будемо.
Так буде чесно.
Не ми обираємо, дамо можливість.
Тому що в липні починається наступний потік.
Там вже буде неактуальна. Тобто ми відпразднуємо, як завершується наша навчальна програма, красиво зробимо.
Так, поїхали. Поїхали у карти МАК. Для мене вони не примітивна історія, скажу так, хоча їх дуже сильно об'яснюють.
Чому? Тому що в нас велика кількість спеціалістів могли бути не психологами, але спеціалістами МАК.
А вже ж, коли був бум на це, це визивало у психотерапевта дуже велику кількість запитань, тобто тут імпровізації дуже багато, і а вже ж, так, багато людей, хто міг, ну, на жаль, апашліть, да, ну, тоб
то, а коли ви накладаєте мак на цю базу, то вже ж це, вау, це цілий світ.
І людина, що вона дає? Відключити контролера, вона починає все одно і прийдеться фантазувати. Вона дає можливість комунікувати. Якщо є карти, кайфові, так, але якщо ви користуєтеся картами, обов'яз
ково купіть 3-4 колоди з різними сенсами, тобто різні картки.
Можна робити це через коротки в звичайному онлайні? Так, мені подобається. Алін, вийшли до силочку на карти МАК?
Більше того, ми зробимо МАК сильні у ТЕІ. Я зараз поставлю задачу, ми це теж підхватимо. Алін, напиши мені в лічній сообщення МАК ТЕІ.
до курсу Дару електронні картки так і так далі і зараз ми зробимо просто декілька трансляцій
дивіться тут є три різні колоди і там три рандомні картки з різних колод перший момент
зараз ми робимо аналіз без запиту це дуже швидкий експрес хто зі мною хоче попрацювати
Я.
Так, Оля там була перша. Поднімала ручку, Оля?
Да.
А чого молча? Ти вирішила молча, щоб я тебе побачила?
Це я живе побачила, опустилася случайно вниз і побачила руку.
Так, у мене ж высвечується тільки верхня полоска,
тому що в мене дуже великий екран слайдів.
Тому дивіться, там, де хтось хоче, голос повинен проявлятися.
Добре? Проявленість – це голос.
Хто сказав «я» в другий?
Я сказав.
Юр, тоді на другу колоду, дивимося, як вона буде про шлях і відносини. Ти хочеш про відносини чи про шлях?
Як випаде, як Боженка зверху казав.
Ні, ти скажи, куди б ти хотів.
Я? У мене дуже трагеріться там відносин.
Тобто ти про відносини. Хто третій буде? Хто хоче?
Я.
Все. Хто кричит проявлення звуку? Кристина, де голос? Дивіться, ось цей момент...
Ні, сміріть, ось цей момент, ось цей момент, він же теж показує, як у житті.
Да, ось це я, проявитися.
Я вам зараз, перед тим, як ми підемо, зараз включу іншу демонстрацію екрану.
Я вчора виступала, просто покажу вам, що таке голос.
А ну, зараз одну хвилинку, буде експромт, але це займе 5-7 хвилин.
Так, Бронюшевська, Артем, Артем, одну хвилину, одну хвилину.
Так, Любі Майя, а видно цю презентацію там, де я зараз в чорному одягнула чи ні? Видно? Поїхали.
Так, на всяк випадок. Зараз воно завантажиться. Так. Все, поїхали.
Вася, в тебе звук чути.
Дивіться, дуже швидко, але подивіться, що таке голос. Голос – це не звук, це право займати місце. Більші жінок не мовчають, вони говорять нижче свого рівня, м'якіше, ніж думають, зручніше, ніж відпов
ідають, безпечніше, ніж можуть.
І в цей момент відбувається ключове. Ви не втрачаєте голос, ви втрачаєте масштаб. Голос – це завжди про владу, не зовнішню, а внутрішню. Це точка, де ви вирішуєте, я зараз проявлю себе повністю чи з
алишусь прийнятою. Дивіться далі. А ось правда, яку мало хто витримує.
Вас не чують не тому, що світ жорсткий, вас не чують, бо ви самі себе зменшуєте до формату, який не тригерить. Вискаківець, постійна мія, можуть вискачки, але їх все одно бачить частіше, навіть якщо
вони тригерають. А те, що не тригерить, не впливає.
І ми повинні визивати або симпатію, або іноді супротив, і це нормально. Але якщо ми не визиваємо жодних емоцій, нас у цілому не помічають. Нас у цілому не помічають. Голос – це не про сказати, це про
витримати наслідки того, що ви сказали. Що за мене подумають? А що буде? І так далі.
Бо як тільки ви починаєте говорити по-справжньому, частина людей відпадає, частина починає опиратись, частина починає вас бачити. І саме тут починається реалізація. Не тоді, коли всі вас люблять, а т
оді, коли ви перестаєте себе редагувати. Гроші, вплив, масштаб приходять не до тих, хто глибокий, а до тих, хто достатньо сміливий бути ким почутим.
Де ви досі говорите обережно, щоб не втратити любов? І в цей момент ви завжди втрачаєте себе. Втратити любов – це не обов'язково провідносини. Втратити симпатію групи, втратити симпатію підписчиків.
Втратити, втратити. Проявленість – це надія, це точка неповернення.
Всі думають, що проявленість – це сторіс, думка, запуск. Ні, це поверхня. Проявленість – це момент, коли ви перестаєте мати можливість повернутися в стару версію себе. Бо як тільки би реально прояв
илось, ви не можете зробити вигляд, що вас не стосується, ви не можете жити нижче того, що ви сказали, ви не можете зменшити себе без внутрішнього конфлікту. І ось чому більшість не проявляється не
через страх камери, а через страх наслідків. Ось так.
Бо все це завжди про нову відповідальність.
Все завжди про відповідальність.
Все, поїхали до презентації. Тут корисно було?
Дуже подобається. А можна цю презентацію скинути?
Можемо всю презентацію.
Юль, Алін, хто сьогодні мене керує, напишіть Артему.
Презентація для Бронішевської. Скинуть в чат.
Ребята.
Так, напишу зараз.
Так, далі. Я зараз роблю презентацію нашої з вами карток.
Йдемо, йдемо. Аліна, Аліна, Аліна, Аліна, Аліна.
А, так, вибачте, затримку викинула.
Так, поїхали. Олічка!
Я здесь?
Так, все, поїхали.
Бачите на всяк випадок?
Чи не бачите?
Поділіться. Ні, не бачу, бачу. Все, а ось так бачите?
Да.
Це, поїхали. Оль, тут історія не про запит, тут історія просто про картки.
Тут є три колоди і є по три просто рандомні картки на кожній сторінці, щоб був вибір.
Тут не історія про обов'язковість, просто щоб був вибір.
Подивіться, що вам подобається тут більше.
Ось це перша, ось це друга, ось це третя.
Так, а можна вторую ще раз?
Можна, любую, спокійненько на своєм темпі.
Юлечка, висылайте в общу групу все підборки по три карти і повністю слайди з вопросами.
І першу ще раз.
Так, любі мої, ви не робите зараз, ви просто дивитеся, добре? Дайте 5 хвилинок, це дуже швидкі штуки. Все, Ольчик, дивіться.
Так, ось цю, якорь, якорь моря.
Все, давайте ось цю беремо, ви дивитеся саме на неї, вона більш близька до вас і так далі.
Йоль, киньте, пожалуйста, Олі, прям эту карту отдельно, щоб вона була перед глазками, а я буду задавати вопрос.
Я в чатах буду все надсилати.
Давай, все, кинь зараз у Чачів, вона була у Олі перед очим.
Ольчик, скажіть, будь ласка, коли буде.
Поки не віжу.
Єсть.
Все, поїхали.
Ви просто дивитесь на картку, щоб не відволікатися,
бо перед очим усі ми, то занадто багато людей.
Тепер давайте, що ви бачите перед очима?
Віжу розсвіт.
Це, скоріше, літа чи вісна, багато трави, спокійне море,
Увесістий такий якорь на берегу, і що віжу? Віжу на берегу камні, скоріше всього.
Імі усыпан не весь берег, але частично є. І землю.
Клас! Що вас зачепило на цій карці?
Безумно красивий розсвіт, хоча я зараз думаю, може бути закат, але ні, тобто буде розсвіт.
І трава і море.
Ось ця совмістна композиція.
Клас. Де ви на цій картині?
Мені потрібно об'єкт вибрати.
Не можу нічого сказати. Ви можете робити те, що ви хочете.
Думаю, що я плаваю в морі.
Думаю, що відбувається далі?
Думаю, що я довго плаваю, лежу на спині.
Дожідаюсь, пока солнце не взайдет, і вихожу на берег, отдыхаю на траві, може, додаю якийсь віночок з цвітов. Тут я вижу, що є якісь цветочки, скоріше всіло.
Добре. Хто головний герой на цій картині?
Я.
Че тут зайва? Красиво глаза ушли, но уверена в возвращении к себе.
А хто тут зайва? Че тут зайва? Че тут зайва? На карте.
Все цельное, я бы ничего не убирала.
Класс. Че ти бачиваєш у цій ролі?
Легкость, свободу і наслаждення від жизни.
Що буде далі, якщо нічого не змінювати?
Я погрузну наслаждіння.
Добре. А якщо ти зміниш хоча б один елемент, то що буде?
А можна додати, а не вбрати?
Можна, можна.
Я б додавила елемент своєї реалізації і проявленності в цю картинку.
Яким предметом це могло б туди додатися?
Бо там якір, сонце і так далі.
Тому що б там з'явилося?
Дуб, огромний, розкатистий, розвесистий дуб.
А тепер дивіться на цю картину, уявляєте, що там є дуб, нова версія цієї картини вам підходить?
Я б ще корабель поставила, додавила.
Давайте, додавайте корабель, давайте, додавайте корабель.
Тепер.
Тепер мене дуже все подобається.
Причем корабль я ж неспроста добавила,
мне його дійсно дуже не хватало.
Корабль у мене ассоціїрується
как раз с семейной исторією
і с бизнесом, який є зараз.
Дуб теж.
У колективному босвідомому це
сім'я, корони, столб, це найсамий
Мощний символ із всіх деревьків, які символизують рот на всякий случай.
Поэтому і рот теж про сем'ю у колективному безвідомому.
Що у житті символизує корабль і що у житті символизує дуб?
Корабль у мене символизує продовольствие, сырье.
Це те, з чого можна створювати продукт.
Це база, скажімо так, для бізнесу.
А ДОП символізує...
Для мене ДОП символізує якусь таку огромну укорінену любов.
А тепер дивіться, переходимо у життя, у реальне життя.
Щоб ви додали укорінену любов і ресурсність,
як ви думаєте, якими діями у своєму житті
ви могли б додати сили тому, що вже існує,
але по цим двом векторам, через реальні дії?
І по любві, і по ресурсу.
Це як два різних питання.
Ресурс, так, правильно, вилетіла своє ресурс.
Мені щось дуже складно щось сказати, тому що все, що я додаю в системі сімейної, я вже додаю на максимум.
Тоді подивіться ще раз на цю картку і подумайте, що ці два елементи,
це ті елементи, яких не вистачало саме на цій картці, бо вони є в житті,
чи це ті елементи, які потрібно додати у житті?
На цій картці.
Там було сказано тільки одна ще фраза, за яку я ще могла б зачепитися.
я б додала б реалізацію, пам'ятаєте, до щодо і до корабля.
Тепер це питання про носу життя, я б додала б реалізацію.
Потрібно щось додавати у житті до цього елементу, це ж дуже велика,
це ж не якась лінія з відповідом, це якийсь елемент,
огромна проявленість в житті, лінія житті.
Чи потрібно щось вже додати, що зараз не сильно додаєте?
По стопроценту, да, нужно.
Саме минимальне действие,
вот саме минимальне действие,
какое вы можете сделать в этом направлении.
Ну, я б могла сказати, що там щось опублікувати в інстаграм,
але це взагалі мені не лжиться на сьогодні.
Не потрібно брати те, що не лжиться, але потрібно те, що лжиться.
На конференції додати в своє виступлення завуаліроване пропонання у коуч-сесіях.
А тепер я хотіла би запитати два питання. Чому завуалірована?
Классний вопрос. Могу напрямую.
Можете напрямую.
Вот и все. У вас западна реализация,
которую вы скрыли под деревом и ресурсностью,
которая уже существует система,
а вы действительно ресурсная семья и сильный род,
и в котором вы развиваетесь.
Соответственно, это оп и увело вас тут реализация.
Реализация, есть запрос внутренней системы.
Просто обратите, можно напрямую.
А второй момент. Я бы добавила, если позволите сказать, можно?
Да.
Я би добавила, що ви ще співвласник Мастер Хаба з Юлією Козачковою в партнерстві по Віктору Ялому.
І відкрила би ці карти теж відкриті.
Дякую.
Це для всієї групи про те, що ми підтримуємо всіх.
Усіма різні відносини, але все, де і ми де можемо, ми знаходимо для себе користь і для вас користь.
Тому це теж у позиціонуванні, Оль, це дуже красиве позиціонування.
І це теж, з чого ви достигли за год.
Ми поки що, з цим говоримо, непробудкова організація, дуже мінусова організація по цьому проєкту.
Поки або з Віктором Яломом пишатися тут мало чим, але ми тільки завели це на український ринок,
тому вже потрібен час, десь з рік-півтори, поки ми це розкачаємо, але ми до цього готові, ми це вміємо робити степ-без степ.
Але для підсилення ще й чому вас обрати, мене вже обрали, я вже є, я вже партнер, я вже спікер, в мене є вже база.
Тому тут не про завуальовано, це дійсно про дуже відкритий модель.
Ось так, тепер дивіться, тут просто звичайна картка, вона пішла у дуже ресурсний стан, тобто в неї не було проблеми,
бо зазвичай у людей більш швидше вийде щось, і так далі.
Але все одно, навіть у гіперресурсній системі,
вона все одно знайшла свою відповідь з картки, яку має.
Як зараз відчуття?
До мене розриваєт внутрі.
Все, перший імпульс, він дійсно, я б додала реалізацію проявленість.
Це з'явилося те, що з'явилося без інтерпретації, без нічого.
Ми пішли у ресурс, а він вже є.
Тобто, ми пішли у любов, а вона вже є.
Тому це цікаво, що навіть коли ви пішли у дію,
інстаграм теж не ліг.
Тобто, система не хоче ще одного публічного навантаження.
Але ціло дало іншу відповідь.
Конференція плюс м'яка інтеграція коучингу.
Але вона може бути більш активна.
Більш активна, бо в ній буде більше нового масштабу.
І це ще буде про ваш каміннаут також. А це завжди дає, це высвобождение от теневой части, да, ще, хороші, девочки, я часть системы, или я уже отдельно сепарированная личності? Здесь гораздо більше см
ыслу. Ну, якщо вже ми коснулись, здесь гораздо більше мыслей. На всякий случай, интересно було бачити, що ви смотрите на карту, де ржавий якорь, а ви видите море.
Море в символізмі означає свобода, дуб — любов, корабль — реалізацію, світанок — це новий цікл.
Очень інтересні смісли, які зрозуміли ви.
А це все про те, що не треба вибирати між любов'ю і проявленностю.
Расцвет — нова ера, новий виток, і вона закладається наперед.
Все.
Можна і береги море, і корабль однічастно.
Понравилось?
Спасибо. Невероятно понравилось. Раз.
Во-вторых, я не можу описати це чувство,
але чувство таке, як будто вот цей масштаб,
я вже його почувствовала внутри просто от цієї техніки.
І як будто моєго тело зараз мало мене розширяє.
Юль, і мені ще хочеться сказати огромне спасибо за цей год обучення.
У мене було мало обучений в житті, які я закінчила.
в силу того, що я всегда вибирала бізнес.
Але з тим, яка була нагрузка, який був об'єм.
І у нас пістояно ще производство страдало, нас обстреливали.
Було дуже тяжело морально.
Але настільки интересно, стільки глибокій інформації,
стільки трансформаційної інформації,
що не було навіть мисли бросити.
В якийсь момент була така маленька,
Але це невероятно. Дякую вам багато.
Це все, це все серце моє хорошее.
Так, все, тут все, слава Богу.
Любимі, можете написати зворотний зв'язок,
але ми зробимо ще 2 маленькі по 4-5 питання
швидкої інтерпрітації.
Мась, ти говорив, писав, говори.
Дуб, оці всі інтерпрітації.
Ти вже загугла в чат GPT чи вже настільки в тебе
в голові сидять асоціації?
Тобто, Боже, як це називається, СМЛ-драма в голові, що ти висі СМЛ-насі ти знаєш.
Я вже закінчувала СМЛ-драму і їй все рано посвятила три роки, тому це прямо старе і старе ще знання.
І коли дуже довго роботи, я не знаю багато, але море, дуб – це колективні такі штуки. Скільки техник метафоричних – тільки на дуб.
Или тільки на воду. Вода – це емоційний інтелект, це зв'язок з мамою.
От ручейка можна відслідовувати морю, куди впадає і як проходит вода. Частота води определяє емоціональну связь з оральною фіксацією.
Тобто є просто такі прямо гора, ви знаєте, фаличний символ. Смотря, яка гора, но чаще всего це досіження ціли.
Тобто є прямо дуже звісні історії, по цілях я ще добре розбираюся, але це, повірте мені, не найбільше.
Тобто, якщо хтось рисує рисунок, я сяду гуглити і дивитися.
Ти прям говорила, по моїх відчуттях, ніби ти прочитала чат GPT і відповідаєш в стилі чату GPT, і це прям так, коли твій стиль вийшов, вийшов такий, який би видав чат GPT. Твоя глибина, тому мені було
цікаво, бо Мак теж люблю, кажу, Мак – це найпростіший спосіб залетіти на ринок, це я стартував колись, але це вже про інші. Дякую.
Це 5-10 хвилинок, це дуже маленьке. Вона отримує якесь розширення, а вже моває по-різному, хтось може бути у травмі. Далі я покажу слайд, де МАК використовувати не потрібно. Навіть зараз покажу.
Не використовувати кризові стани. Гостра травма – ні. Психіатричні діагнози – ні.
Чому? Потому що вони там будуть війти дыру. Туди не можна. І всім драму не можна.
Там дуже потрібно обережно. Ще й виводити дуже сильно. І не закривати очі.
Тобто тут дуже потрібно обережно. І коли клієнта потрібна жорстка структура, а не образи.
Це теж може бути не зовсім коректно, бо він буде розмазуватися.
Інфантильні дівчата, вони будуть, ой, я тут бачу і бачу, їм буде там добре, дуже, але це не буде структурно сильною одиницею, що саме вони роблять.
Тому там є моменти. Але де працює? Відсутність чіткого запиту, тривогою, гіперконтролем. Отлічна! З тривогою, гіперконтролем. У нас половина таких клієнтів.
Запитами про стосунки, про гроші, про якісь такі конкретні теми, але там потрібно брати колуди, жаленти, підходящі під відносини, щоб там була якась асоціація.
щоб там була якась асоціація поїхали у відносини тут в нас одна колода парне обрати одну карту
обирай Юро третя третя Юльчик скінь пожалуйся одразу в чат і одразу питання для всіх
нехай будуть про відносини але ми зараз підемо окремо Юрочка і як тільки будуть карти в чаті
перед тобою покажи скажи мені що можемо починати можемо все це тільки асоціації все нічого
нічого складного ми йдемо без запиту але у тему відносин да ну тобто є якийсь вектор який ти
даєш у колодах вже ж там 30 40 100 карток і так далі ми рандомно просто те що вибрало сьогодні
дитей поставили далі кроки виконання техніки так все який я у цих стосунках дивлячись на цю карту
відкритий віддалений від цього світу і просто на максимальному моменті як сказати відчуваю
Максимально красу цього моменту, незважаючи ні на що, більше з боку.
Добре. Як я бачу партнера у наших стосунках?
Так само відкритим, коли ти в моменті насладжуєшся один одним, як тут на краю обриву.
Весь світ десь позаді, ти спочатку бачиш прекрасний вид і можеш просто відчувати цей момент.
Без ніякого більше з боку навантаження.
Чого ти не бачиш у цих стосунках?
Дивлячись на цю карту також, можна на неї спиратись.
Ілюзій? У мене перше в голові.
Не знаю, просто ілюзій.
Добре. А чого ти хочеш насправді від цих стосунків?
Ну, цієї тотальної довіри один до одного, тотальної любові, тотального погруження в сенси один одного, цієї взаємодії на стику.
Це як хімія відбувається, коли один елемент з'єднується з іншим і створюється щось третє, що неможливо роз'єднати.
І воно доповнює дуже один одного.
Скажи мені, будь ласка, на попередні питання ти відповів, все, тут питань більше не буде, зараз трішки поспілкуємося, на попередні питання ти відповів, що чого ти не бачиш ілюзії, а потім ти дав зап
ит, що ти хочеш отримати, як ти думаєш, те, що ти хочеш отримати, чи є то ілюзію, чи є то дійсністю, яку ти можеш створити?
Хороше питання. Коли ти це проговорювала, десь є межа, що це ілюзія.
Тобто в силу свого якогось життєвого досвіду, мені важко повірити, що це можливо.
Скажи мені, будь ласка, коли тобі важко повірити, то це не є знання, як база, на котрій ти будуєш.
То які ризики ти отримуєш?
Коли мені важко повірити, це не є знання.
Дивись, закрутіли сильно, все, извині, мій мозк. Дивись, є в нас елемент ілюзія, є те, як я хочу. Коли я запитую, чи дійсно то є ілюзія, чи твоя спроможність це створити, ти говориш з урахуванням дос
віду, а в нас у всіх є досвід, я розумію, що тут є якась частка ілюзій.
І я запитала про те, що є тут ілюзією? У тому другій відповіді, що є реальністю, що є ілюзією?
Що б ти розмежував? Де там цей відсоток? Що тобі здається на основі свого досвіду, що це нереально?
не ті людиною який ти можеш повністю довіряти ну тотально без ризику що десь настане момент до
побачення от дивись ось ця відповідь вона дуже сильно конкурує з тим що ти хочеш отримати
Вона сильно конкуруча, бо тут єдність, поєднання, гармонія, довіра, а є знання.
Дивись, навіщо я сказала, а який є відсоток? І ти прям говориш, як віра. Тобто віра, що ось така реальність є.
І ось тут момент, наскільки ти віриш, що це можливо досягти?
Тут якраз в мене є цей внутрішній конфлікт, тому що в мене по факту було два випадки таких глибоких зв'язків,
коли я повністю довіряв людині і з'єднувався в одне ціле, називаємо це так.
І два випадки, вони дуже жорстко фейлились і мали після себе такі болючі наслідки.
І після цього мій мозк, він обережний, він зразу бачить, тут зафейлиться, тут зафейлиться, тут зафейлиться.
Я на цьому моменті просто, ну, такий, ок, все.
Ну, я приймаю, що це так і є.
І ми просто, ну, дуже багато чого аналізую, і я не даю собі відчувати ці моменти.
І цей аналіз, він, типу, доганяє мене.
Я такий, ні, давай роз'єднуватися, давай десуціатися, і воно десь виходить, але частіше ні.
Частіше ця здорова логіка, як здорова логіка, вона перемагає над відчуттям якимось.
Дивись, по суті, ми через цю картку вийшли до твоєї моделі сценарної відносин до отношення к отношеням, до можливості відносин.
І тут історія про те, що тут можна вже поглиблюватися. Звідки це? Який був досвід? Чи є в тебе рольові моделі там, де це дійсно вийшло? Це дуже важливо. Чи є пари навколо? Просто реальні історії, де
ти бачиш, що це дійсність. І якщо ні, їх потрібно знайти і створити, бо вони є. Ось в чому парадокс. Це просто твоє поле ще не дає тобі цю інформацію.
Але ти шукаєш, шукаєш, шукаєш, і чим більше ти, ну, якщо б ми йшли, навіщо нам ці картки? Бо ці картки дають нам досвід, все, все, ти почав говорити про картку, а вже вийшов у глибин терапії, ми пов
инні йти вже до тебе досередини.
Тобто ще зробила картку, вона відкрила вхід. Та не мав мене, не я, як запуті. Ну, давай поговоримо про що ти хочеш, гроші, деньги, там, отношения. Ну, давайте, гроші, у мене там є випросики к ним. Д
аєте карту, даєте 5 випросів, все, у вас відкритая книга. Заходите, куди хочете, да, ну, то сидите вглубь, человек заведет, если там є, є сейчас запрос, дефіцитарності, здесь є запрос.
Але в цілому, якщо б я говорила зараз, так як у нас немає можливості углубляти дата по випросам, якщо б я говорила як друг чи коуч і так далі, создай себе знання, що це може.
Іщу знання, де знати, подскажіть, будь ласка.
Знання, знання, сто процентів.
Ти знаєш, можна я скажу личний пример, якщо він корректен буде для вас?
Я говорю про личну свою сферу, можливо, на тебе буде интересно.
У мене завжди була встановка касательно відношений,
чи лучшее, чи ніхак.
Я завжди говорила, що в любі любой компроміс,
любой компроміс завжди заканчивається,
особливо для жінки, для мужчин, в тому числе,
болю, временем, да, там, і так далі.
Поэтому, чи лучшее, чи ніхак.
І ось це відстояне, чи я в своєм ізобілі,
чи в деньгах, можливостях, проживаю красиву життю,
і, да, не захожу в союз, тому що, ну, не мэтчутся.
Или ти ожідаєш свою жінчину, з якима цей мєч відбувається,
але при тотальному відсутті спешки.
Лучше в 60, ніж в 30, але не туди.
Особенно вовремя разводів і так далі.
Все, це наша реальність.
Тобто, коли почти половина дітей украинських, у дівочек,
виспитують не родні папи, а родних дітей.
Этих хороших пап воспитують інші папи.
Тому що розводів дуже багато, але це реальність нашого міра.
Тому питання формування знання. Знання того, що для мене лучше, а це союз, о якому ти сказав,
і це не ідеалізація. Хтось скажет із психологів, що це ідеалізація.
Я в житті завжди получала краще. Якраз тому, що ніколи не опускала планку под те, що являлась планка для многих.
І зараз получаю від мира все краще і краще дару. І мені таке відчування, що життя не зупиняється, а просто розширяється.
Тому велика рекомендація працювати з мишлением, навіть з тими людьми, у котрих є динамика фарта, в таких запросах це дуже важливо.
Ну а карта завела... Дальше, які можна... Вопроси, да, що в цій картинці для тебе є невозможним? Любовь, довері, отсутствие втраты, можливість потери і т.д. І тут можна навалувати вопросы.
Ну, головний вот сейчас фактор того, что вы через карту заходите в консультацию.
І заходите настільки быстро, як будто бы людина ныряє в море.
Щоб не заканчувати це на незаконченной истории.
Ми, конечно, там є последний, да, там, вопрос, інсайты, висновки, да, там, і так далі.
Скажи мені, пожалуйста, ісходя з того, що ти видиш на карте, тебе все рано потрібно підвести определенний вивод.
Вот давай сделаємо маленьке упражнення.
У Климова недавно було дуже класне. Вася, знаю, що ви, наверно, це виділи. У Климова було таке упражнення. Бері зараз її руку, поворачивай її к себе. Можеш дати себе почучити. Шучу. Все, все, шучу, ш
учу, шучу.
Скорість моєї руки була, що скорість звука.
Все, це була шутка.
Все, юмор ми не отменяли.
Тепер, набирай номер какой-нибудь.
Давай, 1-3-6, нет, 8, так, 0, да, 0, 99, 0, 97, 8, 8, 8, 8, 9, 10.
Ну да, ну короче, набери, тогда плюсик надо.
Да, какой-нибудь номер.
О, знаєш, какой номер? Подожди, набери свій номер.
Я именно свій набрав.
Що, набери свій номер, і ти береш зараз через 10 років, там сидит Юра, бери Юру і говориш, Юр, знаєш, що у тебе все вийшло і у тебе той союз, який дает 11, який не далося не по половинці.
у тебе все вышло, у тебя тот союз, який дает 11, где 1 плюс 1 равно 11, у тебя все вышло, и ты красава, що не слушала этих всех пиздоболов, которые говорили соглашаться на менше, вот, і топил до св
ого
да, но только теперь он тебе должен что-то сказати, что он тебе скажет?
Це то, що я, що?
Це він тобі повинен сказати.
Не ти йому говориш, що ти молодец, красава, ти топив к тому, що у тебе було.
Що він тобі в точці всього скажет, в цього сьогоднішнього?
Що він тобі скажет?
Іди просто далі, следуй своєму серцю і доверяй только йому.
Вот, тільки воно знає, де правда.
Все. Где твоя правда?
В серця. Всегда відвігаюся пощінням.
Смотрю, де вони не обманують в силу того, що було раніше.
Я смотрю, де... Ну, якби... Вижу, сердце послушало, вижу, результат не той.
Я такой смотрю так, а де здесь связь оборвалась?
Где-то ж я включил логику, а не сердце.
І потім меняю просто эту взаємосвязь.
Ну, як ісцеляю травму, да.
І потім мені показує, що вот сюди правильно, сюди правильно, сюди йдем, сюди йдем.
Вот. Получаю лише...
В чому правда?
в сердце, в искренности,
в тотальной честности к себе
в первую очередь. Тому що це тільки,
ісходя з цього, строїться двері к миру.
А без двері к миру дуже тяжело жити.
Все, в тотальной честности.
В тотальной честности. І якщо що-то не так,
йдеш далі. Але ти за счет
честності вистраиваєш
путь шагів до того момента,
де встречаєш свого чоловіка
на житті.
Якщо це є ценності.
Опять ж, класне упражнення.
В коучинге не ми даємо советы, в коучинге треба слушати, що совет йому дал він, то є розпаковка його видіння.
Все, тому вивод, який ми можемо быстро обеспечити і сформувати, це якраз то, що, несмотря на те, що є конфлікт між іллюзією і желанням, що знання формирується через твоє доверіе к самому себе і через
тотальну честность. Веди діалог.
Сто процент. Классне напряження.
Я, коли вначале пути делала, делала себе письмо з будущего,
типа «Спасибо, що не здался».
Ну смотри, «Спасибо, що не здался» требує сценарного процеса «Будь сильный».
Якщо ми говоримо про отношения, то ти маєш право на «Быть сильним» і «Быть слабым» і «Любим».
Честность предполагає «Быть всем».
І отношения – це про «хотеть».
То есть здесь вопрос не про то, каким делает меня другой человек,
про то, кем я хочу быть рядом с этим человеком,
что я хочу дать в ту сторону.
І це формирує планки, норму і так далі.
Мені здається твоя фраза, що ми не вибираємо людина,
з яким ми будемо жити, ми вибираємо ту життя,
яку ми з ним будемо зробити.
Да, тому адекватніше відношення к вибору партнера.
Білая, спокійная, переборчевая і так далі.
Дуже переборчевая і дуже чесная.
Умнички.
Так, давайте, Вась, ти тоді якнув.
Так, я якнув.
Можна маленький коментар щодо попереднього?
Фактично, пам'ятаєш, ми з тобою робили практику зміни переконань зі мною,
що великі гроші заробити нереально.
Або ти сказала, або я ще потім, я точно ще пішов по роботі з підсвідомістю,
І там багато чого допрошував, регресовував, мені дуже класно помогли, але прикол, чому мені дали завдання, тут написали фільми, дивитися, знайти історії реальних людей, які великі гроші не робили
легко.
Я дав чату GPT, він мені зразу не видав, класно, хто і як, а потім я один раз попадаю на фільм «Соціальна сеть», як Цюкербер створив Фейсбук.
Так він створив його з бунту, з приколу по дівчині, і, принаймні, в фільмі подано, що він от тако, чуть не за півроку, став мільйонером чи мільярдером,
просто ідучи в свій карт, свою насолоду, роблячи то, що є, і взагалі без напрягу.
І, в принципі, коли в моїй голові з'явилася усвідомленість, що були люди, які мали охеренний досвід,
легкий, і тоді дуже легше розуміння. Тому тут я Юрій Тащин написав, що знайти фільми,
знайти історії реальних людей, де було таке кохання, яке було, а воно 100% було, і прожити ці історії.
Ось для прикладу фільм «Де живуть мрії» — прям охеренний фільм, там Юрій не треба, вона типу буде в мінус, там вони померли всі.
Ну прям розмахав цей фільм «Де живуть мрії» — дуже сильний, коротше, ось такий мій фідбек на оце.
Мені допомогло, саме з підсвідомістю в рази легше пропрацьовувати і через Маккарто ці всі блоки, які оцей у міщі накидує, що такого не існує.
Не десь, це потрібно створити у твоєму полі знайомих людей і т.д.
Це потрібно знайти, побачити і бути впевненим в цьому.
Ніхто не дає гарантію, що ми ж еволюціонуємо і т.д.
Але ось ця, о, я бачила дуже сильну фразу від Габора Матеа, десь він сказав про те, що зріла любов – це остання любов, в якій ми вирішили залишитися назавжди.
І це дуже сильно, тобто це остання любов, в котрій ми вирішили вже залишитися назавжди, з двох боків.
І воно дійсно існує.
Давай тобі зроблю подарунок від себе.
Це така нестандартна історія буде.
І в мене там зовсім нема місця, але я тобі так скажу.
Давай я тебе запрошую 25 липня до себе на весілля.
І ти побачиш не одну таку пару в нашому оточенні.
Сільченка з мужем. Ніреальна взросла пера.
Там буде 15-20 пар, які выбрали друг друга зрело, взросло, дуже разумно, і не тільки через симпатию і хороше сексу, тому що дуже багато стратегічних, сильних, взрослых об'єднений личності.
І ти побачиш своїми глазами нереальне окруження, це відричається окруження від моєго дня рождення і всього іншого, тому що тут два руха людей, дуже серйозний івент, і моє личне тобі предложення для
того, щоб ти поверив в можливість дуже сильних союзів, які можуть вліять на історію даже государства.
Мені безумно приємно, мені прямо втру провалюється, не говорите, що це в Україні, будь ласка.
А, в Україні.
Юль, я готовий займати місце Юрию.
Юль, я не знала, серйозно, це не був пранк.
Я не хотела.
Я задумався, я задумався, що повернутися в Україну.
вернуться в Україну. Ну, дивись, якщо в Україну повертатися, тільки, знаєш,
як мені кажуть іноді, хлопці, ми не їздимо туди, куди є білети в один кінець,
треба, щоб було в два. Тобто в Україну їздимо тільки тоді, коли питання закриті.
Просто так ми сюди не їздимо. 27 липня? 25. 25. Я запишу, я буду рішувати тоді,
щоб був білет в другий кінець. Вот, тому якщо вийде, імей ввідо,
Це моє личне.
Дуже, якщо ти не попадєш, сам факт зараз, зробленого в твою сторону события,
це просто підтвердження того, що є на ринці.
І там люди, о которых ти говориш,
які просто не кричат на весь мир о тому, що пантики-цветочки,
але де є дуже сексуальні взрослі союзи,
де видно, що є секс, власть, діньки, спокійство, роскоші,
там, зберігальництво, який якийсь, колекціонування хороших машин і так далі.
і далі. Ти видиш, видиш эти пари. А у нас в основному все мужья і жін, у нас в основному семья в окружении, да? Ну, то есть, поэтому ты это в целом увидишь. А даже если нет, то уже даже сам факт приг
лашения, это есть камінг аут, да? Ну, то есть окружає себя сильными союзами. Вот і все. І оно создаст себя, поле создастся всему з вами.
Деревною благодарность. Очень приятно. Очень тепло.
Все. Ну, это про то, кто мы. Мы всегда дадим. Мы всегда дадим. Все. Поехали дальше.
Вась, про шлях, обирай. Смотри, яка у тебя підборка.
У мене фанець плюс ця, плюс дати були перші.
Так що?
А зіграти в дві гри?
Ти все одно, дивись, безвідома така штука, це як з буковками.
Какую ти карту не вибереш, ти все одно дійдеш до суті.
Все, дартс. Поехали випроси. Це про шлях. Теж. Швидко інтерпретуємо. Погнали. На емоцію.
Все, це на шлях життя.
Не бачу, не бачу.
Так, Юлечка, скинь, пожалуйста, в чат эту.
І потім йдемо в практическое. Я дам паузу чуть-чуть побольше.
Ми тоді с Тешу вже ворвемся. Хорошо.
Юль, скинь.
Є, є вже в чаті.
Все, відкривай, увеличивай себе дартси, будемо гнати.
Ти смотришь, ми йдемо через карту.
Ну давай, що ти видиш на карте?
Центр, точка попадання, вдалося, успіх, перемога, біль, рани, зранення.
Тобто ці точки, куди попались.
Я зміг.
Я що?
Зміг, клас.
Який мій шлях зараз?
Я вже в цій точці, в центрі, і ця стріла попала в мене.
І я попав там, де я мав бути.
Що мені не дає рухатися вперед?
Нічого, перша відповідь.
І оці точки, які вже понівачені.
Тобто, болючий досвід.
Не дає рухатися вперед, болючий досвід. Про який шлях я мрію?
Цікаво, щоб цей дарт був взагалі без цих, без стран, але тоді не буде і кітка.
Просто легкий, кайфовий, ніжний, свобідний, в кайфі, в насолоді, коли є час і все реше.
Які рішення я повинен прийняти, щоб надалі мій шлях був на солоді, легкий?
Чи більше любити себе, чути себе і домовлятися з собою,
я домовляюся навязково платити собі, дуже багато платити собі, дохіря платити собі.
Добре, повертаємося до реального життя.
Як житті виглядає на зараз дуже конкретними діями?
Любити себе і повертати себе, платити собі.
Мам, подорожі, дом, забавити болти на інстаграм, бути без телефону.
Пенсі. Тобто всі мої хобі. Чаконь, чистіше і теніс.
Нема дедлайну. Мені потрібен план на два тижні.
Сформуй, що саме ти робиш.
Я працюю в п'ятницю, в п'ятницю, в суботі вечір з дівчиною в Кам'янці.
П'ятницю, в суботі танці не підуть і наступний тиждень – в коні.
Подобається?
Ну, звісно. В принципі, це і було, крім коней. Коней додавались.
В Кам'янці мені сам по собі пішов і...
У мене зараз три дні. Мій продукт запускається. Типу 50 людей в першу. Хочеться і похвалитися навіть у це. Типу. Кайф.
Тебя з перезагрузки?
Ах!
Бо дійсно запит тут не про шлях, а про забрати, упобільнути, повернути собі, там себе.
І ось це найголовніша історія. І ось це є шлях.
Давай повернутися собі.
Що б ти додав ще? Що б ти додав ще?
Мені бляха, Юль, дуже хочеться сказати як.
У плані того, що до кінця я себе поверну собі в свободі від державної роботи.
Ну, тут історія про те, що є періоди, котрі потрібно пройти.
Котрі просто потрібно, да?
Так. Я дам тобі теж такі два приклади.
Сьогодні у консультуванні клієнт почав говорити про те,
що я дуже вдячний мамі, татові за той шлях,
бо він сформував мене таким, який я є і так далі.
А там шлях, ну, капець дитячий.
Тобто там не за що говорити «спасиба не папі, не мамі» от слова совсем.
Вот даже лучшее вытянуть там неоткуда.
І іногда клієнт починає романтизувати травму, наділяє її суперспособностями,
що вона привела человека к той точці, яка є, як ти сказав, на дырочці.
Нет, це ти привел себе к тому, що ти не сломався.
Тому що хто-то при такі обстоятельствах був, хто-то пішов був в жертву, хто-то пішов був і так далі.
Ти, вот це платить себе, ти создав себе.
І вот це дуже важливий елемент системи.
Возвращаємо клієнту авторство.
Він привів себе в ту точку, де він є, чого б не було б там.
Второй момент по поводу болей, обстоятельств і так далі.
Девочка, зараз, тож ще одна клієнтка,
сьогодні утром,
ну, примірний запрос на відношення,
хотілася б зараз зайти, а там не відношення,
там уйти от «Быть сильной»,
там вообще не про одиночество, там про другой момент.
І її ждуть операція.
І здесь розуміння того, що це як про державну роботу.
І вона буде восстаналюватися в силі определеної спеціфики.
Эта операція где-то порядка року.
То есть, она все равно никого к себе не подпустит в силу еще шрамирования, там есть определенная нюансовость.
І вот здесь вопрос.
Она заходит в эту операцию, понимая, що їй потрібно отбыти цей момент і цей срок, ну, щоб получить щось більше.
Я болела в своїй жизни, коли не подпускала, там, году-полтора-два никого к себе.
Ты знаєш этот дедлайн, де він закончиться.
Ти знаєш, але це настільки делает тебе гиперсильним і ценищим потім свої обстоятельства, як ніхто другое.
І ось це обстоятельство, не обстоятельство ломає мене, а я наделяю смыслом це обстоятельство.
Оно і закінчиться коли-то.
Тому дай йому відбути.
Не воюй с ним, дай йому відбути.
Зато, зато у тебе є безпецість.
Ну, знаєш, ти дуже права, бо саме через те, що я перестав з цим воювати, почав з цим грати,
ну, типу, почало все виходити.
Коли я в квітні минулого року казав, якщо я цьому піздєцю ще щось створюю великі бабки,
а для мене тоді 80 тисяч в місяці були великі бабки, я буду охерненний, типу.
І листопад місяць, я розумію, що я вже маю медійку, але не маю, це два роки тому було,
але немає легкості і думаю що я створив я створив сам собі і піздец і бабки припіздіцю тільки я сказав що в мене улюблена хороша робота
мене півтора року ну та відстрочка настільки халявля дається просто оточення і ну типу я плачу тут енергію
тому що ну десь це але просто вже оце душа настільки хоче цієї свободи вона от хоч чуть-чуть от хоче десь оце прожити але ну ми є то що є приймаю
Вона свобода і отримала за рахунок того, що зараз вона є. І тебе потрібно повертатися у цьому егостані з дитячою, бунтуючого, що не хочеться, а вже ж не хочеться, до дорослого і до того, що в мене є
зараз свобода, щоб дочекатись і так далі.
А по-друге, все одно, рано чи пізно, я знаю, що ти шукаєш, робота зміниться на іншу. І вона десь дасть тобі якогось нового повітря, не зупиняйся. Все. Ви молодці. Тобі було корисно?
Так, звісно що, починаю.
Солночко моє, тут ручка, пользователь зум, с выключенной камерой, с ручкой поднятой. Ну давайте.
Это Елена Гаврилова, здравствуйте. Я просто не знаю, де камера на телефоне включается, и я не дому.
У меня такой вопрос, вот я вся тебе написала, но ответ не получила.
Вот Оля первое, що сказала, она сказала, карта с якорем. То есть это было на інтуицію, правильно?
А потім, коли вона вже увидела це все, вона пішла вже умом працювати.
Стоить обращати увагу на це перше, що вона сказала.
Лені, що ви бачите?
Видіте, я поставила слайд, перше написано «факт».
Це просто описання.
Нас інтересують гораздо більше емоція, ідентифікація і динамика.
Саме головне динамика, як вона розвиває рисунок і куди вона приходить.
Фарт – це вводна, звичайно, це важна, але в цілому слово «якорь» ні разу більше не взяла в інтерпретацию.
Причем ж було інтересно, що большинство б на якорі начали описувати якорь, як главний елемент, чи ще щось.
І це було інтересно, що найголовніше в карте – це динамика. Не наше желання за щось схватитися, а динамика, куди розвиває і веде клієнт.
Я зрозуміла, просягла.
Все, отлично. Юльчик.
Да.
Я? Или?
Да, да, да, Юлечка, ты.
Да, Юля.
Юля, Юля.
Я благодарю за все, Юль.
Я вышла с курса совершенно другим человеком.
И я пока не консультирую в коучинге, так вот, как работать.
Але я виросла в бізнесі XX, і рішення, які я вирішила, вирішилися за счет сильного окруження і той поверенність, яку я почувствовала, поверенність в себе, яку я тут почувствовала і обрела.
Умнічка.
Вот, і, ну, в общем, для мене це просто вау-вау-вау, вау, відкривось ще більше можливостей.
Благодарю.
У мене є випадок. Продовження к темі Юри. Чого ще у мене немає, це відношення. І це іскати тих, у кого вийшло, у кого є такі відношення.
Іскати – нет. Іскати – нет. Потихонечку наполніть поле, наполніть його примерами.
Наполніть? Це должно бути обязательно живе поле?
Не обязательно. Вам главное – сформувати знання. Юль, главное – сформувати знання.
У мене коли-то, не так давно, в Спартакі ми розмовляли про Бога.
Він говорить, це вера? Я говорю, що не, він є.
Я говорю, для мене це знання.
Знання, да, тому що все мої спитання в житті я пройшла з ним.
Якщо б у мене не було б вери, то в цілому можна було б крепко попасть в жертву, да, чи ще щось.
Тому це знання, навіть якщо я розумію на рівні головного мозку, що я можу це опровергнути, знаю религії, як писалася Библия, куча всього вліяния, я вибираю це знання як константу.
Ваша задача сформувати, що там, не знаю, у мене в голові сформувано, що я є любиме дитя Бога, мені тупо фартить, і все є. І все є, і у мене реально все є. У мене позавчера на Бронишевской спросили, Ю
ля, о чому ви мечтаєте? Говорю, о чому? У мене нет нічого, о чому я мечтаю. Нет матерії, которая мені недоступна сейчас. Якщо мені треба, я поставлю. Более того, я даже можу бугати за нескільки мільй
онів доларів захотеть, я розумію, яким образом.
Так, мені треба, щоб фарк зложився, але дійти навіть до цих цифр для мене, вони не пугаючі в голові, нічого немає в матерії, що мене можуть не дати.
Второй момент – у мене є идеальні, да, там, відношення, діти, там, все, у мене є все.
Тому єдинственна моя мечта – це здоров'я. Все, щоб мене пожити цю життя чуть подільше. Все.
І, звісно, звісно, чіт-чуть би сохранити тело і мозг до самого цього подільше, да, ну, то есть, хотілося б для ігреч жизнених.
Але в цілому знання, що треба? Сформувати знання. Знання, що я для лучших відношень, що я готова. Але при цьому, що єдинствено, з чого в мене немає, це відношення. Це вже говорить про потребності.
В период, я просто, сори, що дам перенос, но в период безумно полюбите свою жизнь. Богатая, красивая, успішная женщина в современном мире – це роскош. У женщині, бути женщинами в современном мире –
це роскош.
Тому що ви, чим взрослеєте, більше можете потреблять яркость цей жизни, путешествувати, не стирати носочки, трусики, нікого не обслуживати і так далі. І ось тут питання, мені треба, щоб на питання, а
чого вам не хватає життя, чи якова ваша жена, ви сказали, Юль, ви що з ума сошли? У мене нахрен все є, а то, що буде, то от Бога.
Тому це то, що буде, там і десь бути відношення.
Понимаєте, в чому віде? Тобто це не отрицает, я відкрита к ним.
Але немає недостаточності, а тут вона ще є.
І це теж і ментальна нагрузка, і колективна, і бессознательна, і соціальна.
Чому-то нам обязательно треба.
І не тільки тому, що ми соціальні существа.
Окружити себе інтереснішими людьми, інтересними мужчинами для разных видів коммуникації.
Ні в одному, так в нескольких людях, женщинах, мужчинах і так далі.
Живіть красиво цю жизнь.
І дай Бог, іскренне желаю, щоб ви встретили свого чоловіка, якщо вам цього хочеться.
Але точно пусть це прийдет, коли ви будете к цьому относитися не тільки як допоміння к вашому счастью, а як усилитель.
Да, опять же, усилитель.
В этом мире бежать за чим-то стало очень опасно.
Будь то материя, будь то отношения и так далее.
А саме правильное в жизни, как в стойках пишут, самое главное,
это развивать состояние счастья.
А счастье – это правильно выстроеное мышление и правильно выстроенная деятельность.
То есть функциональное закрытие всех ваших значимо, желанно, важна,
Закривайте, да, вот эти голода, качественно закривайте эти голоды.
Вот.
Ну і дай Бог, понятне діло, якщо це в цілях, то пусть це буде.
Ну, якщо це в хачушках є, то пусть, звісно, це буде.
Сніжан, давайте ви і беремо.
Я хотіла в продовження для Юлі сказати, Юль Печенко.
Не знаю, для Юлі, але для Юлі.
У мене сьогодні сесія з клієнткою була, я ахнула.
Ми там визначали її точку А, точку Б, і вона пораховувала,
Які ролі в неї зараз є, і там не було жінки, і там не було жінки, я підсвітила, а вона також розлучена, навіть бої дітей, і вона каже, ну як я можу бути жінкою?
Що бути жінкою має бути наявність чоловіка, уявляєте, яке відторгнення? Не треба так.
Ну, це в целом то, що интересно, тож така лична маленька дата Малаверды. Я в целом амбасадор богатых, красивых, одиноких женщин. Я всегда була за те, що жінка шикарно живеться, коли она реализована.
І я ніколи не хотела в брак. Ну, я вообще не про эту историю.
Ось так сложилось. Я свої лучші годи будущого верила і видела на Гелике в Монако. Я зараз не шучу, це моя реальна картинка, і она мені нравится з сигарою, з своїми друзями, інтелігентнішими дедушками
і бабушками. У мене дуже крутое окруження.
там, с этими палочками,
вот эти бабульки, які будуть ходити, це буду я.
Ну, то есть це сто процентов, і там медитувати
где-нибудь среди других бабулек.
І мені це класно.
І я завжди думала і про то,
що красивий союз на три-пять лет,
зачем заходить в це все?
В це все. Все. Оно взяло
і привалилося зовсім по-другому.
І второй момент. Я завжди говорила,
чи лучше, чи нікак. І коли мені боженька дала лучше,
я сказала, ти що, пошутил? Це ж була отговорка,
щоб не заходить. Ну, то есть
Я задалась випросом, я, по-моему, в мечте миллиардов женщин, но моя ли это мечта, а другой начался кризис. Готова ли я, надо ли мне это на самом деле, когда я хочу другую линию жизни, да, ну то есть
там ушла другая работа на понимание вообще того, что такое может быть действительно сильный союз.
Тому полюбите колосально свою собственну жизнь. Настільки станьте фанатом, фанатом своей роскошной жизни і создайте її роскошнішим образом. Там, де женщина выбирает, вони її вибирають. І тільки тоді
подумайте о тому, треба вам воно чи ні. І тому, що тоді ви будете думати, привалить, окей, посмотрим. Не привалить, не факт, що треба.
тому в это касается не только женщины да вот станьте фанатом своей роскошной жизни вот это
главная цель вот она где за цель но точно не поиск партнер в крестюш у меня к вам вопрос он
у меня еще давно ночей вот когда мы ставим цели по поводу бизнеса там достижений спорта не важно
Ви на паузу не хочете, вам нікому не хочеться. Ну, хорошо, давайте.
А коли касається отношений, мені кажуть, це єдина сфера, де, мені зрозумі, ваше мнение, де це не роботає.
Тому що коли я бачу людей, зацикленні на відношеннях, у них, наоборот, нічого не йдет.
Тобто настільки потрібно бути в гармонії з собою, наслаждаться своєю жизнєю, прокачувати як-то себе.
І тоді, як це сказати, не зазвісить від цього внимання, є партнер, і тоді всі вони хочуть з тобою бути. А коли ти такий, я просто виділа дівчих, які зациклені, на цьому просто блок, який не відбуває
ться.
Любовь – це духовна составляча, любовь – це, ми називаємо її Богом, ми називаємо що-то, любов'ю пропитана життя, любов'ю – це той духовний спектр і пласт.
Господи, ловец снов, хто написав? Ану, подскажіть.
Перший маг в історії, однім словом, езотерик, він писав таку фразу, що любов' – це лифт на рівнях сознання. Матерія. Многі хочуть закріться любов'ю, щоб не строити матерію. Але задача чоловіка – ми
матеріальні, ми приходимо в матерію, ми рождаємося матеріальними.
як душа приходить в матеріальне проявлення
і в матерію здає цей опыт.
Тому цель человека – бути вовне,
а внутрення должно розрастатися.
Нельзя внутрення ставити,
ну, вот эту любовь действительно ставити як цель.
І в англійському недавно у мене було заняття,
там тоже психологічні все ці аспекти,
там у них є навіть…
Ми изучали ФОМО, синдром, да,
отложеного вот цього счастья,
І у них є в англійському языку прямо названня love sick. Я кажу, це влюблённість, чи що це за разновидність сленга і так далі?
Нет, це люди страдаючі, це прямо діагноз психології, психіатриї в Америкі, люди страдаючі з желанням иметь пар.
Це болезнє.
Ну то есть там немножечко другая философія развития. В целом психология. Что-то нам, понятное дело, мы все пересекаемся, но тем не менее, интересная линия лавсик. Вот этот вот интересный момент. Леш,
мы задержались, у тебя есть полчаса свободных, как минимум. Можешь идти кофе, я тебе еще наберу. Вот прямо отдохни еще.
Хорошо, вот это подарок.
Давай, я тебе наберу.
Щас ще отпущу всех отдыхать.
Вот.
Поэтому, действительно,
чем сильнее мы держимся за духовное,
тем скорее оно от нас ускользает.
Любое активное сильное желание.
А деньги, наоборот, мы ставим как цель.
Но, опять же, там и там есть огромные элементы.
Такі философські вопросы ви задали.
Ну, і там, і там є элемент доверия.
Все от Бога.
Я готова йти, этот путь,
но только ти решиш, коли мне дати.
Да? Ну, то есть, это история.
Так, Аліночка, давайте, швиденько, все, і будемо біжати.
Я просто маю скористатися можливостю і все-таки спитати.
Мене дуже зачіпили слова Кристини, там де зависання.
Тобто, зараз я так розшифрую в двох словах.
Без стосунків, там вже близько півтора роки і взагалі.
Ну, от так, як ви говорили, мрія бути одною самотньою красивою жінкою.
Приходить в життя людина і ти розумом розумієш, що взагалі ні, ні, я не хочу і не буду, але думки відпустити важко важко.
Тобто якесь таке, я не знаю, затіпаніння на одній темі. І це дратує, і це мене виносить зараз страшенно.
Що з таким робити?
як ви попали в больну тему.
Ну, в цілому, тема
отношений, она огромна, і она актуальна
всегда для любых людей,
потому що це частина життя, яка отыгрывает
вообще философію ценностей і так далі.
Она бьет
по очень глубоким темам.
Во-вторых, коли приходит
мужчина в життя, і вот этот вот
вопрос хочу сказати. Я не хочу,
я хочу... Це не про одиночество,
вот на самотність братися.
Це красива, самодостаточна,
неодинокая життя. Особенно, якщо ви
ще й мать, якщо класне відношення там з родителями,
де ж ви одинокі, коли у вас там 15 чоловік вдома вечно тусит,
де ви почуваєте це одиночество в обязок, блин, за всіх, чесно?
Не знаю, т.е. коли ви ще закріта, як мать,
це тож дуже важливий момент для дівчини,
тому що у нас є еволюційне желання це иметь.
А якщо ще хороше відношення там з папою, діток,
т.е. ви ще не одна в цій історії, там багато модносу, може бути.
Пересмотрите, Алин, мучина, який приходит і появляється на горизонте,
Якщо це той мужчина, він, повірте, заберет ваше внімання, навіть якщо у вас є – немає.
Якщо в мужчині є питання, головне, щоб цей компроміс, який відбувається в голові,
ці діалоги, які зараз відбуваються, не стали причиною вибору мужчин.
Тому тут справа, що у мене зараз, справді, фокус на розвитку.
Тобто, у мене, боже, у мене стільки планів, у мене стільки ідей, ну, тобто, в реалізацію.
І я не хочу витрачати час.
Смотрите, тепер вопрос.
Ну так, а почему вы это говорите мне, вместо того,
щоб прийти і сказати, дорогой мій чоловік,
мне так важна сейчас реалізація, біжать, кайфовать,
честность принесите йому.
І якщо він це винесе, то скажеш, да круто, давай,
чем тебе помочь, где тебе гроші дати,
где тебе с дітьми посидіти, да іди ты,
мені ти подобаєшся така, як ти ти.
І якщо він не уменьшить масштаб,
здається жінчина в цьому стані, що хтось зустріюється, що хтось зустріюється її масштаб і потенціал.
Якщо ви донесете правду і там скажуть «да окей, погнали». Пробуйте. Масштаб не сити, не приуменьшайте.
Страшно, коли жінчина в чужой масштаб влазить. Ідите в своєм масштабе. Нові відношення.
Якщо він готов этому – окей. Потестити. Ніхто ж не заставляє вас зразу замовж у дітей.
Але дайте правду! Особенно, коли ви ще не влюблені і не строїте відношення навсегда, приходите з тотальній честністью і смотрите, відбувається матча чи ні. В цьому є шикарність взрослых союзів.
Ви точно не дорожите на старте,
ви приходите з дуже величай честністю.
І коли другої чоловік вносить вашу честність,
легко, а ви його честність
касательно своєї життя не напрягаєш,
то вот здесь і формирується хороший союз.
Несіть честність.
І проверяйте через честність.
Я хочу Бентли, я хочу, там, що ви хочете, там, не знаю,
яхту, дом, амбиції, выступлення,
научну роботу, це все стоить.
Вот це, вот це, вот це.
І смотрите на реакцію.
Десь про те, що я хочу свобода.
Для мене зараз свобода.
поднятая давайте по поводу от этого что хочется отношений нуждаются в отношениях да у меня есть
любимое выражение вот так говорила что у голодной собаки взгляд далеко не сексуальный то есть это
про нужду и второе тоже мое любимое выражение что одиночество и даже когда тебе некому забрать
морга все остальное это свобода ну вот как-то я люблю эти два выражения они меня почему смеется
Тільки мій Алексей, тому що він не психолог, добре, позитивно. Дорогі мої, 20 минут віддіха, потім у нас практична частина на 20 минут, і ми починаємо, сліше, працювати з вашими питаннями.
Все, більше пауз не буде, беріть 20 минутку для того, щоб выдохнути. Зараз 10 минут, в 17.30 починаємо.
Це означає практична частина далі, тобто зразу далі питання-відповіді чи щось ще буде?
Не, смотри, ми починаємо з 17.30, 17.30 до 17.50 ви роботаєте друг з другом з картами, 17.50, 18, там, грубо кажучи, 18.05, ми з вами общаємся по поводу того, що ви зробили, і з 6 до 8 ми роботаємо,
не до 8.15, ми просто без одного переріва, там нет смысл його буде робити, тому що його треба буде зробити через час зразу.
От, тому ми на 15 минути раніше закінчимо, не на 8.15, а на 8.00, і у нас буде 2 часа на роботу з питаннями і відповідами.
Поняв, дякую.
Тому що це вже фінішна сесія, наша величина задача вже вас відпушити на масштаб, все.
Ну, тепер вже випуск.
Є одна проблема, все-таки, напевно, буде до 8.15 і прийдеться записувати останні 15 хвилин в'ячності.
Разберемся.
Давайте, ми раніше почнемо, все завістить від ваших питань.
Давайте, все, 20 минути, у вас спокійно.
Дякую.
Дякую за перегляд!
Субтитрувальниця Оля Шор
Так, підключаємося і будемо працювати.
Маленьке розвантаження нервової системи, маленький такий перефокус,
спробуйте попрацювати один з одним з картами метафорічними.
Юлічка, ти здесь уже на связі?
Так, так, я тут.
Юлічка, смотри, зараз потрібно обновити, щоб це було останню інформацію.
Ось ці три карти, друга колода, ось ці три карти, третя колода, ось ці три карти. Вони повинні бути підряд і потім ще додаткові питання, по котрим можна пройти. Тобто раз, два, три, чотири, п'ять, ші
сть слайдиків в них повинно бути, прямо перед очим.
Яким чином ви працюєте? Ви розділяєтеся на дві, рекомендую взяти саме першу техніку, бо вона виведе і на відносини, і на реалізацію, і на що завгодно. Тобто не брати ось такі профільні, бо з ними
складніше, вам потрібно імпровізувати.
А тут повний цикл питань, і він закінчується, куди це веде, що буде далі, якщо нічого не змінювати, яка нова версія цієї картинки тобі підходить, що ти будеш з цим робити, все. Вона повністю заверш
ена, але вона дає легкість. І вам, як спеціалісту, і клієнту, який працює з цією технікою, що потрібно зробити, ще раз повторюся, у вас є три підборочки, людина обирає карту, і ви ведете її без запиту
по питанням, знаходячись навколо.
Попрацюйте в парах, якщо хтось хоче з кимось, можете написати «Юлі», все, і попрацюйте в одну і в іншу сторону для того, щоб здобути свій власний досвід.
Дозвольте собі зробити це ідеально, не ідеально, не зважайте на те, що це останній модуль, ви все одно тут учні, якщо не тут, то де?
Будьте лояльні друг до друга і вчиться знаходити свої власні відповіді.
Ми все одно тут робимо демо-версії, ось цю практичну частину. Плюс все одно натхнення потрібно десь здобувати. Можете бути з постарігачами, ви знаєте, що я дуже лояльна до цього, робіть так, як ви
хочете, бо ви дорослі в мене люди.
Ну що, поїхали. Юлі, розділяй 20 хвилин. 10 в одну сторону, 10 в другу сторону. Повертаєтеся. Ми обговорюємо і починаємо Q&A сесію. Почне Олексій. Олексій почне з того, як працює зараз ринок, які ре
алії. Вони мають деякі особливості. Ринок дуже сильно змінився. І там є певна нюансовість.
Тому ми почнемо з того, що відбувається зсередини і коучингового ринку, і маркетингового ринку, і як дорожчає зараз лід, і складніше, і так далі.
І від цього будемо вже йти у ваші більш тактичні, точкові розбори. Обіняла. Все, поїхали.
Я б надіслала в чатик фото і розділяю вас по парах.
Наскільки хвилин ми їх розділяємо?
20 20 максимум 20 хвилин добро
а можна дуже коротко що зараз буде відбуватись бо я тільки прийшов Юрочка можна
розбивається з попаром даєте клієнту вибрати одну із цих трьох і проходитесь по випросам
не рекомендовала не брать про отношения
і все остальное, але ці шість слайдів,
тому що вони достатньо плотно
розкрывають тему без запроса.
І ти в одну сторону, і в другу
сторону проходиш з клиентом.
Тобто берете метафоричні карти.
Дякую.
Я б хотела попросити, щоб мене
добавили я з телефона і з ноутбука
зараз. У мене просто інтернет
в ноутбук і вибиває іноді.
І щоб я була завжди на зв'язі, з телефоном мене теж. Добавьте туди.
Ви використовуєтеся писюмом, да?
Да-да-да.
Щоб я була завжди на зв'язку.
Спасибо.
Да.
Дякую за перегляд!
Дякую.
троє до Катя Ентель я і Юля Петінка давайте якраз Маша Граб була доєднулася тому я до вас Машу Граб зал 10 і Катерина Ентель і Олена Сі також вас просто переміщає щоб ви були вдвох так а карась Тетя
на вам прийшла запрошення
От Анна.
Дякую за перегляд!
Субтитрувальниця Оля Шор
Дякую.
Дякую за перегляд!
Субтитрувальниця Оля Шор
Так, обратну связь все-таки придеться мені дати, якщо не хочете. Маша, ну ти засмеялась, ти і даєш. Вот і п'їхали.
А я ще з мікрофоном. Я з об'єдом.
Привіт, Юлічка, рада бачити, рада бачити всіх. Неймовірна практика, дуже класна, була зі своєю колегою в кімнатці, йому так зрозуміло, з якої би карти ти не зайшов, Серед, ти шов би до того, що в
тебе зараз є лінійною, основною, ось, і дуже круто, насправді, виводить дійсно, що болить найбільше зараз.
От що воно, ти значить і про гроші, і про успіх, і про реалізацію, і про це, і воно такий хіразь тобі, і знову такий, твоя болюча тема, що я там з коханим не поруч, і я тут тако, і ця мета варуч, це
опять в точку, так, і опять в точку, ну короче, так що дуже круто, дуже дякую, беру з собою.
Кем працювали, Маш?
Камер.
А, з Юлією.
З Юлією Печені.
Рубаємо пальми, Маш, рубаємо пальми, відкриваємо.
Єлечка, ваше обратно з воротні зв'язок, і ви як пара, тому дайте вин-вин.
Да, ну я присоединяюсь к Маше, тому как ми пришли к тому, да, ми обсуждали там картинку, которая попадалась Оле, я озвучила, що ну да, а я там вижу ржавий якорь, который я би убирала,
Тому що це щось таке старе, яке мене якорить, і мені вже не треба, мені треба тут очистити пространство. А потім у мене там картинка була божья коровка з бульбашкою, і вона тож, мені треба вбрати цю
бульбашку.
Як не крутиш, що-то треба вбрати. І веде дійсно, може не любая, але більше картинки ведуть к тому, що зараз актуальніє всього. Класно, нам понравилось, дуже понравилось.
Вони хорошо вводят в запрос, вони хорошо вводят в ассесію, с них вообще в целом можна начинати. Така метафоричність, як дела, а ну погнали, да, і так далі. Все, хорошо, хто ще скажет? Кому хочеться,
це тут по желанню пока. Давайте, Костюш.
Давайте я скажу, вперше, коли треба було виконувати практику, я такая, о май гад, ви настільки її легко провели, а ти тут посмотриш і не розумієш, а як її проводити.
І потім я в шокі, наскільки за 10 минут і в одну і в обратну сторону
вдалося реально чітко отобразити насущне ситуація
чи блоки, страхи, настільки глибоко і настільки об'єктивно.
Я в шокі.
Я в шокі, що з такими метафіорическими картами
І навіть за 10 минут з клієнтом можна прийти до того, к чому ми прийшли. Восторг.
Главное, Крістюш, зази головне, щоб карти були інтересними.
Ось карти должны бути прям картинами.
Посмотрите, даже эти карти, подборки, вони прям всі разные з них.
Вони прям всі имеють любу інтерпретацию, тож даже телевізор.
Для кого-то це може бути хороше, для кого-то це разрушення, для кого-то це созидання.
Ну то есть кажа карта, це прям, ну то есть интересно порассматривать. Я їх все взяла з одного сайта, поэтому посмотрите, выберите себе класные карти, возможно їх можна заказати, не знаю, не пробовали
, но тем не менее найдите свои любимые, да, но тут дуже важливо, щоб вони були не дуже примитивненькі, потому що є картишки такі, вроде і фраза написана, і рисуночок, а воно начепляє, начепляє,
поэтому картинка должна бути прям все.
І на тому сайту, який ми скинули, там є дуже класні техніки для того, щоб взяти 3, 5, 6 варіацій.
Мені більше всього подобається то, що я вам написала, така більш широкая, тому що в будь-якому випадково підведе вас к результату.
Але якщо хочете поїздити, там теж є. І як роботати з закритими картами, як розклад зробити, і так далі.
Але, опять же, це не таро, це інтерпретация чоловіка, тобто він дає відповідь, він витаскиває все, що у нього є.
Клас.
Анют.
Да. Благодаря метафорическим картам пришло такое понимание,
що картинка може бути одна, якщо ми щось переносимо на життя.
Ситуация може бути одна, события можуть бути одні,
але кожен чоловік інтерпретує її по-своєму.
Каждий увидит в ньому своє.
Метафорічні карти, вони настільки дають вот цю ясність себе,
і потім можна це своїм клієнтам приподносити,
що та ситуація, на яку ви дивитесь, і вам кажуть, що це трагедія,
Другой на це посмотрит і скажет, що все нормально, все в порядку.
Через метафоричні карти можна клієнту донести, що те собіти чисто суб'єктивні.
Да, чи можна сказати, а якщо б людина, у якого все було, посмотріла на цю карту,
коли ви це пройшли, то що б ви тут увиділи?
Какий б другий смысл ви увиділи?
Тобто можна зігратися з разною інтерпретациєю,
Казати навіть міста просмотра чоловіка.
Ось одна картинка, а зараз навіть нас.
Возьми всіх, вже коучів, прокачанних, вимчанних в МСММ.
І кожен в цій картинці вважає своє.
Ну, можна навіть, дивіться, для якого-либо...
Якщо здаєте мини-продукт, візьміть одну метафорічну карту
і скажіть, напишіть, що ви тут видіте.
Увидіть 15 тисяч разных характеристиків і скажіть,
що це значить, що немає монополії на істину.
Ви кожені слухаєте, що б я не говорила своєю.
Тоже хорошее, водное, таке отрезвляюще.
Поэтому давайте будем адекватны.
Ваш предыдущий опыт влияет на то, что я говорю, гораздо більше, чем то, что я говорю вам.
Вот і все.
І от цього починаємо вже двигатися.
Поэтому це теж хорошее.
І хорошее демонстрація силы теж.
Тоже, ну то есть, в зависимости от того, що ви робите,
ви можете використовувати любой інструмент.
В зависимости от того, що його, як його подати і кому.
Це хорошо.
Ну що, є ще коментарі?
Якщо нет, починаємо далі двигатися.
Нет, хорошо. Олексей.
Алексей.
Щас, одну секунду, вибачте, будь ласка.
Да, я тут.
А, ти, Сонечка, тут? Давай, Сонечка.
Все нормально. Небольшой форс-мажорчик.
Ты можеш дать? Да, я тут, я тут.
Можеш дать затравку двухминутную, і я включаю і розкажу історію.
Хорошо? Треть минути.
Хорошо, добре. Любі мої, у кого ще є коментар?
Тоді ось так, вибачте за затримку.
Ну, таке теж буває.
Мене подивилися метафоричні карти.
Пробачу, Юрочка, вже я почала.
Ви всі вже скажете, давайте, давайте.
Ну, от про актуальність однозначно.
Я метафоричні карти обожнюю, ну, я з ними працюю,
і я бачу просто настільки глибокі процеси відбуваються.
Відкриття, що скажу з приводу роботи, тільки що я з Олею працювала.
І хочу дати фідбек Оліній роботі, якось чогось я ніколи з Олею не попадала, ну попадала в якісь такі практики дуже маленькі, а сьогодні попала, я кажу Олі, і так хочу побути просто клієнтом.
І вона провела, і насправді тут я починаю бачити картинку реалізації, до чого я зараз йду, що мені актуально, все, але все одно ти хочеш, не хочеш, воно тебе все одно в ті болючі місця затягує.
І, власне, да, підсвідомість дуже класно говорить через метафори, мозок вона дуже класно обманює, і таким чином ми отримуємо відповідь від підсвідомості.
І ще раз дякую Олічке, бо того, що вона реально дуже класно розположила, вона, ну, з нею мені було дуже легко, комфортно відкритись, да, там, до якихось таких подробиць, про які ніхто не знає.
І вона дуже бережно, да, вона створила класний простір. Дуже дякую.
Олічка, з якою я працювала?
Богдановська, Оля, да.
Богдановська. Олічка, це ще одна тебе, виді, сьогодні закидончик в копілку по поводу, як говорити собі?
Тобто, все не просто так. Ти можеш лікувати своїм простором, тому лікуй. І ось це дуже-дуже сильно.
Добре, Юрчик.
Оля точно красотка. Оля в цьому талант. Я їй теж про це говорив. І точно тут підтримує при всіх 100%.
Оце глибина її. Я не сумнівав, що не вибрав цю карточку Озера, тому що з ним окрема історія.
от і це топ 10 10 а я взяв слово чисто був щоб якусь заповнити оцю тишу яку Олексій хотів
за те що ви настільки кайфово вовлякаєтесь показуєте себе демонструєте створити цей
простір це середовище це кайф класно я насолоджуюся цим всім це саме розйомний
Розйоб, як у нас казали, розйобним розйобом, а не навчанням, просто за силу, за масштаб, за людей, за ком'юніті, за знання, за вашу щедрість, за вашу щирість, за любов, я не знаю, просто, назавжди в
моєму серці.
Це як вчора був коментар, розйоб, розйобаний, розйобним, розйобом. І взагалі я не матікаюся.
Ну це та ж характерістика емоції. Так, сонечки ми, давайте до питань. Почну я тоді розбирати. Олексій, дуже рідко в нього бувають форс-мажорної ціної.
Привіт, дуже рідко. Ну все, тоді питання закрите. Давайте.
Всім привіт. Я дуже радий вас бачити. Чим більше до завершення такого проміжного, то тим більше я бачу щасливих очей, мені це дуже приємно відчувати, бачити, знати.
Знаючи, я за всіми слідкую, хто активнішує в чаті, хто спілкується, хто з Юрою робить ці моменти, хтось окремо, і я бачу, як велика кількість людей виросла.
виросла, я хочу
сказати, що мені б дуже хотілося
вам сказати сьогодні, знаєте, які гарні слова,
де будуть звучати такі типові фрази,
як «Дой, все буде супер», «Все буде
добре», «Все буде летіти». Але
насправді ні, тому що ринок дуже
сильно змінюється. Ви це
прекрасно всі відчуваєте.
В січні місяці дуже сильно
на ринок вплинула
в Україні вплинула дуже сильна
криза українська, в освіті
вплинула дуже іранська криза.
і це повпливало на велику кількість секторів, і доміно потягнуло всі інші сектори.
Тоді ви це бачили серед своїх клієнтів, своїх знайомих, і криза – це найкращий час для активності і робиння чогось хорошого, класного, великого.
Ми 100% бачимо, що деякі проекти у нас в рекламі, не пов'язані з психологією, працюють гірше,
а деякі краще, де була своя база, своя аудиторія, і з цим можна працювати.
Ми, наприклад, задатувалися і зробили так, що більше працюємо зі своєю базою, ніж з холодною.
Але це той момент, який я побачив, що коли у всіх почалася кризи, всі почали виключати рекламу,
вимикати активний пошук, при тому, що реклама працює гірше, але ринок дуже звільнився,
бо велика кількість людей спугалась, замірла і досі нічого не робить.
І зараз найкращий час для того, щоб почати щось робити, в тому плані, що продукти тепер не шукають людей-методолога, вони йдуть в чат-джіпіті.
Люди навіть рекламу не налаштовують, йдуть в клод, не роблять презентації, йдуть в чат-джіпіті, клод, або джимінай.
Ринок дуже сильно перебудувався, дуже сильно змінилися акценти і фокус на тому, як створюються продукти, як швидко вони створюються, як робиться реклама.
Цікаво, можна, що я починала з вами про клод, про чат GPT, про зміни, хоча ми не спілкувалися з ООСІ, про те, що ми будемо говорити, але ми обидва у ринку, і по різні боки, у нас нещодавно запитали,
наскільки часто ми зізвонимося, я говорю, ну якщо вийде один раз в місяць на синхронізацію, то це победа, і це не шутка, ну то есть я відповідаю за один блок ринку, він відповідає за інший блок ринку
, і ми так спінка к спінки, да, ну то есть просто очень много довері.
І ось цей момент, що ми по різні боки сказали одне інше. Знову синхрон. Ринок дійсно настільки явно змінюється, настільки потужно, що зараз йде прям актного фарадея.
Тобто йде дуже сильна зміна еволюційна. Вона дуже сильно буде змінювати ринок найближчі навіть 2-3 роки. Тому будьте уважні до змін і не лініться дивитися на цифрові якісь рішення. Це факт.
Якщо раніше можна було пролезти з якимось там умовно посереднім, нормальним продуктом, запустити рекламу і скласти цю юніт-економіку, це стало важкіше. Один там інфо-циган казав, що типу, ой, тепер в
маркетингу важливий продукт. Бляхта, завжди продукт був найважливіший. Найважливіше в маркетингу завжди був продукт, його якість, його глибина, його результат.
І ринок залучення клієнтів змінився, але не для всіх, він змінився для тих, у кого був продукт, який щатався, для людей, у кого твердий продукт, де вони на першому дотику отримують результат.
Те, про що ми з вами казали на блоках маркетингу, дуже багато я про це розбирав.
Ви в мене в особисті питали, я про це записував окремі голосові, наскільки важлива зараз якість, сила продукту і результат на першому дотиці.
Якщо ми кажемо, сьогодні у нас буде більше, всі питання будемо обговорювати, але на чому я хотів сфокусуватися, то те, що Юра робить за я, і те, що я бачив продукти ваші деякі.
На першому дотиці з продуктом має бути результат. Якщо це ваша менторська сесія, ви продаєте тільки менторські сесії, у вас є перші запити, або знайомі знайомих, зробіть так, щоб точка входа, коли в
оно звертається до вас,
Ні ви їм присилали, я вже про це казав, просто хочу нагадати. Напишіть, от має ціна, все. Ні, пройдіть оцей тест, отримайте такі результати, давайте подивимось, підійдемо ми одному в роботі чи ні. Д
уже банально, але повірте, я бачу, як перед це працює, я бачу, як дуже великої кількості інфоринку відпало, і зараз найкращий час для того, щоб робити класний, продуманий, цікавий продукт, робити його
в короткому форматі, потім розбільшувати, збільшувати, збільшувати, збільшувати.
З цього хотів почати, щоб трошки синхронізувати, дати такий акцент, показати, що змінилось на ринку.
Ми про це з вами на блокі маркетингу говорили, і якщо ви виконували ті задачі, які ми з вами говорили, то у вас в цілому проблем глобальних не буде.
Буде тільки кінчасова турболентність.
Хто хоче перше задати питання, або будемо по черзі підіймати?
Любі мої, це менторська і вона останнє. Ми справді на ринку прям фігачимо і знаємо його середини. Дуже рекомендую з нас випитувати все. Дадім все.
Тоді питання. Льош і Юль, дуже багато на ринку зараз і, в принципі, я працювала це продавати через зізвон.
Розумію, що люди вже наїлись, розумію, що люди вже вкусили цю тему, ходять і користуються цими, звісно, безкоштовними всякими плюшечками.
Як тенденція з вашого досвіду, куди дивитися надалі,
все-таки залишати і робити ці безкоштовні діагностики, цей контакт?
Чи, може, ви якось там...
Відповім, відповім.
Я за останній тиждень передивився воронки,
начинай, який бюджет тратить і тисячу доларів, і сто доларів, і сто тисяч доларів на місяць.
І конверсія діагностик – 22% все одно.
В нашому випадку, у нас більше, до 2 тисяч доларів, 22% можна вижимати.
Якщо це ви особисто продаєте, 22, 20, 15 – це можна тримати вообще спокійно.
На 100% дзвонив 15-20% продаж, мало чи багато, мені здається, для дажиму норм.
Робити просто групові ці дзвони по 2-3 людини, і це працює.
Обична продажа, звичайний продаж по телефону, якщо ви експерт, спеціаліст, ментор, вам далишив заявку, і ви набираєте, альо, давай тобі продам, ну, я і вважаю, що це не ок, воно буде збивати, дуже
сильно понижувати вашу експертність.
Ось такий діагностіка, умовна оця, перший діагності, він досі працює, класно працює, у тих, у кого нормальний продукт, він класно працює, у нас з вами він частково працює.
Тому ми зараз теж будемо адаптуватися, у нас є там декілька ідей на трансформацію, але в цілому це працює.
Що з цим робити ще? По-перше, перестати нагадатися, давайте з вами на діагностику задзвонимося, давайте ще щось.
Оце все треба прибирати, ці звичайні базові фрази. Треба шукати свою назву, тіпа тестова, менторська сесія, тест-драйв, демо.
Тобто шукати фразу, яку в вашій самій ніші, вона не заюзана в нас, діагностика, у вас частково у деяких ніщі, слово діагностика дуже сильно заюзана.
У мене мині-коуч-сесія, я це називаю.
Міні-коуч-сесія, офігенно, звучить отлично, якщо вони після цього ще будуть, от як, Юрий, звиніся, не буду деякий час ссылатися на тебе, бо бачу, розвиток роботи.
там, де у Юри после созвона приходить презентація, да, з рішеннями,
і в цій презентації ще буде пропозиція, і следующий шах какой-то,
очень легкий, то Слариця буде працювати.
Наступний момент.
Селайся.
Можна?
Леш?
Давай, конечно.
Мені подобається ось ця історія, що ти сказав там, не обов'язково.
Юрия продукт є часто, GPT, є куча всього, да, то, що ви можете дати.
Якщо ви можете якось адаптувати ще ось це, дожати, додати інформацію, ось це нам,
то це дійсно може підвищити дуже сильну конверсію.
Бо людина зазвичай звикла, що закінчилася коуч-сесія і все, і воно закінчилося.
Уявіть, через 4-5 годин долітає повідомлення, а тут коротко те, що ви робили і те, що я рекомендую.
Вона не чекає, але вона отримує дотик ще більше, який підтверджує там wow-ефект, якщо він був створений.
Тому це дуже класно. А якщо там буде ще відеоформат, візуальний формат, картки, що можна попрацювати, ну уявіть, наскільки це масштабна історія.
Тобто це можна використовувати як такий лід-магнітік до вашої воронки. Але якщо говорити моє особисте, Льоша, з цим частково погоджується, частково ні, в нас є ось ці діагностики на продукції Академ
ії.
Академія поки що продукт новий на ринку. Але якщо взяти експоненту, ось цей продукт, він вже давно саїдав на ринку. Вони все одно роблять співбесіду, де з людиною розмовляють і допрацьовують запит,
де вони доводять запит.
Взяти півварову формулу, він 50-50, з кимось зізвонюється він, з кимось не він. Що стосується мене, чесно скажу, в мене ніколи не було безкоштовного часу для людей. Все. Я ніколи не проводила безкош
товні сесії за рахунок мого часу, мого життя.
Що я могла робити? Ну, це моє особисто, Льоша знаю, ми класно використовуємо діагностику, але там не я ж проводжу діагностику. Що я робила на першому потосі, якщо ви пам'ятаєте, коли ми робили співб
есіди? Навіть тоді я робила не на одну людину. Я провела одну чи дві сесії, сказала, що це таке, ну, тобто, що ви хочете? І ми почали збирати по 6-8 людей.
Тобто, якщо на діагностику, то це не індивідуально. І ми ж теж тоді обійшли систему. Але ми взяли міні-групи, де я презентувала і могла відповісти на питання. Чи були безкоштовні продукти там, де ох
оплення людей було більше. Тому тільки вам вирішувати, працює цей момент чи не працює, щоб знаходити свого клієнта.
На старці своєї практики я просто робила дешевшу сесію, але завжди хотіла, щоб за неї заплатили, бо я більше вірю, що людина, якщо платить, вона це більше цінує, чим безкоштовно.
З чим ми зіштовхнулися на діагностиках, теж такий нюанс. Коли ми говорили, в нас безкоштовна сесія, наваліла людей, які хотіли безкоштовну сесію.
Коли ми сказали, ті, хто хочуть поступити, для них є сесія, щоб ви вирішили остаточно, чи хочете ви, чи ні, одразу менше.
Тобто, якщо ви готові поступити, чи бажаєте поступити, ось цей момент одразу їх зіштовхує ціною, що там за поступити.
Хоча б заходять на сайт і подивляться.
Тобто, оцей момент, фільтр, він все одно навіть у діагностиках зараз існує.
Тому що якщо зовсім широкий фільтр, зайдіть до мене, хто хоче скористатися, що таке сесія, ні.
Так? Ну, що таке сесія, бо дуже багато людей, їм цікаво спробувати таку сесію, why not.
А є люди, котрі готові заходити, тому я б все одно працювала з якимось офером.
Ну, це моя думка. Але ви бачите, ми на одному продуці використовуємо саме такий офер,
Тобто ми заводимо на чек через безкоштовну історію, але якщо вже підводите, якщо ви цим користуєтеся і цей інструмент все ж таки працює, тоді допрацюйте ось ці вау-ефекти, щоб хоча б конверсія була
підвищена.
Ну, тобто, додайте вже такі мало ефекти, щоб воно того коштувало. І трішки дайте якогось, не знаю, ранжування тим, хто доходить. Ну, тобто, хто хоче працювати зі мною і готовий зайти в 10 сесій, я
готова запропонувати першу сесію безкоштовно.
І тільки потім ви вирішите, ви мене обираєте чи ні, і я вирішу, чи обираю ваш запит.
Хоча б якась часткова частка людей буде розуміти, що там об'язна 10 сесій.
Звісно, хтось пролізе, але це буде вже менша категорія людей, яка пролізе просто так.
Я тільки про час. Леш.
Так, так, 100%. Ви вже тут на перший день, тому вам 100% варіанти платні теж підходять.
Просто, ну, короче, да, в принципі, якщо не відповідає, то скажіть, ми доповнимо.
Ну, ось ця ідея безплатна, щоб дати їм допрацювати сильно цей досвід, то це прямо топова історія.
А хто наступний?
Я руку подняла, наверное, я вам буду говорити.
Мене інтересується такий момент.
Як би менторство, наставничество вставити в свою страничку в інстаграме?
Я можу.
Тому що, оказывається, до вчорашнього дня я понимала, що я безплатно давала цю інформацію.
Зараз я можу своїх ученихів, які мені обучаються, виводити на менторство, наставничество.
За доповнительну оплату.
А вот як мені коучінг ввести в мою страницу?
Тому що менторство, наставничество, массажистам я розумію,
а вот якщо ще коучінг, то це взагалі буде спорна солянка на страниці.
А чим вам коучінг?
Ви хочете коучінгом заниматися не для своїх студентів, а именно для внешнього ринку?
Ну, як дополнительно, да.
Зачем, якщо у вас є основна від діяльності,
який приносить гривень, в якому ви професіонал,
і через який ви можете заводити.
Якщо ви будете своїх студентів заводити на масаж,
і потім їм говорити, що у вас є коучинговая наставничество,
то есть ви вже техніку проработали,
це проработали, але у вас є там випроси з результатом,
то да, давайте коучинг.
Можливо, в цьому є смысл, тому що, смачте,
я прекрасно знаю ваше странице,
я периодично захожу, посматриваю,
мені в заметках є тікток, інстаграм.
У вас в тіктоке полгода назад залетели ролики,
ТикТоке в марте у вас залетали ролики. Типа вам нужно сфокусироваться на том, как это масштабировать, а не завести еще одну страницу, в которой вы будете тратить время и ресурс.
А фокусироваться на том, что работает, то, что сработало, еще больше глубже это изучить, почему это сработало, сделать ролики посистемно, чтобы они залетали и масштабировались.
теж у вас там, наприклад, карусельки, те же, у вас тукарилсы, карусельки можна зробити, і це масштабувати, і просто иногда допоминати, говорить, що я провожу массажистам, провожу этот, но я знаю, що
у мені всі люди собрались, і я чаще всего коучингом займаюся, хто хоче на першу сесію ко мне попасть, давайте попробуем, у меня є така методологія, яка я поняла, як добиваться результата, і вот так
заходить, да, і мея вже перших коучингів клиентів, дальше отталкиватися.
Я вважаю це тільки так.
Тобто тут я можу создати такий кейс,
що у мене учениця на менторстві, на наставничестві,
і у нього такий результат после третій нашої сесії,
тому що ми нашли її затык.
Це так, в двох словах.
Все верно, абсолютно правильно ви описали, так і є.
Наприклад, у вас в карусілик немає,
ви можете про це в карусіликах розказувати.
Взагалюєте, розказувати, але, опять же,
вам, якщо ви хочете на коучинг закрывати,
Ви можете, тут ще виправо з того, що відкликнеться ви чоловіку чи нету, в першу чергу, то я б на самом деле був говорил, що да, я ученикам своїм провожу як коуч, новий, більше розбори, бла-бла-бла-б
ла, і тему був вже в профилі, у вас там про масаж, офігенно, круто, але він подумав би, може б, шире братися, ви вже научились в кабінете записати, що ми можемо ще зробити, щоб шире аудиторію брати?
Це щас виправді ко мене, да?
Це риторичний питання, тобто, наприклад, як місць виявляє на відношення?
Тобто, якісь такі широкі теми, які можуть заходити?
Я зрозуміла, дякую більше.
Лена, можна я відмовляю на відгонку?
Да, звісно, це дуже зрозуміло для мене.
Як місць виявляє на секс?
Це вообще максимально широкая тему.
Ти понимаєш, якщо турки переведуть цю фразу, я і так успіваю їх тільки удалять,
тому що вони пишуть «хочу массаж», дайте термін.
А якщо вони ще услышать слово «секс», то це капец, вони вискребуть оттуда і адрес у мене.
Як у Юли, да, власть, деньги, секс.
То є це три теми, які будуть інтересуватися всіх, і всіх.
Ну да, я в одно время практиковала скандал, секс и спорт.
Вот у меня есть какой-то этот самый.
Скандал, спорт, вони вешли бы тоже, коли плохо.
Поэтому, да, спасибо.
Ну, Анечка, секс за границей,
коли кругом турки і все эти, це чуть-чуть.
Нет.
Спасибо.
Ну, оно б залетало среди тех, кто в ТикТоке, Инстаграме і так далі.
Я подумаю, как сюда.
Ну, ми ввели, ми перше слово поставили секс, спорт і ще щось, не помню.
Трес, я помню.
Ну, не можу сказати, що оно сильно залетело.
Ну, будем пробувати.
Вот у мене щас, наприклад, залетела, оказывається, фішка в Берлині, не знаю, как в інших країнах, в городах.
Ми запустили рекламу «Массаж без масла».
Оказывається, «Массаж без масла» вообще в Берлині ніхто не делает.
просто никто и вот мы запустили в рекламу у меня запись до 30 числа уже полная это вы записались
куда на этот на вы записали на немецкий аккаунт смысле на немецкий в инстаграм основной да я с
немцами не работаю я не знаю немецкий поэтому с немцами не работа и вот оказывается вот мы
посмотрели что вот эта реклама у нас выстрела лучше всего массаж без масла тесно прикольная
ниша хорошо раскрытие быстрых словах не задержали выносить вы высшим практикуйте массажи делаете
вы когда общаетесь с клиентом вы расскажете что вы вот коуч чтобы развиваете в этой сфере так
далее да я даже говорю хочешь мини-сессию во время массажа да хочу то есть по затылькам по телу я
понимаю уже как человек живет и как шо у него какие затыки в жизни что-то очень уникально
звучит такого не слышал никогда это я себя был такой попал от ума сошел если поменял наушники
як і обіщався не бри всіх не бри всіх ну так хорошо і що я начинала мені сенсію да там а
как ты вот здесь а как вот а ну вопросы вот эти все подготов конкретний запрос на следующий
массаж а если ты захочешь мы проведем с тобой никто еще ни один человек не не подготовил запрос
а не за разбором їхних психологических затыкав ну это понятно да ну мне кажется
что то можно подумать почему так типа я не знаю у них то есть потенциал точно
я их подготавливаю что вы можете да там задаю вопросы как бы точечно трогаю их насчет коучинга
но вони не загораються вони не приходять запросами не буду если у тебя будет запрос ты мне скажешь
запрос мы начнем делать массаж и разберем твой запрос по твоему телу и ты получишь ответ они
через сайт приходят лент до через инстаграм ну тут уже цыганское радио и но я бы ставила бы
когда вы высылаете проси не все спрашивают прайса сколько стоит вызвать какой-то скрин и
І ви пишете, масаж стоїть стільки-то.
Вторе, развернутое коуч-сесія плюс масаж два часа стоїть стільки-то.
Тобто, т.е. отдельно коуч-сесія стоїть стільки-то.
Ви сразу дають прайс на разні види услуг.
А так, вони получають завжди предложення тільки на одне.
І вот ця форма, якщо хочете, я це вам дам.
Вот це, якщо хочете, я вам це дам,
обычно дає чоловіку багато вибору.
Надо давати більш чітку рамку туди, куди він може зайти.
Прайс, це взагалі круто.
Я прайс сразу же на услуги, которые существуют,
потому что так выглядит, как будто бы я это умею,
но тем не менее, как бы, ну, как бы есть.
То есть, нет, я работаю в этих направлениях.
Все, если вы хотите перед массажем проработать
психосоматический аспект того, что происходит с вами,
тогда мы сначала работаем, потом вы ложитесь на массаж
и закрываем тело.
Телесная и ментальная работа.
Ну да.
Мене Аня як-то скидавала прайс, помниш, Аня?
Якщо тільки ви плачете 200 евро, якщо ми плачем вместе 300 евро, ну, такий шуточний.
Ми навіть виставляли в сторісет.
Ну, шутки, не шутки, але тим не мене, да.
Оно, работаюча система.
Це як варіант, як це може бути?
І тут як раз у мене і виявиться тихонечко коучинг, не перекрыває мою страницю.
Не тихонечко, а прям варіанты, і прям оплачені варіанты.
он не должен быть дешевле, он наоборот
как екстра-услуга, да, ну то есть
вот і все, і є категория людей,
які хочуть брати все, а є категория
людей, у якого психосоматика, да,
ну то есть, опять же, психосоматика – це вже
терапевтическое направлення, але там, де треба поработати
з телом до того, як зайти в тело,
или выговориться.
Да, я поняла. Ну, я имею в виду, что
потихонечку вести, оно буде в прайсе,
они прайс все читають,
а вот именно, щоб там сказати,
у мене ролик там какой-то, да,
що я там кулу, то це вже буде зборна солянка, да, шикарно.
Ні, ні, ні, дожна бути прайс, чітке предложення,
оно намігає, оно намігає,
і коли возникнє потребності,
хтось захочет дійти.
Поэтому треба зробити
цю имитатию активної деятельності,
треба зробити людям
понимання того, що вас вже покупають
інші люди, так.
Ви хочете, покупаєте тільки массаж,
а є категория клієнтів, які покупають так.
Уже вот этот момент, а вы среди них или не среди них, да, ну то есть, грубо говоря, если не, ну так, более завуалировано.
Да, потом будет, потом будет первый кейс, и уже все, и тогда будете потихонечку вливать это в Инстаграм все больше и больше.
А сейчас просто сделайте стори, скажите, я придумала, ну ладно, я скажу своими словами, вы перефразируйте под сюда просто, что я бы так бы подал, что я придумала что-то новое, уникальное,
Типа це либо дуже круто, либо дуже странно.
Але в будь-якому взагалі це все нове,
завжди може бути странно, але інтересно.
Я проходила коучинг, я перейдив...
Много того, що ви розказували нам, помните, пару раз,
що я общаюсь з людьми, я общаюсь з клієнтами,
я слышу багато запросів, я вижу дежу зажиму в телі.
І ми іногда на сесіях общаємося.
Я рішу це зробити віддільно.
Не тому, що мені там складно общаться безплатно,
а тому, що я считаю, що це є огромна ценность,
яку я можу дати.
Дальше, ну, якщо ви коли-то хотіли побувати у коучерів, з массажем, ви можете тепер це об'єднити, тому що я маю сертифікацію, бла-бла-бла-бла.
І це подати розказ, що це появилось в сторіс, і в прайс це добавить, все.
Дуже, мені здається, які люди, якщо ви будете скидати прайс, вони будуть спрашивати, що таке, плюс коучинг.
Ви будете говорити, ну, це взагалі, я вам щас розкажу, ви офігієте.
І одніється, що пролаби цей момент, це може вам показатися странним.
Тому ми даємо їм таке відчування, якщо право страною це чи не страно.
Так, ми вбираємо будь-які показати слабості.
Сразу говорити о тому, що є така позиція, такий варіант.
Хочете приходити? Вот так. Хочете приходити? Вот так.
Я ввела в перечінь услуг це направлення. Сертифіціровано, завершено і так далі.
Так, все. Ой, спасибо огромне. Очень круто. Спасибо.
Леш, я одну минуту подойду.
Без проблем. Маша?
Леш, з досвіду, як зараз працюють ті мініпродукти як воронка?
І друге питання, цінеутворення з приводу ціни, яку краще заходять, або так вже, або так.
Окей, да, тут не по досвиду, тут по тому, що я зговорю, що я общаюсь з всім ринком інфобізах глибоко, я чітко знаю, у кого що. Я знаю чітко, що 90% продуктів зараз в плюс не роботи, навіть в ноль
дуже мало виходить, но є дійсно в ниші фітнеса, фейс-фітнеса, ниші, такі точечні, узкі ниші, ниші, внутри ниші, роботають офігенно.
Я знаю там, у кого окупаємость X2, X3 за місяць і класно працює.
Але це виключення із правил, але на високому бюджеті плюс дуже багато що протестувано в рекламі.
Щоб щас знайти зацеп за мини-продукт, треба дуже жоско, дуже багато в рекламу потратити і протестувати багато гипотези.
Наприклад, ми тестимо шість продуктів протестували в января місяць, тільки один зробив, а остальні плохо працюють.
По цене то же самое, то есть, ну, у нас там запускается, когда продукт, мы тестим 3-4 цены минимум в рекламе, смотрим, какая лучше работает, от этого отталкиваемся.
Ну, я бы, ну, думал бы с точки зрения логики, то есть, если человек, люди не верят в массу своей мини-продукты, да, но верят в то, что, типа, они все равно, смотрите, формат продукта меняется, как бы
, все равно, да, там, меняется что-то на рынке, но проблема-то у людей не ушла.
То, що вони хочуть гроші, не вшла проблема, то, що вони хочуть спокійства, не вшла проблема, то, що вони хочуть закрити свої страхи, нерви, тревоги, не вшла проблема. Вопрос в тому, що я б зараз фок
усувався на широкому, дешево, безплатному продукці, і з безплатного вже б дальше їх заводив туди, куди потрібно. Ми зараз так робимо, по своїй базі робимо, і на халатку теж запускати будемо, на безп
латний формат.
Ми зараз, я зараз розкажу одну воронку, в якому є консалтинг, то есть у нас є група по маркетингу, де ми допомагаємо, і є консалтинг, де я з командою, ми пошагово говоримо, що робити.
І в одному продукті я придумав таку штуку, що ми запустили рекламу на безплатний продукт, типу вебинара, трьохдневного інтенсива точніше, і рекламу у блогерів, ну другу друзі і блогерів запустили на
этот інтенсив.
Забрали бесплатно 1000 чоловік, на першому шагі, коли вони попадають в бот, вони отвечають на два коротких вопроса і заполняють анкету.
І виходить, що в мене 100 людей, які зашли на безплатний продукт, там 180, заполнили таку анкету на 8-10 вопросів, з дуже чітко описано своєю проблемою.
І вже з цими людьми ми на цих людей продаємо, і даже 20% продаємо з середним чеком 20-800 тисяч доларів, це буде хороша виручка запуска.
То есть, ми по факту с людей анкету раньше давали после вебинара, а мы начали собирати очень сразу, сразу после перехода по рекламе, условно.
Собирали глубокую анкету с запросами людей.
По этой анкете уже продавали, потому що в этой анкете люди відъявили желание, показали свою реальну проблему.
Вот так ми щас делаємо.
Кто-то запускає миники, вони у них работають, но я знаю, що просто нереально офігенно работает повышення квалифікації.
Звісно, в англійському високий уровень английського.
Це дуже мало продуктів, там класно роботи, милі продукти.
На базовий курс, типу, як построити отношення,
будуть збиратися не дуже.
Прямо гаранірую.
Ми недавно на курсі по маркетингу
збирали інтенсив по отношенням Андрея Мазуренка,
але якого-то нереального количества продаж не було,
тому що це чуть-чуть піднадоєло.
Там у нього потрібно цю тему...
У нього класно зашло на свою аудиторію,
тому що там є у нього фанатами.
Но зараз треба брати і ниши, внутри своїй широкій ниші і сказати, що таке, якийсь уникальний, новий підход.
І тоді миник буде добре робити, там не важливо на цену, буде 5, 10, 15, абсолютно не важливо.
Важна тематика і рішення проблеми.
Це ще раз, саме важливе — це рішення проблеми.
Це то, на яку роботу вас найміт чоловік і наскільки ви качественно рішите його проблему.
Перестаньте думати о тому, як заробітати, як мені заробітати плюс 300 доларів на своїй.
мини-продукти, перестаньте думати,
як мені запустили рекламу. Це все
важливо, дуже важливо. Ну, первично
задумайтесь, як я можу, блин,
реально лечити проблеми чоловіка?
Ну, то есть у Юлі, типо, ну, личні
консультации, чому вони так дорого стоять?
Потому що Юля фанат рішення проблеми.
Ну, типо, рішить,
як би, салюшен, це для людей, дає
настільки вникає на це рішення,
що люди, коли соприкоснуться на 2-3
сесії, вони вже такі понимають, що Юля
вложилась настільки глубоко в рішення,
що, як би, не можуть вже,
вже починається рекомендувати,
тому сарафан офігенно работает.
Так і з онлайн-продуктами, т.е. люди, які...
У нас, якби, головний батлнек,
така узкая горлышко в наших продуктах,
це доходимості до середини продукту.
Т.е. у нас заходять добре,
коли прошли там вообще офігенні конверсії,
але це, типо, момент від першого захода до пройти,
там саме узкое горлышко.
Якщо решить, то все буде офігенно.
Тут, якби, другя методологія в нашому часу работает.
А в вашем случае це все про сумасшедшими, просто сумасшедшими, сумасшедшими желаниями иметь, решити проблему человека.
Давайте я вам расскажу пример из своей жизни, очень личный.
А это тоже связано с нашими компаниями.
Ми стартап, давайте зразу відноситися, що ми не 15 років до компанії, ми не Гарвард, 300 років історії і так далі. Ми стартап по факту до сих пор. І ми завжди іщем пиво, як і в личній роботі з Юлією,
так і в команді нашої в бізнесі. В бізнесі у нас понятний путь, роудмар, і ми для себе взяли, також ми, ми 4 роки, Юля всю життя, я всю життя, в психології, в маркетингу, і ми для себе рішили, що як
що у нас відбувається какой-то екзит в смежної ниші, ми повністю фокус зробимо туда.
тому що наша задача – мисія глобальна – помогати людям.
Для цього потрібно більше охвату, для цього потрібно більше діння.
Конічна ціль все одно – діння.
Ми вищем найлігий спосіб знайти діння.
І ми виходимо, в нашому випадку, я не буду все подробності розказувати,
в будущем якось розкажу, ми виходимо на зовсім інші чеки,
де связь, зв'язати людей на мільйони доларів,
це ти, звісно, получаєш дуже багато зв'язок і знакомство, і діння.
І на такому рівні я думаю ось, як решитися, яка у них проблема, особисто там у одного чоловіка.
Ему потрібно інвестиція, а інший іщет їх.
Окей, що ми можемо зробити? Тобто, треба цих людей з'єднити, треба мені вебинар запускати?
Нет, але мені потрібно так з'єднити їх, так, усовно, всю структуризувати роботу, щоб це швидше і легко відбувало.
Ми це зробили, в це вникаємо і це починає працювати.
І я просто, ну, там, усовно, до сумасшістя, у мене там всю життя було 2-3 роботи, так і зараз.
Я до сумасшедствия просто думаю, узнаю там у інвесторов, у проектов, в тех нишах, в которых мы работаем, у стартапов.
Ви иногда видели у Юлі в сторісах, може, що іщем інвесторов для таких-то направлений.
Я настільки вникаю в детали, в боль человека, ринка, наприклад,
почему в нишах биотек в Європі люди не несуть інвестиції, да?
І наоборот, почему проекты плохо привлекають інвестиції?
Я вдалблююсь в эту нишу настільки, що я понимаю, как работает изотопо, как работает проблематика,
Почему це не видят, почему це не слышат,
почему вони між собою не можуть знайти связь.
Я настільки вдалблююсь в проблему двох сторон,
щоб рішити і стати цим соєдинителем,
що це доходить до сумасшесті, до 2-3 часу ночі,
цього Клода вимучиваю, щоб він зрозуміло проблему,
зрозумість проблему і зрозумість.
Тобто ваша задача, хто буде більше всіх зароблядати,
хто решає проблему других людей, і все.
Самий багатий чоловік в цьому мірі
вирішив дуже великі глобальні проблеми.
Ваша задача на вашому ровні, вашу нишу — решити ці больші глобальні проблеми.
Це мій посил і філософія в цьому.
І бути готовим завжди поменяться.
Ви сьогодні «вот, все, я для пар».
Пляха, а завтра він прийшов, предприєматель, все, значит, ви для предприємателей.
Не бойтесь поменяться, не бойтесь развернуться.
Ми тож з Юлією думали, що Атея буде приложенням,
де будуть собрані всі інструменти, связані з роботи з собою.
Ага, це нікому не потрібно, супер.
Коли ми створимо тільки три, що потрібно, і це масштабуємо, висіляємо, робимо, краще, красивіше, інтересніше і так далі.
Полністю маємо віктор. Це окей, будьте в цьому.
Може тут Елена завтра підійде в місаж робити, велосипеди продавати, і мільярды на цьому заробітати.
Таке теж може бути, тому що вона знає, як правильно створиться, фізіологія чоловіка, як це педали тут крутити і так далі.
Я в словно пример привожу, просто щоб вам було понятно.
Тому, Маша, відвічаємо про випроси, чим просто.
Цену можемо ставити любу і, головне, рішити проблеми чоловіка.
Хорошо, Аліна.
І знову добрий день, і знову ті самі гості в ту саму хат.
Давайте.
Обширна ніша.
Я так і не можу її звузити.
От що б я не робила, я навіть, ну, от зараз буквально до кінця цього тижня
вже буде моя авторська колода метафоричних карт і вона теж іде обширно тобто там іде зображення
з обратної сторони послання і коучингове запитання спочатку я думала що в друкованому
варіанті але потім вже оце спомнила що зараз АІ і створюємо зараз як ну я не знаю чи це
клод зробить чи чи робити це в телеграм-каналі як краще бо я ще ну якби все прописала да зараз
скажу це 88 карт 8 блоків інтерпретація кожного блоку життя людини і до кожного блоку я даю
дві практики і авторську медитацію ось продаватися будуть фізичні карти ясно що типу як в подарунок
буде вам електронне оце все дорожче і дешевший варіант явно електронний от яким чином мені в
першу чергу оцю обширність свою показати бо то що ну не хочу я згоджуватись я себе як кудись
не поміщаю ну блін ну мені там от воно взагалі і показати да ну мені насправді вдається там
якщо це якийсь такий один конкретний запит з яким людина вже находилася за одну глибоку
сесію я цей запит їй закриваю якщо людина що не знаходилась просто ну типу от ще в розмышленнях
тож от вже в мене є да там от 3-5 сесій і і все і тіпо і все ок і все класно яким чином
мені це донести показати і ну зараз я вже так договорю да зараз я взагалі взяла ніяких
правил просто от в моменті нехай воно буде навіть не дуже красиво да але в моменті з моєю оцю
енергію з моєю впевненістю, бо ж тут теж є ще питання, але я ще не можу поняти, звідки вже зайти,
донести ту інформацію, яку я хочу тут і зараз, щоб людина до мене доторкнулася і щоб за цю точку,
ту чи іншу точку людина зачепилася. Все, я виговорилась.
А питання в тому, що як продавати себе і все це донести, чи карти?
ну от донести цінність мого комплексного підходу тобто психолог консультант в інтегративному
підході коуч ментор так і при цьому я і власниця бізнеса ну тобто я прям наголошую що це маленький
жіночий бізнес тобто я можу і тут допомогти створити маленький жіночий бізнес тобто взяти
жінку я можу її провести до її шляху можна сказати практично з усіх сторін кожному напрямку
можна я тут для мене тут не розфокус для мене є тут фокус я спеціаліст у напрямку
Ту-ду-ду-ду-ду-ду-ду-ду-ду, інтегративного підходу, це і е вузька подача, просто то, що є велике позиціонування вікруг. Я можу сказати, що в своє час ми так переживали за велике кількість продукти, і
, дійсно, коли їх дуже багато, це, звісно, не відвікає людей. Але, тим не мене, не сильно відвікає, коли формируєте базу людей, які следять за вами. Тож все дуже відносительно.
Ми коли-то аналізували мистера Биста, його випуски, і у нього 15 тисяч продуктів, він кожен раз 2 чи 3 рекламу в своїй випускі дає на різні продукти, і вони добре продаються.
Тому у вас дожна бути якась система напомінань, прогрівів, щоб там по 2-3 дня ви уделяли якій-то ліній, і потім меняли фокус внимання, з якого сторони говорити о себе.
Ми зараз взяли піарщиків і почали працювати перший місяць, тільки закінчився, з однією командою, з іншою було інтересно, як вони будуть смотреть.
Ми повністю збираємо позиціонування, психолог, коуч, нигде цього вже більше написано не буде.
Взде буде вже стояти предприніматель, ученый, дослідник, автор книг, все, вже вже збираємо.
Але це не говорить про те, що я не буду продаватися як психолог чи коуч, наоборот, буду продаватися і далі, просто вопрос чеки і так далі.
Ну і фокус, на скільки я цьому зараз буду уделять увагу.
Тому вопрос карты – це допомінний продукт, як мини-продукт, як курс і так далі.
Це продуктова линейка, просто сделана в другому еквіваленті доступа к чоловіку.
І вона буде продаватися по той же логіки, як і предыдущі продукти.
Сначала на тєплу аудиторію, а потім треба буде це отдавати на холодну аудиторію.
Але для мене це не розфокус.
І вот тут вопрос, як це продавати? Рассказувати.
Других варіантов нет. Знакомить собою. Знакомить собою, розказувати об этой болі, що часто не можуть понять, почему, да, ну то есть і так далі. Единственное, що мене смутило, сразу говорю, то, що реж
ет слух, це маленький жіночий бізнес, я можу научити маленькому жіночьому бізнесу, як будто бы аккуратненько відповідальність не беру за що-то крупне. І коли жінки дійсно хочуть щось почати, вони не
хочуть йти к кому-то, хто зробив маленький жіночий бізнес, вони хочуть йти к тому, хто зробив бізнес.
Даже, якщо вони хочуть маленький жіночий бізнес, вони себе розрешають сказати маленький жіночий бізнес, але вони не підуть тому, хто зробив маленький.
Тому що, звісно, вони розуміють, що якщо ви достигли цього при своєму бікграунде знаний, то вони не дістигнут і цього.
Тобто вони можуть дістигнуть меншого. Обичай, чоловік думає, що він дістигнет менше, ніж учителі.
Тому це в позиціонування треба точно вбирати і зразу давати в позиціонування, що я – предприниматель, яка построила бізнес-систему з товарними продуктами, з онлайн-продуктами, з кар'єрной лістницей,
я знаю, як вистрається фінансовая модель, що таке цілеполагання і так далі.
Тому я можу бути полезна, як це ваше запрос, але в першу чергу не важливо, щоб ваше ядро було собрано. А здесь інструментарий любой. Я можу і так, і так, і так, і так, але определимо, як робити не ш
аблонно, а именно тільки після вашої першої сиси.
ну то есть поэтому для меня это не 1 фокус для меня это уметь о себе рассказать нам все больше
и больше нужно учиться на себя рассказывать да типа соцсети ну они перестали работать все
прекрасно работает людей собираются просмотры охват ну куда падает больше куда-то меньше но
просто чтобы найти свою нишу и подход который работает некоторые видео залетают некоторые
не залетають а вот например на наших аккаунтах рабочих есть которые вообще спокойно каждый ролик
набирает там по пять тысяч и по 40 50 новых подписчиков клиентов привносит и все киют на
консалтинге нас человек просто берет и делает вот у нас даже с вами в группе есть люди которые
смогли собирать себе людей даже не имея большого актива в инстаграме работа с третцем автоматизировав
третц вам просто нужно привлекать большую аудиторию когда будет большую аудиторию не
буде цих всіх випросів. Ось то, що Юля сказала, правильно да, заводить, давати касання з собою і розширять
це. Та, що я говорив на маркетингі. Найдіть спосіб показати свою унікальну технологію. Ви так душевно
розказуєте свої технології більшої. Це так, ну, круто звучить, интересно. Я розумію, що там є сила,
в цьому є мощь. Вам треба знайти спосіб це показати. Тобто, наприклад, щас покажу, як меніум.
Можем ли ми зробити вам сайт, де буде, ми вже знаємо, що сайт можна зробити з допомогою Клоду за один вечер. Можем ли ми зробити сайт, де буде не просто описання ваших услуг, а описання ваших услуг і
сразу тест встроений, щоб показав метод, що таке інтегративний метод і на яких рівнях ви роботите.
де чек там, які-то 3-4 випроси заполняє, і получає какой-то результат, і ви говорите,
«Вот с цим ми і роботимо, ви тільки 3-4 випроси пройшлися, у вас вже є результат,
от що вам потрібно робити, а представте, що ми зможемо з вами розібрати,
коли у вас буду я, і буде не три інструмента, а 4, там, 4 кнопки,
а буде 25 таких інструментів на год вперед, без прив'язки ко мене,
і ви будете знати, як дійсною, тому що я можу і в бізнесі, і в відношеннях, і в здоров'ю,
і вот це показати. У вас є карта, ми можемо…
І ще, можна, така ідея. Уберіть цю історію ілі-іли, вдавіть в цю історію, так жінкам постійно нав'язують, що ми повинні бути, або ти працюєш, або ти не працюєш, або ти така, або ти така. І навіть оп
озиціонування. Тебе знано, з ким самим ти працюєш. Усі хочуть ці рамки. Ні. Ви дуже велика особистість. І ось ця історія про гроші секслади, там ми ж роботаємо з архетипами поведення.
Вопрос не в тому, щоб определити, в якому архетипі чоловік работает, а в тому, щоб він мог работать во всіх, в зависимости от ситуації.
І це говорить об оркестрації сценарії, що я можу перейти з одніх рельсів на інші.
Класс, все.
Так я скажу, я оркестр і вчу вас бути в різних ролях.
Проблема, якщо ви усюди начальник.
Але не проблема, якщо ви начальник на роботі.
Проблема, якщо ви усюди жінка.
Та не потрібна жінка в економічних співвідносинах.
Там ви повинні бути суб'єктом економічної діяльності, який проносить цілісність і користь.
Яка ви там жінка у бізнесі?
Який там жіночий бізнес?
Ну, серйозно, от поэтому і денег нет.
А коли ви становитесь суб'єктом діяльності, у вас і деньги з'являються моментально.
Тому що відповідальність.
І ось цю історію потрібно дати теж.
Тому навпаки, граєте на своїй болі.
Вам само не нравится вот це вот или-или
подстроити себе под якісь рамки.
Так іменно це і тригерить буде
вашого клієнта і ваших жінчин.
Отдавайте. Чувствуйте своє,
це ваша зона розширення. Проходите своє
і ще й других через це привлекайте
к себе. Дякую. Дякую, Юль. Дякую, Леш.
Леш, а ти ще хотів щось додати?
Не, не, все, я все сказав.
Все. А, не, про карти, да,
сори, про карти. Карти, да.
Ну, типа, блин, это вот как бы сложно зараз залететь на Львсах,
если даже, вот видите, у меня даже не получается не всегда,
когда я условно сам.
То есть у меня нет еще где-то такой подачи, такого послужби,
я сам мог условно залетать.
Но диалог всегда заходит в класс.
Ну, в месяц собрать там 10, там 5-10 знакомых,
с которыми записать видео на 30-40 секунд,
где они достают вашу карту, и вы им рассказываете что-то, да,
и видео обрывается, там, и продолжение в Телеграм,
или там, продолжение следующей серии.
Ну, почніть показувати свої продукції, як ви їм пользуєтеся, в онлайні, в офлайні, записуєте це, показуєте.
Смотрите, мені не хотілося б вас на цю сторону, як би, толкати, але я хочу вам донести ще ідею, що ви є своєй стартап, да?
Як я кажу, ми своєм бізнесом стосуємося як стартапу.
Я хочу вот таку модель мышління вам подати, що один інвестор на ютубі сказав, що якщо ко мене приходять за інвестиціями люди,
І вони не спробували написати 100-200 грантів, на які їм відказали.
Я їм вряд ли дам, тому що вони спробували ще не все.
Весь, ви должны також почати відноситися до себе, до своєму профілю.
Поки ви не спробували все, о чому говорили, все говорять інші в своєм аккаунті,
як експериментатор, рилси, ага, рилси неравні, не можу робити рилси, а що можна?
А, карусели, делаю карусели, не карусели, трес, ага, значить, делаю трес.
Ютуб – не Ютуб, Телеграм – не Телеграм, колаборация – не колаборация, реклама – не реклама.
Пока ви це все не перепробували, то есть, ну, вы не должны останавливаться.
Що-то з цього всього точно зайдет, то, що підходить вам.
І ви должны максимально з ума сходить над тем, як мені ще попробувати, як мені зробити,
як я можу пробитись більше кому кількість людей показати свій продукт.
Я вже говорив, що, да, ми…
нас продукт для женщин там 35 плюс мы находим курсы которые здесь наша целевая аудитория идем
на эти курсы на этих курсах собираем вокруг себя группа 10 человек кому интересно психологии
проводим практику показываем наши инструменты карт я условно говорю да не мог быть клуба это
могут быть ивенты это могут быть закрытые какие-то сообщества и так далее то есть и в
у мене консалтий дівчинка, у ній дуже більшій чек, у ній там всякі практики, кундаліни, а що в ній делать, ну що делать, идти по клубам, це реально все, що я вам советую, просто один в один, просто
все, що ми говорили на маркетинге, тупо я беру і говорю, идем с тобою, делаем вот це, блин, Ірина, какой у вас код, я не можу, я отвлекаюсь на нього, так смотрю, можно я тут додам?
Закончити? Закончити, зраздобавиш. Антка, да, хорошо, все, она пошла в один, второй, третий клуб, два не сработало, в третьем просто вокруг нее 10 человек на практику пришло, два стала клиентом, она
купила участие в этих ивентах Pix3 і заработила денег. Типа все, она по этой системе просто пошла дальше, дальше, дальше, дальше. И закрыла полностью себе там 15-20 тысяч долларов за полтора месяца.
в кінці в кінці місяця в Чернівцях ну в мене ближче найближче в Чернівцях дійсно жінки хочуть
розвиватися чогось хочуть і я так і вже колоду доробляю так що до того виступу тепер я хотіла
трішечко додати про те що ми були там декілька тижнів тому у Бережі і я бачила з Анітою Соловей з її
Аниту Соловію думаю, знаєте, она достатньо публична касательно інфобіза, а муж у нього, основной собственный фінмайпа, на секундочку, ну то есть айтишка сумасшедшая, да, там в бухгалтерії, финансовой
аналитики и так далее, а всесобственник, дубилет, который разрабатывал монобанк, ну короче, такой прям сильнейший состав, и он такой говорит, у меня один инвестор на 300 питчей, быстрее я его не ищу
и даже не стремлюсь.
Т.е. 300 питчів, де-то 30 чоловік хотять зайти к нам,
але нам не підходять усови, як ми хочемо, як ми не хочемо, і так далі.
Тому один інвестор, вони впускають інвестора одного на 300 личних питчей собственників, богатейшого мужчину.
Скільки він уделяє моментів.
Тому, коли ко мене приходять стартап і говорять, що ми хочемо, щоб наш стартап взлетел,
він сидит і таке говорить, ну, заміцательно, а скільки ви провели встречи, скільки ви зробили?
Говорить, ну там, блин, уже 20 или 30.
Говорить, ну прикольно.
Говорить, у меня одна сделка на 300.
И это мы говорим про миллионы, да?
Ну то есть все, и там нет спешки.
Они понимают, что что бы заметчилось, должно быть.
А мы хотим быстро, мы расстраиваемся.
Что 20-й ролик не залетел в инсте.
20-й за месяц отработали бедненькие.
Понимаете, о чем я?
Ну то есть вот вам и, ну вот вам и разница.
300 год отработайте каждый день.
И каждый увеличивая действительно качество, свет, подача.
Смотрите, де зашло. Не просто снимите 300 подряд, отработайте год, і ви увидите.
Вот вам 300 касаний с аудиторией.
Вот вам те же 300 питчей.
І так по кожному моменту.
Второй момент – класна метафора по поводу того,
що якщо б ви знали, що через 300 нет, у вас буде 100% «да».
Як быстро ви б хотіли, з якого радости ви б проходили ці 300 нет?
Наскільки ви хотіли б? Быстріе, быстрі, быстрі.
там, ой, лямчик, надо, вы радовались
бы каждому, вже 202-е, нет,
слава тебе, Господи, да, і все.
Вот і розкачивайте себе, що у вас где-то лежит
ваше «да». Це знання.
Вот то, що ми говорили про мужчин і жінчин,
це знання, знання надо качать. Ребята,
вот це, почему ми все-таки
менторським уделили, а не МЧП,
почему ми убрали последніх два
модуля і дали коммуникацію,
ну, потому що среда, у вас знань уже
хватає, среда, среда,
де ви можете поговорити, вот це головне схватить.
Все, Лерочка.
Дякую.
Всім привіт. Минулого разу Льоша питав, що я нічого не винесла, бо я працюю над цим.
Поки в мене питань немає, я ще прийду.
Щоб, знаєш, це трошки відзвітувати. Я розвиваю свій телеграм-канал Біла Ворона.
На цьому тижні записую для себе коучингову лекцію як формат воронки під назвою банка про стелі в нашій голові,
які вони бувають, звідки беруться, на які зони впливають і певний покруковий алгоритм, як це можна зробити.
Ходили на нетворкінг, знайшла для себе партнера, з яким будемо починати працювати.
Він більше в консультуванні, стратегічному напрямку.
В мене софтова частина, яка взаємодоповнена, щоб там, де він не може закрити.
Я закривала і так навпаки.
Сьогодні в нього без мене вже була зустріч з Дія Бізнес.
ми будемо працювати через ДІІ Бізнес з різними напрямками, тобто є можливість ще через тренерство залучати в коучинг.
Знайшла на тому ж нетворкінгу для себе ментора зі створення бізнес-спільноти, бізнес-клубу, бо я не пам'ятаю, я, напевно, не говорила,
я розробляла для себе покруковий алгоритм створення мастермайнд-груп для підприємців.
Але на цьому ж нетворкінгу один з підприємців мені сказав, ну інашо тобі виращувати потенційних учасників для інших клубів.
Вони в тебе побудуть і потім підуть далі, давайте, я тебе навчу, це Дмитро Верховцев з Києва, буду в тебе ментором, буду передавати.
Тобто я в цих напрямках поступово працюю. І в мене питання, я останнім часом спостерігаю, де за колегами, не те, щоби по ринку в напрямку коучингу,
і психології взагалі, як зараз розвивається, і бачу тенденцію на те, що записують максимально такі, не так, як Юлічка каже, про те, що і світло, і якість, і звук, а навпаки, максимально десь по-домаш
ньому, десь в тому образі, в якому ти є, для того, щоб більше знайомити з особистістю, з людиною.
По вашому досвіду, що краще все ж таки працює, на що можливо робити свій акценти і так далі?
Ох, блін, давай ти, да, окей.
Ну, по-перше, ви повинні робити варіантів тисячі на сцені.
Якщо ви бачите, то ми зараз не знімаємо у студії вже останній рік.
У нас нема більш професійної сйомки, хоча на наступний тиждень я вперше записалася знову.
але в нас майже рік не було професійної зйомки.
Все знімалося на айфон і вдома.
Але світло так і звук так.
Ні, ну, понятно, я маю на увазі без оцих там шалених спецефектів,
якогось шаленого монтажу.
Дивіться, знаєте, як потрібно відслідковувати те, що робити для публіки?
Те, що ви дивитеся і те, що ви зберігаєте, те, що вам подобається,
саме цей образ, бо з цього починається, покажіть мені ваші рольові моделі.
у кого вийшло. Саме з цього ви дивитеся, що потрібно у ринку,
що відгукається вам і надягаєте на себе.
Тому вам потрібно знайти подачу, як це виглядає.
Бо і вдома можна виглядати по-різному.
Подивіться, в нас були дуже кайфові історії.
На минулій моїй квартирі я сиджу, там, де я знімала про хейт.
Там ми говорили, ну що, давайте розберемо хейт.
Там неймовірне світло, бо воно так лягало у такий часовий проміжок у сутках.
А знімаючи з ранку, вже інша картинка, і вона зовсім по-іншому залітає.
Тому дійсно, навіть вдома це може бути зовсім різний формат.
Це може бути дуже дорого і може бути дуже просто.
І просто іноді теж класно, а іноді просто буде ніяк.
Тому вдома від вдома дуже сильно відрізняється.
Теж це потрібно розуміти.
Мене домашня зйомка дуже влаштова.
Дуже влаштова.
Але є зйомки домашні, там де я буду дивитися, думаю, ой, прикольно.
З мікрофончиком, коленочкою, тут таке прям friendly-friendly, таке все.
А іноді це буде, в общем-то, нормальна, але це старательна дівочка.
І от це я слушати вже не буду.
Тому тут така специфіка, чи може бути це там у студії, може бути.
Чому б ні?
Тест на сцену обов'язково буде, там буде просто кресло і стена.
Тоже, що це не обязательно постановка.
Постановки нет.
Зараз вони сильно не потрібні.
Але все одно люди, як любили хорошу картинку,
люди, як любили хороший звук, так і будуть любити.
Людям, як нравилось глазами, так їм все одно, блин, і нравится.
Домашнюю сьемку все равно можна подати достаточно effективно.
І второй момент можна подати достаточно просто.
Ми Ютуб знімаємо на телефон дому.
Я не можу добитися той картинки, яка подобається Ютубу.
Я розумію, що сьомка професіональна, намного краще, зато я знімаю його безплатно, але я розумію, що я розумію професіональні сьомки, тому що навіть це б при правильному світі, трьох камерах, перебив
ки кадра, це було б намного по-другому в тому ж домі, в тому ж зале з цією історією, я розумію, що вони б зробили краще.
І так вони набирають три тисячі просмотров, а так б набирали 12. Але так мені треба, правда, по тисячі доларів доплачувати. Вот здесь є моментик, і я розумію пока по три.
І тут, по цьому, ви должны зрозуміти, що профсіональна сьомка дому теж може бути. А за чого ми беремо постановочну і чого ми беремо домашнюю? Постановочна може бути дому. Тоді це зовсім інший третий
формат. І тут треба знайти все одно картинку, яка дравить аудиторію, а главное, оттестити через те, що ви самі копіруєте, де вам дравиться картинка. Не тільки смысл.
Вот де ви сказали, що дівчина молодец, мальчик молодец, ну інтересно, він там йде, чи він в машині сидить, чи він при цьому розмовляється з дівчинком, чи там світ якийсь.
Ви ж теж обращаєте увагу на естетику, вот посмотрите, яка картинка вам подобається, від цього відповідьте себе, який хочете бути ви.
Вот це буде честніше, ніж хто-либо вам скажет, що буде правильно на ринці.
Окей, дякую.
Леш, ти?
Ух, це такий дуже комплексний питання, що залежить від аудиторії, наприклад, Юля, може ли вийти, да, з бігодями, але на голові є, у нього там з списка українського форбсу 100-500 люди, ну, наверное,
нет.
Не можу, воно дякую.
А якщо у нас аудиторія, наприклад, мамы, дівшки, якщо вам комфортно, то як, почему нет?
Я вже приводив кейс, я не знаю, бачили мені в інстаграмі чи не, що там є така в тіктокі жінчина була без зубов,
яка розказувала про свою життя, ну, і она так і проводила свою консультати за 500 евро за час,
по цьому тему, а почему нет? Все в этом мире ок, тут еще важно под себя подобрати, но, вот, Валерия, я вот не знаю, я вас не вижу, типа, в домашнем таком, типа, спокойном, вы мне не ассоциируйтесь с
условным таким, знаєшки, да, вы что работаете с компаниями, бизнес, работа, активность, то есть у вас, наоборот, такой, мне кажется, вайп простоты, но, да, без там лухари, без, ну, там, не нужно льв
ов, чтоб львы сзади ходили, там, в роллс-ройс стоял, но при этом не супер домашний вайп, например, да, это вот,
Нужно те, що вам відкрікається більше, в якому форматі.
Мені більше відгукуються, коли воно, знаєш, живе, коли не має сценарію, за яким ти рухаєшся,
коли, умовно, є якась думка, яку ти хочеш донести, розкрити, як тобі в моменті захотілося.
Я останнім часом все більше схильна до таких «в моменті».
Бо коли починаєш записувати або десь, чи то вдома зі звуком, зі світлом, чи то десь їхати,
я потім, коли передивляюсь, в мене відчуття, що я б таке не дивилась.
Мені не подобається і на що я буду витрачати на це і час, і гроші.
Ну, це має бути спокійний, кежуал, домашній, тихий стиль.
От і все, якщо вам це комфортно. Я бачу, це так.
Ну, заморачиваться, запариваться не нужно.
Но у вас так, мне кажется, очень, как бы, образ узнаваемый, может быть.
Да, типа, и поэтому, я думаю, що все окей буде.
То есть, то, нужно быть в том, в чем комфортно.
Ну, і в цьому, що касається речі, все равно Instagram дуже реагує на момент,
коли перестають прилистувати вас, да, ну, то есть, поэтому можно
с сценарием,
можна без сценария,
але сценарий дає
можливість, піши і сокращай.
Создати
таке красиве, словесне,
коротке сообщення,
яке убирає все лишнє,
каже лишнє слово, що дає можливість розкрыти
не за минуту, а за 15 секунд.
І 15 секунд, конечно, победять в минуту.
Все, тільки в силу посмотру.
Я вчора
запустила ролик там,
на 8 секунд ми просто сміялися,
я його вберу з ленту, мені було просто интересно.
І він там набрав 20 чим-то тисяч,
взагалі в момент, я думаю, на чому?
Просто люди ждали, що він буде дольше,
і не успевали сойти.
Там 6-7 секунд, да, він там був, і так далі.
Поэтому вопрос смыслової конструкції.
Почему ролик о тому, що 10 правил як за хестит СБ
набереться у чаще всего більше,
потому що він всього 3 секунду,
чем очень больша мысль.
І вот здесь вопрос, імпровизація – це хорошо.
Должні бути ролики там, де ви розказуєте.
Але обся динамика інстаграму любить дуже хлєсткость каждої фрази,
коли смысловий конструкт.
І по цьому сценарі – це не завжди плохо.
Просто дайте варіант тому і тому, варіанту теж бути.
Тоже, щоб не уйти тільки в один стиль.
Ну, опять же, а далі чувствуйте по себе.
Якщо ви дивитеся потім і розумієте, що це не ваше,
то, звісно, добиватися не треба,
тому що ваша чесність це саме головне що тільки є саме для клієнта важна чесність
як і для нас самих не менше ну що поїхали далі важливо да зараз ми будемо вже отримувати
сертифікати будемо офігенними вже ми вже офігенні да будемо ще кротіше я до того що мені цікаво
Реша, на початку, коли ми тільки починали, ще рік назад, ми говорили про ціноутворення,
про скільки може коштувати коуч-сесія.
Ти говорив, що там або вже низька, або вже, типа, вище, що складно бути в середньому.
Як зараз ця ситуація, теж з вашого досвіду, те, що ви спілкуєтесь з багатьма,
бо всі ж підуть ставити свою ціну, я думаю, це теж буде актуально для кожного.
Я розумію, що скільки ти вартуєш, скільки ти відчуваєш, скільки ти користі можеш дати,
і регалії, і артефакти, і все таке, по ринку, як зараз ситуація, я буду дячна. Дякую.
Да, ну, по ринку така ситуація, що ніхто нічого не знає.
Ось, як би, ітоху. Хтось ставив по 200 доларів, і вони зараз не продаються.
Хтось ставив 100, у них все забіто, і вони бояться повищати.
Тобто від внутрішнього, від своєї аудиторії, від своєго окруження від цього відталкуватися
і розуміти, що я можу заводити, і від цього відталкуватися.
Я знаю людей, хто кажуть, що 1500 гривень за сейси – це капець как дорого,
тому що вони там виставляються на Майдли і вони такі, ну це не реал.
А я знаю ті, хто ставить 100 доларів і кажуть, ну за 100 доларів я не дуже хочу общаться з кимось.
Для мене це дешево і вот так.
Але при цьому не хочуть опускати.
Ну, дуже разний момент.
Тобто, я считаю, що на ринці є якась середня статистика по ринку,
але она нерелевантна, бо що є дуже багато ниш, дуже багато нюансів.
Те, хто роботи з бізнесом, хто роботи з відношеннями, парні, непарні, групові, негрупові.
Звісно, що для перестраховки річних генів треба мати хорошу, бачу, бачу, класну, інтересний пакет на 10 сесій,
мати разову сесію за якусь цену, за яку людина може зайти вас пощупати, мати групові для тих, у кого немає денег,
і при цьому себе показувати в інших місцях, де можуть люди з вами познакомитися,
і сказати, що прикольні речі ви розказуєте, а як вам потрапити?
Я, це мій профтык тоже, я мало активнічаю на виступлінях і на івентах,
що мені з кожного виступління івента завжди консультування, продажа і так далі.
Але я просто на практичному не співаю.
Якщо вам потрібні клієнти і ви хочете підняти свою цену, то потрібно активнічати і перебирати, перебирати. Задача яка? Зробити переледос, щоб не було часу на сессію, щоб продавати і почати дорогу.
Потихонечку у старих клієнтів либо переводити нову цену, либо отсеївати.
Тому що... Ой, ми з Юлією говорили, що... Смотрите, це буде неправильно сказати, що неправильно така формувальна формувальна, але якщо на нас вляє третій круг окруження наших друзів, друзів, друзів,
правильно?
Але клієнти, як би не хотілося, як би це була неправильно,
якщо такі професіональна етика, в клієнтах така ж історія.
Якщо ви крутитесь з людьми проблемними, і ще те, які в травме, жертви,
і вони ще не зарабатують, і не хочуть зарабатувати,
то, скоріше, ви в такій аудиторії будете вокруг себя привлекати і собирати.
І це я кажу з точки зрення маркетингу.
Як спеціаліст, як чоловік, в темі психології, навіть, ніде так говорить,
але в плані маркетингу я це сам залишаю, чісно.
як тільки я в консалтингі перішов в своєму вичному.
Хоча в консалтингі я і тим же, що і вы, занимаюсь.
Коучи нам по парту.
Я, як тільки перешов в нишу,
де люди, для них оплата моєго консалтинга
1,5-2 в місяць — це не то, що не послідний день,
і у них, це, условно, виїхати в ресторан вечером,
то у мене перестали появляться
вообще какие-то либо проблемы с тем,
що люди ждуть быстрого результата,
і мені потрібно бороться з їх травмами,
з їх ограниченнями і так далі.
І, наприклад, недавній кейс, мені дуже хотілося взяти когось інтересного на консулт, я не буду говорити фамилию,
але до мене обратися на один із найпопулярних гипнопрактиків, терапевтів в Україні.
І з посилом, що у нас вшов продюсер, ми хочемо пойти на…
С яким конкурентом, блин, і роботи шоком, я не знаю. Це перший раз оке.
Це нормально, Юля, вони бедні.
Типа, да, вони зашли з посилом, я шучу, ні, це оціночне заслаждение, я так не считаю.
Типа, вони зашли і сказали, що ми хочемо запуску, ми хочемо в місяць чистими деньгами забирати 30 тисяч доларів.
Я кажу, що це амбиція, клас, мені подобається, 300 тисячами в год, супер, давайте.
і я кажу, що заробляти 30 чистими, потрібно 25-30 влажити, щоб оборот був 60, і ми там 100% при определенних моментах ми сделаємо, це реально, вони кажуть, класно, у нас тут продюсер, нам щось потріб
но на что-то кушати, може таки, давайте бесплатно 3-4 місяці поработаємо, заработаємо, і потім будемо вже розбиратися, а ви поки за процент поработайте, я кажу, конечно же, нет.
і, в принципі, я навіть не був далі коммунікації,
але я не заблокировався, як я був сказав,
да, звісно, ми так не можем,
але ви там поверене, що ви знайдете того,
з кем вам буде комфортно в такому форматі поработати.
Я, к сожалению, в такому форматі без інвестицій,
ну, я просто не вважаю смысл.
Я свій бізнес с Юлією строю на чужих деньгах і на інвестиціях.
Ми, типо, все бізнеси в будущем будем строити тільки на чужих деньгах і на інвестиціях.
На влаженнях бі свої, все, научились, наконец-то, для этого надо було по-другому.
Да, вот.
Можна я пробувати по цене скажу?
Так, нет, опять же, тут я полностью поддерживаю, нет, много и нет, мало, нет истории, а вот теперь я стою дороже, потому что я завершила обучение.
Є історія, коли аудиторія готова. Я вже приводила пример, як можна повишати ценову політику.
Є разні моменти. В терапії це більш екологічне направлення.
Там обязательно предупрежать о повищенні зарані, повишать на 10-20% медленними слотами.
Вы предупреждаєте зарані, повишаєте в цілому по всему полю коммуникації і вашого консультировання. Чаще всего.
Ну, опять же, є висключення, кожен в цеременому мірі робить, як хочеть.
Але, якщо ми говоримо про слот, я вам приводила пример, як повищаємо денюжку ми.
Першу, ми повищаємо тільки тоді, коли є зайнятость, т.е. коли є востребованість.
Не тоді, коли востребованності немає, не в цей момент.
Тому що, якщо на цій цені ви не можете взяти свого клієнта,
то, значить, ще щось вас не видит, т.е. поле.
Тому, ваша задача – на роботи сначала видений.
Тільки ви видите, ви не перегружені, але ви видите, що в цілому динамика пішла.
Ви оставляєте цих клієнтів, які вас пооплачували по 10 сесій, по 5, ну, какую-то динамику.
Ви оставляєте цих людей, але пишіть тепер новим людям в інстаграм,
тому що, ребят, з 1 числа на следующий місяць я повишаю чек на вот таку стоимость.
Тому всіх, хто зайдуть в цей місяць, welcome по старій ціне.
Потім, ну, буде другая цена без исключення.
Все, і ви пушите це цей місяць, ви об цьому повторяєте два-три рази в неделю, прям красиво, лояльно і так далі.
Ви об цьому говорите, почему, почему сейчас, як відсходять сессії, да, і показуєте.
Даже на сайті написано, с такої дати буду стакати, а вам даже це проговарувати далі не треба, в цьому говорити раз за два за місяць.
Все, і ви готовіте, все, за це час заходять ще люди, хто хотів би, спешив, у кого в полі ви були за місяць, вони дозревають.
І ви потім випадаєте для ринка місяців от 3 до 6.
Чому? Тому що ті люди, які хотіли на предыдущу цену, вони будуть думати, що ви стоїте дорого.
І вони будуть не готові к новій цені.
А ті, які нові, вони повинні сформуватись.
І таким чином формирується новий пласт.
І далі ви можете... А у старихається цінність того, що для всіх це стоїть дороже, а у них стара ціна.
І таким чином можна більш лояльно удерживати якийсь період времени і так далі.
Ну а потім, коли високая цена, треба однозначно договаруватися з собою, щоб не сломатися.
«Вот ко мене не йду, значит, треба понизити, значит, я все остальное».
Нет, там реально от 3 до 6 місяців може бути окно.
На смотленості нової і нового выбора нової ценової політики.
Просто будьте к этому готовы.
Поэтому повышайте тоді, коли ви готові, коли ви по пирамиді масло не сидите на етапі выживання і собирання денег.
Повышати треба тоді, коли ви йдете.
Второй момент, коли вам кажеться, що ви на вживанні, і ви щас потеряєте все гроші. Це ще один момент, треба повишати. Це теж момент, хороє моє. Тобто, якщо ви засиделись, це теж може бути моментом
того, що треба ризковати і ставити на другу цену.
Тому все завістить від контексту, але чаще всего, коли є база, вже существуюча я, це найбільший, найбезопасний способ.
Все.
Ой, Юля, це у тебе там на фоне Мія?
Так, я слышу, як там отіграються ноты.
Так, хорошо. Надеюсь, ответили, правильно, Мах?
Более, чем дякую.
Буду всіх по-очень.
Так, де Христина?
Христина, коли ми будемо в Грузії вже запускати проєкти більші?
Я помню, що там були якісь випроси.
Хто у нас ще з усіх активних, хто хоче додати випрос?
Я зараз в принципі вже систему свою опрацьовую, бо в мене як багатьох було як це скомпонувати, тобто імміграцію, коуч, менторство, закони і взагалі ідея на якому світі, як це все.
Тобто я реально розумію, що менторство – це саме те, що необхідно, його практикую, тобто і тут я цю систему, що якраз ви казали дівчатам, рекомендували, тобто це має бути силою, бо я так або то, або
то, або який ринок, або то, тобто я зараз в усному режимі в коучингу йду якраз на італійський ринок, ну тобто помалесенько я публікую, але український я його тримаю, бо він у мене сильний,
На мене алгоритми, які зміни зараз не вплинули зовсім.
Тобто, ярою, в мене є аудиторія, в мене є довіра і менторство тут заходить чітко.
Я зараз на цьому експериментую.
Штучний інтелект вивчала максимально теж його вивчати і на клод перейшла.
І бачу там потужність, яка є, те, що вчать HGPT, бо він мені не заходив,
бо це було просто штучно-комп'ютерне.
Я навіть бачила, коли читала пости, і я їх зразу закривала.
Тобто ці всі, це не моє.
Ну, і активую, і знову ж таки, Олексій, те, що ви сказали,
активувати те, що нам було дано.
Тобто в планах, в ближчих.
Мені треба було час, бо коучинг – це ніша, яку я взагалі не знала.
Для мене тут все нове.
І просто розумію, інформації багато, почати працювати,
ще раз передивитися, це все, що нам було дано.
але з позиції вже типу ментора, а не новачка, який ні про що.
Ну, ось так, десь для мене це все відбулося.
І навіть вчора класна ораторська майстерність мені підказала,
тобто, де там ми виступали, про конфліктність, про слово,
і було просто підкреслено, де я говорю про те, що я роблю,
про іміграційну систему, про тому, тобто, у мене тональність голосу змінюється,
А де йде про коучинг, про психологію більше туди?
Тобто я там здуваюся, я там не відчуваю.
Бо це не є мірень.
Тобто я беру те, що є, і додаю зараз інструменти,
ті, що ви дали в то, що я маю, в те, що я зараз відчуваю.
Як буде далі, реально розумію, що все змінюється.
Я готова до змін.
Тому, але в більших сильних і більше в такому режимі.
Ось, так що, дослідницький.
на якому висок акаунту в мене зараз українська та мене зараз українська іде і ось по менторству
тобто в принципі в мене і коуч сесії в мене дві клієнтки я зробила систему не готова я була
безкоштовно працювати чесно сказано тобто в мене знань багато і клієнти мої відповідно
мінімальна ставка.
Я їм зробила з таким типу,
тобто перша сесія, вона йде платна,
якщо ми підходимо один другому
з позицій з коуч-менторства,
тоді 10 сесій,
але платити за 9.
Тобто перша вступна, ніби вам йде
як в подарунок. Ось такого плану.
І вони були, 10 ми відпрацювали.
Потім одна сказала,
що треба подумати, і зараз вона повернулася.
Вона сказала, ну це тобто для реалізації
я їй реально допомагаю направляю ділюся оце все тому практика йде і в цьому якраз
тому зараз десь я така мовчазна в цьому всьому да я розумію що я в системі навчальні відстаю
в сенсі що результата але для мене це дуже круті результати те що дали ці базу опору я
навіть відчуваю, навіть деколи, коли вихожу говорити з клієнтом і все, тобто я інакша, навіть якщо це в розрізі коучингу, воно може бути по-інакшому,
бо якщо будемо з коучами, які тут є, я себе типу слабшою відчуваю, якщо по коучингу, ну тобто тут ні, але якщо в розрізі мого бізнесу і мого ринку,
тобто я відчуваю класні кроки вперед, і це відчувається, тому я вам дуже дякую, це реально.
Я не обесценивала ваш опыт, извините, що влезла, касательно среди коучів,
ви так це подчеркиваєте, той же момент, не даєте себе дораскрытися.
У вас сили хватить і предыдущого опыта, і безуслового опыта.
Ви не обесцениваєте то, з чим ви заходите.
Мені сегодня клієнка говорить, блин, Юль, ну як ви це видите?
Я постоянно говорю, вот це, а ви вот так, ви вот так.
Я говорю, господи, я говорю, Сонечка, а я ніколи в житті не пойму,
як строїться фінтех на уровні міжнародного влияния.
Ну то есть все
Поэтому, но я захожу с этим бэкграундом
Она заходит с этим бэкграундом
Не только в миксе рождается что-то
А кому-то очень нужен кочка
Который с очень сильным бизнесовым бэкграундом
С которого он не вышел
Не я в прошлом предприниматель
И теперь я психолог, а я работающее
Сильное звено топ-менеджер в компании
Который влияет на процессы
И я практик в этом
Поэтому, понятное дело, кончинговый инструмент
У меня заточен именно под это поле
Не обесценивайте
Ви сильнее других коучів в своєм профилі авторства, то, що ми говорили, авторства.
І поэтому цей момент обесценивання, який остається, все одно ще прослеживається в житті, кроме як в цій ситуації.
Убираємо. Все з вами нормально. І серед коучів в тому числі.
Якщо ви год выдержали і не сошли, то тут вже теж безправно.
Ніколи не сподівайтеся з іншими, сподівайте свій опыт з тим, що ви обрели і з той пользою, яку ви даєте, і ориентируйтесь на людей, з которими ви працюєте.
А не на фідбек від коучей. А не на фідбек від коучей. Вот серйозно. Услышали, да, мені?
Так, дякую. Дякую, дякую. Це для всіх.
Класно. Хорошо, так що я ще так помню нагласно. Оксана, у вас була робота з людьми? Расказуйте нам.
Ну я в першу чергу, коли вже буде закінчуватися у нас сесія, хочу поблагодарити вас всіх.
Я зараз і починаю так, тому що перше це зазростання, це реально зазростання всередині себе, це мій був такий перший запит, коли я сюди йшла.
Я дуже благодарна Юлі за словами на нашій перші встречі.
«Никогда не закривайте двери, а ставте двери ще для професіонального взрастання в сфере коучинга».
Вот, поэтому очень круто, я дуже довольна за знання, за людей, за знакомства,
за людей, с которими стали намного ближче, це просто кайф.
Насчет професіональної деятельності. Виросла дуже сильно внутри, з-за цього почала себе по-другому позиціонувати. Могу сказати, що мене знали, але стали замечати. Я выступала на трьох конференціях.
Це було на 50 чоловік, на 100, а потім було на 200. І на 200 я прям вже кайфанула, тому що це вже було 50 і 100, я думала, провалюся під землю.
А далі просто кайф-кайф-кайф.
І зараз работаю з мастерами.
Леша, тут теж отдельне спасибо.
Я думаю, ти знаєш, якимось були спротивления.
Работаю з мастерами, беру.
У мене є мастера вже в роботі на пістоянній основі.
Щас чуть затихло, ну, тому що дуже сильна нагрузка, що в твірдій сфері.
І поки з обученнями, з тими вашими екзаменами, господи, прости,
дуже багато реміни уходить, але як тільки все це закінчиться, знову набираю нову групу, хочу взяти 5 чоловік, вже придумала, як я буду далі двигатися і як вести таку мини-свою групу.
Кайф моє, все-таки, благодаря нашим глубинкам і так далі, це зараз про роботу з відкладуванням про кастинації, дійсними в бітимастерах, ну то, що вони все роблять, вони сидять на місці, не можуть пну
тися, і ми роботаємо з цим, і мені поки з цим легче, тому що з психикою, самоцінністю, обидами, самоубийством і так далі роботи дуже тяжко.
Пока теряюсь, як Кіра говорить, пока перестав себе сравнюватися з другими нашими сильніми коучами,
треба було нормально з собою поработати.
Але внутрі виросла капітальна.
І дуже доволна, дуже люблю, дуже хочу бути далі вимістю.
Просто кайф. Лучше рішення, лучше обучення – це 100%.
Хорошо, спасибо. А виходилося по доходу вирости за счет груп?
За счет груп ти маєш віду в коучингі?
Ага, да.
Ну, смотри, вот мы, когда тогда я проводила «Глубинки», потом я себе, вот тогда я взяла, у меня зашло три человека, и я взяла по…
В «Глубинах», да?
Да, ко мне зашли люди, то есть, потом я брала просто на индивидуалки, но уже платные, ну, то есть на первые пробные вот эти сессии, я не знала, какую ставить цену.
І коли там в той, Маше, ти, по-моєму, спрашивала, я себе придумала так. Я пощупаю ценовую спроможність своєї аудиторії і з їх сторони ціність моїх консультацій. І ставила просто це за донат.
І я, хоча у мене дівчонки були не тільки з Європи, а й з України, я думала, це буде там 500-700 гривень. Минімальна оплата була 1500 гривень. Максимально було 2,5.
І тому я поняла, що моя аудиторія – це мінімум 2-2,5 точно, то є як входна.
І потім, ну на пакет-сейси я щас ставлю 400 евро, це на 10 сейси.
Більше пока не можу, не чувствую себе сильніше внутрішньо.
Коли будуть вже якісь стабильні результати у кого-то,
коли можна буде кем-то хвастатися, тоді вже можна повищати.
Ну, клас, супер.
А ви сказали, що можна раніше, але дай Бог, щоб ви увиділи скоріше результаты.
І головне, щоб ви їх не пропустили.
Знаєте, іноді можна їх обесценивати, що це недостаточний результат,
а клієнти іноді достигають результату після того, коли от нас нашли інсайд і його взрастили.
Тобто, щоб ви не були ожідаючим бойцом, коли ви повлияли, просто не увиділи цього.
Тому с уважением к своєму труду, коли ви видите, що сесія заканчується плюсом і людина береться в собі действи, це вже победа.
Це знаєте, це як в контракті з юристом. Мені спросили, ви відповідаєте за результат клієнта? Говорю, ні, звісно.
Що це за питання? Що це за питання? Откуде це? Ну, тобто, я відповідаю за свою роботу, за качество своєї роботи.
Причем тут результат клиенту?
Он же участвует в результате?
Как я могу заставить клиенту?
Ой, а це ви взрастили дуже сильно, я извиняюсь, перебила.
Вот це, що не все на тебе, а що відповідальність тож на клієнте,
це вам отдельний респект.
І в другий момент.
Ми на першій сесії, у нас є можливість настроитися там,
де ви це говорите, о тому, що я тут бессильна,
наскільки вам треба.
То есть, якщо вам треба, то мені точно треба.
Але ми не можемо грати, що мене буде нужніє, чим вам.
Тоді ми точно проіграємо.
Тому це честність.
Тому дивіться по результату.
В ресурсі ли виходить людина, с пониманням різепросу.
Це і є результат.
А не тільки в життя його побіду.
Класно, коли ви вже розгналися на стільки, що ви бачите життя і побіду.
Пойміть ще такий момент.
У мене зараз категория людей, с которими я в цьому працюю, вони все побідути.
Нелегко видеть в їх побідах, ну, в їх житті побіда.
Вони все приходять вже в силі, їм хочеться усилення.
І, понятне діло, коли їм дали буст, підтримку, драйв,
вони ще більше, вони привыкші к побіду.
Тому, якщо ориентироватися тільки на, там, у мене кожен кейс заканчивається побіду,
у них у всіх є точка Б, ну, так вони ж приходять в позиції зовсім іншої сили, да?
Тому що чек определяє ще їх предыдущий путь,
і вони вже всі по 10 раз були у психологів до мене.
Прошли личні терапії, чаще всего.
Клиент приходить.
Да, с ним тяжелее, потому что надо ювелирнее.
Но они заточены на победу.
Но був же период, когда женщины или мужчины не могли,
не были способны к такому количеству побед.
На другом этаже финансовая оплата, это тоже влияет.
Поэтому не ждите сразу побед.
Травмированной женщине, сложной жизненных обстоятельствах,
нужно больше времени, чтобы себя залечить.
А если вы будете ориентироваться только на результат,
Наверное, результат буде сложнее.
Уверенность чуть дольше формирується,
Чем после двух или пяти сессий, или десяти.
Поэтому не привязывайте себя
Только к результату на этом этапе.
Потому что можно сыграть против себя.
Привязывайте к тому,
С какой целью зашел человек на сессию,
И получил ли он ответ на этой сессии,
Сформировал ли он ответ на от нуля до десяти,
Насколько вы довольны сессией.
Что надо добавить, чтобы у вас была десятка.
И если у вас там шесть из десяти
Говорят на десять, или на восемь,
На девять, на десять,
на висшій категории, да, там, оцінки, все, це – победа.
Це вже і говорить у вас.
Судіте себе в моменті вашого результату, а не в моменті результата клієнта.
Спасибо, посмітили.
Хорошо, бусинки, давайте далі.
Да, у кого є якийсь който момент, вопрос, питання, запит, жалоби не треба.
Так, давайте, піднімайте руку, або я анекдот не почну розказувати, ні, ти просто точечно спрашиває всіх потихоньку.
Так? Хорошо. О, Тетяна. А, тут ще руки є, хто без камери, все, так, Тетяна?
Не захотіла анікдотів твоїх, Лешу Русалюч.
Так, Тетяна, зі звуком буде легше вас слухати.
Так, так, всім привіт. Я теж, Леша, хочу анікдоти, але спочатку просто хотіла,
Дуже сильно подякувати за навчання. Я пройшла сюди після ICF і я та людина, яка завжди була в пошуках навчання.
Ще один курс, ще треба якось посилити себе, щоб піднімати вартість, щоб вийти на новий рівень клієнтів і так далі.
І зараз, от з цим навчанням, ну, по-перше, дуже дякую ще за транзактний,
ну, це просто взагалі топ of the top, я не знаю, просто one love, я обожнюю.
Просто закохалась, ніколи до цього не стикалась з транзакційним,
але тут я просто дивлюсь по результатах клієнтів, ну, це просто взагалі вау для мене.
Це для мене головний показник, от якраз в роботі завжди був,
Тобто не сертифікатами я якось для себе вимірю, а от якраз результатом.
Що наче для мене зараз вже немає відмазок, щоб не йти далі.
І от якраз і в проявлення, і в більший чек, і в принципі в те, щоб просуватись активно.
Тому я вам сильно вдячна за академію.
Взагалі не знаю, що б я робила, якби не пішла сюди рік тому.
Я просто аналізувала для себе, що це якраз рік тому, в цей час, я така думала, приймала рішення, чи йти, чи не йти.
І краще б я взагалі не знала, що тут відбувається, якщо б я не пішла.
Це в мене завжди така думка, що не розказуйте мені, що я втратила, якщо б я не пішла.
Але я дуже щаслива, що я тут, і у нас крутецька група, і менторський склад, і взагалі команда.
Просто, я не знаю, це якийсь новий рівень, якого я до цього ніколи не бачила, але вже, знаєте, як сказати, не розбачити вже.
Тобто, на менше вже не хочеться погоджуватись. Це прям дуже круто.
Прямо так от всім обіймашки, всій команді, всім-всім-всім прям дуже вдячно.
Супер, дуже приємно. Харшо, окей, окей. А так, я от заметил, що у багатьох наших, ну, у нас з вами, у багатьох є в шапці профіля ваш Телеграм, да? У кого-то він більше підписчиків, у кого-то менше,
но, да, у кого-то, кстати, дуже хороша історія про те, щоб у вас був Телеграм-канал, але якщо там 10 людей, 20, 30, 50, наважливо, собіраєте там свої мислі, базу знань, думки, кружочки.
Хай це буде просто для ваших клієнтів існуючих, які хочуть зайти, щоб це був такий елемент прогріва, щоб людина могла зайти і подивитися.
Я взагалі вважаю, що на Телеграм-канал не потрібно розфокусуватися, тому що це контент невіральний і він не має шансів залетіти в рекомендаціях і збрати підписників і продажі.
Але для прогріву, якщо вам хочеться заражити мислі, то класно. Тетяна, я бачила, якраз локаунти 6 канал. Класно, що він є, але не забрасуйте його, а у систему дозволяйте своєї думки.
Наталія, давайте.
Всім доброго вечора. В мене питання, чесно кажучи, нема, бо з тією інформацією, що ви дали, просто треба робити і отримувати результати. Тому питань нема і так з того, що я робила, і так же класні
результати, і клієнтів більше стало, і навіть мені цікавіше стало вести соціальні мережі.
І справді я теж хочу подякувати за таке неймовірне навчання, і що стільки всього було в цьому навчанні, і настільки це все комплексно повпливало і на мене, як на особистість, і на мою експертність, і
взагалі на проявлення,
Що навіть неможливо передати, щоб за рік настільки стати іншою людиною і отримати тут розуміння, як Таня сказала, що це вже неможливо розбачити, тих людей, які тільки бачать сильні сторони, коли не
обезцінюють, а навпаки підсилюють,
І коли створилося реально своє ком'юніті, і я так думаю, що вже до кінця життя будемо йти разом. Тому величезне дякую за всі інструменти. І єдине, що я для себе точно винесла з цього навчання, що роб
и, і все в тебе буде.
Тому ви дали реально стільки інструментів, що ще можна їх розбирати і практикувати протягом року точно, і отримувати результати, і насолоджуватися взагалі проявленням.
Воно почало подобатись, скажімо так. Якщо до цього інстаграми і ведення взагалі цього всього, це був якийсь жах, від якого тікали, то зараз це прям цікаво, і залишилось тільки до кінця зрозуміти свій
стиль.
І найголовніше, тут історія про те, що особисті сні трансформації, саме вони дають можливість зовсім по-інакшому продавати, говорити і так далі.
Бо це голос, яким ви користуєтеся. Якщо він повнений сумнівів, то ви таким голосом продаєте себе.
Якщо він сповнений уваги і поваги до себе, то він не звучить зовсім інакше у всьому, що ви робите.
І по довірі до вас саме тому зверніть на це увагу.
А ще Надочка запускає ретрит.
Вообще, красотка.
Офлайн, вообще забирає дівчат.
І взагалі, просто не...
О, це добре.
Звикольно.
Круто, да.
Елена, давай, туди виходься з членом.
Ну, випросів, як би, ні.
Вже випроси тільки к себе, що я буду з цим далі робити.
А так, звісно, я з собою горжусь.
Я почала виходити в прямі ефіри.
Я стала менше говорити то, що не потрібно, і буквально вчера на последній остановочці я поняла цей онлайн продукт, з яким я сюди зашла, що я хотіла онлайн продукт, але я його не бачила.
І вот буквально вчера у мене тук шух,
Благодаря, опять-таки, спикерам,
Учителям нашої групи.
І, конечно же, всім большое спасибо,
Та, що я имеюся зараз,
Така, як я зараз.
Я дуже виросла в своїх глазах,
В глазах своїх клієнтів.
Діти мною гордяться для мене,
Це дуже ценно.
Тим більше, що вони взрослі,
У них своя життя.
І я ще гаражусь тим, що я не слилась.
дуже хотіла слиться, тому що у мене нічого не може, я нічого не можу, і вони всі знають, що я древнія, я влеві ненавидела, і я тут не успеваю за цими новими словами, але, опять-таки, сильна команда у
чителей, сумасшедша, крутая платформа, на якій це все зробило, і нереально шикарні все спеціалісти в групі,
Котори підтримували
Котори, ну, я благодарна
Очень всім
І, звісно ж, я буду рекомендовать
Эту академію, тому що
У мене спрашивають, за счет чого ти змінилась
Мой круг общения
Который на витянутой руке
Вот, поэтому, спасибо большое, Юля
За це пространство
Держку
Ми здаємо все вместе, поэтому здесь правда
Про всіх місців
Спасибо большое
Ну що Юльчик так всіх вітаю і вже тут пішли не питання вдячності то я не можу але ми можемо і на
питання на всяк випадок в мене питання немає тому що ну я ще минулого разу ділилась я трішечки
з інстаграму з цього проявлення всього випала через там певні питання свої зараз вже трішки
Відновила ресурс, тому повертаюся.
І навіть те, що там зараз немає клієнтів, я особою проявлялася.
Раз колись там вийти і щось сказати, тому їх і немає.
Сподіваюся, що це все нас догоню і все буде.
Але по вдячності це реально навчання, яке, по-перше, всі вже ділилися,
воно сформувало нас самих, воно зростило нас.
і ті знання, які ви даєте, і те, наскільки ви вкладаєтесь,
наскільки ви вірите в кожного з нас, ну це просто неймовірно.
Це надає таку силу, таку впевненість, бо для мене питання впевненості,
воно стояло, то зараз оця віра, вона дуже посилює.
І ще хочеться окремо сказати дякую саме за приклад якості взагалі навчання,
продукту, щедрості, всього того, що ви даєте, тому що я нещодавно
була на такому інтенсиві, ну, класний, нікого не знецінюючи, просто сам приклад.
Але там продавали workbook, ну, щось там типу якийсь, ну, якийсь там планшеточку
з додатковими питаннями за 100 гривнів, додатково, хоча продукт сам коштував там
скількись там тисяч гривень. Ну, тобто, а тут нам все, візьміть тільки, тільки візьміть.
Тому і цей приклад реально беру для себе, бо до такого хочеться повертатися.
Тобто, дійсно, продукт і якість продукту – це, насправді, найголовніше.
І ви прям це показуєте не тільки на словах говорити, а показуєте прикладом.
Тому дякую дуже за власні зміни, за приклад цієї щедрості, якості, всього того, що ви даєте.
І найголовніше – віри в нас. Це дуже прям цінно.
Віри в нас – це 100%. В вас – дуже багато.
Але вона не безосновательна віра.
Ви реально прошли хардкор, да, отсюда в любом случае невозможно уйти без знаний, да, каждый возьмёт свой багаж ровно столько, сколько нужно, чтобы добить свои какие-то внутренние позиции, ну, вы
большие молодцы, и поэтому за доброту, даже отклик от того, как вы нам говорите, это дорогого стоит. Вам огромное спасибо.
Спасибо большое, класс, очень приятно слышать. Мы стараемся сделать, и приятно слышать, что это получается. Да, Маш?
Тут вже пішли слова вдячності. Думаю, я люблю цифри і по фактам. Перше, що я зробила, тільки що я підрахувала, і я така вау, я зробила 823 тисячі 160 гривень з коучингу, з інстаграму, менше ніж за р
ік завдяки MCMM.
Це вау, це круто, тому що до цього там було максимум 47 тисяч і таке інше.
Тому зробила фламецький продукт, запустила річне наставництво,
куди пішли наші одногрупники, коучі, ментори, і я така вау, це теж круто,
це теж рівень, де ми партнери, де ми підсилюємо одна одну,
де ми точно йдемо далі, не зливаємося і таке інше.
Це неймовірня впевненість, трансформація, транзакційний аналіз, НЛП, коучинг, філософія,
яка важко для мене давалась, але теж для розширення, теж круто, психіатрія.
Я вчора казала, вже жоден шизик від мене не скрийться.
Тому, Юль, твої менторські сесії, кожне слово було під запис цілий блокнот.
У мене Юлія Козачкова, прямо мої фрази, тому що коли захожу до таких льошані, теж маркетинг, ці таблички, це все, ну це просто.
Я такого, я на початку казала, такої щедрості, тако, що, вам щось оце потрібно, пожалуйста, беріть і сьогодні теж, що, вам презентацію, беріть, беріть, беріть, беріть, беріть.
Та, блин, ну я, я такова, я це впроваджую в своїх продуктах для своїх дівчат, і вони теж отак відкриваються очі.
Дякую за цю рольову модель, як може бути.
Дякую за ваше відношення, за вашу енергію,
скільки ви вкладаєтесь і те, що ви говорили на початку,
що дійдуть не всі.
Оці слова мені дуже вбилися і закорбувалися,
це дійсно так.
За те, як ви, які гнучки, як швидко адаптуєтесь,
як швидко реалізуєте, створюєте, внідряєте.
Ну, коротше, назавжди в моєму серці стали для мене трампліном, для мене, для моєї сім'ї.
І, звісно, я піду давати це іншим жінкам в маси, тому вам в карму там просто мільярд плюсиків.
Просто вам, просто вам, отуди вам, так. Дуже багато від щирого серця вам дякую.
Так, ну що, любімо наші. Хтось хоче ще сказати, дамо вже вам відпочивати. Ми великі, молодці. Давайте, Юрочка.
Секунду, секунду, секунду.
Там є Юра, його клод, знаєте, засасує в екран, і він руки оттуда вирває, ось такий, щас скажу сам.
Да, щас включу, щоб качество звука було.
А кого поється?
У мене, звісно. Все, закріли вже двері, все, извините.
Раз, два, три, раз, два. Проверіть настрійки.
Мене слышно?
Не знаю.
Да, все отлично.
стойте
вот так должно быть
і так слышно, і так було до цього
не слышно, не слышно
тебе слышно по всякому
ты не слышишь, ми слышимо гавна
какая разниця, ти ж нам говориш, а не себе
давай вже розказуй
так він нас не слышит
мене зум вызвал звукове предупреждення
о, щас должно вроде быть
да, давай, давай
А, серйозно?
Ти був всі свої коментарії, вони були тут, не переживай.
Ти нас не слухав, але ми коментували те, що ти нас не слухав.
Прикольно.
Короче, щоб не повторити це за всіх, тому що тут слова вдячність і ще щось точно мають місце бути велико, нейбірно, фантастично.
Але хочеться щось здати унікальне від себе.
Подумався, а куди я міг ще потратити п'ятерку баксів, щоб настільки кайфанути?
І в мене немає відповіді на це питання.
Тому що що таке п'ятерка баксів? Це місяць прожити якесь життя.
Але це не рік якоїсь такої взаємодії глибокої, класної, з людьми і так далі.
П'ятерка баксів – це машина? Ну яка машина за п'ятерку баксів? Ну що ти купиш?
Немає реально якогось кайфовішого місця, інвестицій, виходячи з того, стільки я в житті побачив, куди можна вкинути п'ятерку, і настільки кайфанути, трансформуватися, насолодитися і так далі.
Якщо мене хтось спитає, яку інвестицію зробити до п'ятерки баксів, щоб кайфанути і так далі, я точно скажу, йдіть в МСММ, зайдете коло своїх людей, якщо у вас є музей, ви зможете це окупити, тому що
я це окупив в рамках групи,
навіть нашої взаємодії і так далі. І це не те, що просто окупив, це те, що дійсно лишиться в житті, в серці.
Тут точно є такий момент, який ти будеш згадувати на своєму смертному одрі, називаємо це так.
Тому що є люди, які вклали реально якусь частинку життя, і люди, з яких я буду безмежно втопити і вболювати, і вони точно про це знають.
і за цим безмежна вдячність, тому я ніколи нікуди не інвестував на стільки приємно 5 тисяч доларів
з точки зору фінансів, з точки зору любові, з точки зору того, що тут створилося
це підтверджують цифри, це підтверджують факти того, що скільки людей ви зібрали на 10 місяць
я перепрошую мати 30 людей з 40 в групі в живому режимі
це фантастика, це фантастика з точки зору будь-яких бізнес-показників і так далі
тому що люди 10 місців віддають свої вихідні кожен тиждень, сидять з вами, доходять до кінця, це фантастика, це просто неймовірно.
Я сам тут сиджу, я кайфую, це фантастика, це просто мої аплодисменти.
І тут хочеться просто кожному підтвердити оцей шлях, гордіться ним, насолоджуйтеся ним, проживіть його, відчуйте його.
який шлях ви пройшли, які взаємодії ви створили, який приклад ви показуєте,
частину якого прикладу ви стали, тому що візьміть оцей приклад і несіть далі у світ.
Я вважаю, що ця академія родила набагато більше, ніж просто 30 людей, які слухали вас кожен тиждень.
Ця академія дала 30 людям приклад того, які продукти можна створювати, які приклади можна показувати,
Як можна людей змінювати, в яке оточення можна подати, і яке натхнення можна створити. Це фантастика, просто. Чесно, я не знаю, що тут щось сказати.
Кайфуйте, насолоджуйтеся, любіть один одного. Тут кожен створив вже якусь свою групку, напевно, людей.
У мене точно створилося, з окремими людьми, окремі зв'язки. Я безмежно вам за це вдячний. Чесно, якщо ви мені рік назад сказали,
Підеш ти ще раз сюди, я б сказав, забирайте мої гроші, забирайте все, не дайте мені жодного шансу злитися.
Тому вам безмежна велика вячність за все, що тут створилося. Воно точно набагато дорожче і точно ніяк не може оцінити це грошима.
Тому що воно на рівні клітинок в тілі, тих відчуттів, які тут лишаються і будуть продовжувати своє життя.
Що ми стали таким оратором, що капець-капець.
Як ви всі говорите, це просто дамарушок.
Дякую, Юр.
Це дуже цікаво.
І вам дуже цікаво, що ви даєте такі слова произносити.
Класс.
Снєжечка, давай вже по словечку.
Всім привіт, всім добрий вечір, Юлія, Олексій.
Ви скористалися останніми можливостями, щоб ми тут всі разом подякувати.
цьому товаристу перш за все Юлі і Олексію за те що ви створили дійсно доєднусь Юра до твоїх слів
хоча ти будеш знов здивований що я з тобою погоджуюсь мені приємно коли ти дивуєшся від мене
приємно тебе здивовувати класна взаємодія двох от зовсім паралельних світів я би так сказав
ти знаєш я не пам'ятаю та геометрія звичайна геометрія кому вивчаємо в школі паралельні преміни
перетинаються але та геометрія завдяки люди які полетіли в космос і в клідувачі яка паралельні
прямі перетинаються Юрто ми маємо багато точок дотику да і скористаючись тим ну що да дійсно дякую за
цей приклад якості да як ви показали у всьому у всьому я багато де вчилася зокрема там в СІФ основну
свою освіту колочингу здобувала і багато шкіл пройшла і багато МСМ пройшла але ви задали дуже
високу планку організації і це прослідковує це усе Команда класна взагалі ваша підтримка ніхто
сьогодні не сказав про підтримку я хочу сказати ваша підтримка ваші дівчата хлопці там за кадром
да чи то була одна людина яка зі мною спілкувалася чи то було кілька людей я не бачила різниці
тому що очевидно напевно якісь є стандарти якості які ви виховуєте в себе всередині в компанії
і це завжди було настільки призємно настільки швидко відповідь на питання настільки там допомога
Підтримка в тому числі, десь там якісь були моменти перед виступом, не хвилюйтесь, максимально все, що могли, я також би хотіла відзначити тих прекрасних дівчат, хлопців, які там працювали. Це дуже
круто.
Про мене. Ясно, що це була інвестиція. Часу, інвестиція, гроші. Чи відбила? Відбила і заробила. Чи відбила тільки на тих техніках, які тут здобула? Не знаю, я так не рахувала, тому що я комплексно
вже тут працюю.
Ну я думаю так на дума на тих техніках також відбила завдяки зокрема і нашій групі в тому
числі великий вклад які приходили приходять до мене далі індивідуальних коучів
що для себе зрозуміло вийшла з трамваєю Юрій я вийшла з трамваєю
а я час від часу коли ахуєнно коли працюю я знаю про що я говорю
так коли я працюю там над якимись моментами з клієнтом а я дозволяю собі виходити Юр
з того трамває ось збагатилася я збагатилася дуже великою кількістю арсеналу працюючих
технік крім того крім того мене якийсь такий відбувся ссу в тому плані що я почала створювати
свої техніки не знаю можливо це критична маса знань яких я здобула так якщо я колись думала
боже а як це а як це то зараз я бачу з якої техніки куди я хочу всунути і що в мене буде там
своєю це вже мене виділяє прім того всього знаєте я здобула дуже велику силу всередині
собі я точно знаю хто я я більше не йожик в тумані як то манекдоті два йожика в тумані
типу куди ми йдемо та похрен куди ми йдемо хто ми я знаю куди я йду я знаю хто я я знаю як мені
туди йти я маю свою цінність я коуча і я її твердо носу на ринку коучингу і мені вдається
Юля, дуже розділяю твої чи ваші слова, я так і не знаю, як я можу, чи на ти, чи на ви, ось ця фраза, що, коли ви ставите певну ціну, підіть в цей дискомфорт тимчасовий, витримати ціну, не погоджуват
ись на менше, я так і дію, і раніше я боялась так діяти,
Коли я відмовлялася від чогось, маючи свою ціну, я потім жаліла.
Але впродовж того року в мене було кілька таких етапів, коли я не погоджувалася на меншу ціну.
І це було завжди в плюс, тому що слідом за тим приходила дуже крута пропозиція, яка мені покривала все, це давала мені зробити.
Тому я дуже дякую, що ви допомогли мені знайти ще більшу мою цінність на ринку коучу, ніж я мала.
це дуже круто я підвищила з чек я спокійно говорю про це я не розмінююся в мене є клієнти
Блін що буде Олексій якщо я нарешті сяду за вашу табличку чи за твою табличку і все це зроблю
тому що досі в мені вже вона пішла в АЄ агент в АІшку Юр яку витурюють з університету
ну ми ще не знаємо її витурюють з університету но вона готує мені сайт вона мені готує
клод-агента так що будемо активно працювати в тому напрямку також але я за екологічність я за
максимальні запити від клієнта дозволи і так далі тому подібні речі це я і я ж теж не хочу від
себе десь так десь так втікати від тої яка я є знаю свою ТП знаю своє все і що дякую за транзактний
аналіз коли я ще вивчала коли почала от слухати владу деякі лекції мене почали наштовхувати на там
певні моменти потім прийшла наша я забула на жаль як звати бо тільки три лекції було ну забула
перепрошую за стратегічного Юля да вона там теж одну фразу сказала і я взяла одне з другим з
з'єднала і зараз будую свою систему коучингу яка буде точно відрізняться на ринку від більшості
вона буде велика вона буде дорога вона буде потужніше але я більше не боюся туди то я не боюся
йти в ціну я не боюся йти в довгострокову тому дякую вам за все також
А я рада була услышати і про Клод, і про малышку твою.
Це прямо про гибкость.
Да, треба под себе настраивать любого новшества,
но не бойтесь изменений, не бойтесь больших цен,
не бойтесь інноваций, не бойтесь цифровизиції.
Це все одно неизбежно все.
Чем смелее ви йдете в то, що вас отталкивает
і даже где-то тригерит, тем більше ви свободи получите.
особливо на ринке на ринке все інструмент я тоді саїшкою я не то щоб баба яга проти була
мене було тільки питання як оце з клієнтом говорити-говорити-говорити-скокійно
вони вже адекатна до всього а перешта вони адекатна штука тому всім а і ще хочу сказати народ
дівчата ну в основному дівчата бо і з дівчатами більше так те що я найбільше тут здобула найбільше
що я тут здобула, крім знань, крім всього, ну да, це да, боже, люди, люди, ви прекрасні, ви всі прекрасні, ви просто всі прекрасні,
не втрачаєте себе, ваш чат, здобула тут кількох, навіть, мені здається, і, ну, подруг, Аліна, Аня, Настя, моя, боже, Валерія,
ми ж баді з неї, ми так кушемо одне одне, ми таки зараз вечір, ну, це просто, люди вас обажають.
Клас, це не дякую.
Наталі.
Всім добрий вечір.
Добрий вечір.
Юлія, коли ти дивишся, я така думаю, що що сказати?
Скажу я правду.
Знаєш, це буде трішки відрізнятися від інших, але завжди всі дивляться, що скажуть.
Я не психолог, я не коуч, я не ментором була.
Але я хочу сказати з іншої сторони для вас на моєбутнє,
як там кейс, клієнти, я зайшла на ММСМ, це було за 3 секунди.
Я клієнт Юлія особистий, після всіх сесій, коли я прийшла до Юлії,
і в один момент, коли Юлія сказала, я буду запускати школу,
і це було, я виметаю цей момент, коли ми їхали в машині,
у мене даже не було, скажімо там, сумніви, що я туди піду.
У мене було питання те, що, а що я буду з цим робити?
І я вирішила це відкласти і відчути саме з тим, що я буду робити вже в самому процесі.
І тоді, коли є фраза там, що якщо у вас є цілі, це не записано в календар,
це дуже важливо записувати і робити зразу.
Звідси я винесила все.
Саме робити в цьому.
Що мені це дало? Мені дало це великий буст бізнесі.
Клас. Саме в бізнесі масштабування.
Особисті клієнти, вони якось приходять через бізнес знайомих, через знайомих, якось це відбувається.
Тут я практикую.
Ну, і саме головне, хочу вам сказати,
що, напевно, якщо у вас є відчуття і ви хочете, треба йти.
Юля, тут дуже тобі дякую за ту енергію,
за ту підтримку, яку ти давала особисто і даєш на сьогоднішній день.
І я знаю, скільки це часу все-таки.
Це велика машина бізнесу, яку треба підтримувати.
Я вам вважаю, що всі рекомендації, які були з кожного,
що додобувалися, вам примножалися.
А там стосовно клієнтів воно все буде. Головне, що були ті люди. Завжди люди заходять з упереченням того, що це можливо мені не понадобиться. Через деякий час у нас багато хтось там відпав. Але я
точно можу сказати, що це можна використати в особистому житті, в бізнесі і в оточенні. Тому що це інвестиція, яка не тільки тебе збагачує, а й збагачує твоє оточення. Це не буде заберете час. Дякую.
Дякую. Це цікавий кейс. Зовсім іншого погляду нація. Нас було б більше. Нас правді. Там були ще людські обставини. Тільки в нас відболилося люди, бо охотилося. Тот же Волков, він би доходил. Но він
зараз, к сожалению, його забрали ТЦК, і він слушав, і так далі.
Тому у нас є хлопці, які там встановилися по здоров'ю. Нічого не комментируювати не хочу.
Тому будуть хлопці, які вернуться наступний поток, просто вони не змогли доходити.
Тому у нас доходимості більше, ніж той процент, який вам кажеться.
Просто там є обстоятельства. Некоторі хлопці, які дуже хотіли до конца добыть,
але є, бувають в житті ситуації, коли треба відстановитися.
Тому негаторим ми дали каникулы, причем на два року, даже вперед, пока не закроються якісь ситуації.
Там, де є желання, повірте, там у частиців з тих шести чи семі, а, сім чоловік у нас не доходило, три чоловіка – це ті люди, які не дійдуть далі.
Тому у нас відпало чотири всього чоловіка, якщо говорити про статистику в чистій воді, ну, три чоловіка ми поки держимо в ожиданні, скажімо так.
І дай Бог, щоб у них все сложилось так, щоб вони дошли занову.
Вот.
Поэтому і Волкова тож дождемся, і все буде нормально.
Все, Васенька.
Знаєш, не даремно в мене тут клубнічка, і MCMM – це оця клубнічка з городу, але протягом всього року.
Протягом всього року. І не та така напічка, а оця саме соковита, травнева така оця.
І це і є для мене MCMM, хоча з клубнічкою – це дуже маленьке порівняння, тому що я до MCMM і я після MCMM.
це дві дуже різні людини і я дякую собі що спочатку тригер російської мови на коли ми разом були
спікерами я це відкинув да я пішов від его і ну ще коли все починалось блог був російський да
мене це тригерило я тобі це писав ділився тоді і тепер і коли вже українською все і навіть
І тут великий кайф в цьому. Тому я за це дякую. Дякую за Софію Роденко, про яку ти теж зараз цей, тому що ми з нею з листопада були баді, і ми зараз з нею далі є, я з нею тепер по Аївці, і Клод супер
, ну, типу, прям факт-факт.
Відбив чи не відбив, там на початку МЧП добряче віддало, зараз тільки практика зміни переконань, ну мінімум дві тисячі доларів принесла, ну тобто є 150 доларів менше не ціню, це от навіть, знаєш, я
говорив, нас Денис давав на цьому, на ураторському, давав техніку гамбургера, своротнього зв'язку, тобто коли ти даєш плюс, потім мінус, потім знову плюс.
Тільки заради цієї техніки вартувало прийти сюди, щоб змінити своє життя і почати відповідати гамбергерам.
Бо от це все. Тому безмежно дякую, я в грі далі і в принципі вірю, що в третій потік піде двоє-троє моїх людей.
Далі буде, вже питаються. Тому великого процвітання, великого успіху і я гордий бути в МСМ.
До речі, Климова йде в третій потокі Климова, Рума, Ілона, Светлічна, там такий зв'язковий состав заходить, людей, хто вибрав. Така група виходить.
Тепер можу сказати, знаєш, вона так каже, Вась, Вась, а розкажи мені за МСММ. Каже, та спитай Юлі, та якщо я Юлі спитаю, то потім її продажники будуть мене допискали.
Ні, ми ж не продаємо, ви ж видели, як ви випадаєте.
Я і це сказав, я і це сказав, тому вот заклинув прямо радий. Супер.
Она переживала, що на квартиру купила, що сейчас она не готова зайти полна сумма.
Там ми просто зробили інші услові по оплаті, коли їй буде удобно, і все, і вопрос закрили.
Человеческий фактор, як і ко всім, у вас у многих були свої услові захода.
Тому просто вопрос, где-то вовремя, а где-то не вовремя, все.
Ну, сильная, там очень тоже сильный такой, сильный состав по личностям.
Ну, вони будуть, звісно, і кусатися, тому що це такі личності, які вміють це робити.
Ну, буде цікаво побачити, як третя група буде функціонувати.
Наступний наш рік ми можемо тільки на твої менторські приходити, так?
Да, а ви хочете ще куди-то?
По Прошки будемо говорити. Давайте, у нас Прошки можна буде рішати.
Будете говорити, що ви хочете, і будемо думати, як це закривати.
У Прошки, ну, ви ж в доступі, ви ж понимаєте, да, це як семейство.
Дякую! Як ти любиш говорити від землі і до неба, і назад мільярд мільйонів разів.
Добре, давайте далі. Дякую вам, сонночки. Коті, давайте 10 минут, щоб вложитися, добре?
Я не віжу, напевно, я.
Всім привіт. Я тільки підключилася недавно,
тому що з 4-х втрата випало 900 км з Солнечного Багарі до Солнечного Одесу.
З температурою, з соплями.
Хожу тут по отелю Босовце, але не могла не включиться.
Ровно 10 місяців назад мені проводила Аня, ой, Настя проводила,
як це називалося тоді, я заявку оставляла на поступління,
тому що мене захотелось стати коучем, і я думаю, куди ж пойти вчитися, і тут Юля говорить, я запускаю.
У мене даже мисля не було вибору вже.
Шла я на третю операцию, я взагалі не знала, з нею выйду чи нет.
І як-то так, знаєте, зашла в такому станію і вихожу в такому станію.
Но я просто щастлива за те, що ці десять місяців я встановлення прожила.
а здесь получила 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9 модуль, я говорила, що я не коуч, я точно не коуч, в кожному модулю заходила, я точно не коуч, і на 10 модулю я кажу, да, я коуч-ментор, ще какой, ще какой,
потому що дуже плодотворно работала останній місяць,
Тому дуже благодарна. Благодарна Алексію, всій команде, всіх, кого ми бачили лично і кого ми не бачили. Те, хто з залаштунками. Я знаю, що з залаштунками завжди дуже багато роботи проводить невидимая
команда і їм отдельно благодарю. Можете мені передати, будь ласка. Благодарю її лично вас за те, що організовали такий бізнес-проект.
І тут я встретила своїх. Благодарна каждому первенцу вашому, да?
Скільки їх було? Тридцять? Не знаю, скільки було. Тридцять, да, по-моєму, у нас було?
Каждому благодарна, с каждим соприкоснулася, с каждого обнимаю
і надіюся, що ми будемо продовжувати плодотворне наше общення.
Спасибо вам от душі.
Дякую. Кристиночка.
і вся ваша команда такої широти душі,
ви такі люди, і так мало таких людей,
і все, що б ви не делали,
просто там чоловічні відношення,
професіональні, ви — це просто океан.
Я вас люблю, я за все благодарю,
я рада, що ви в моїй житті появились.
А по поводу моєї трансформації,
мені два дні назад приснілся сон,
по поводу метафорічних карт,
мене приснилась гора, я забралась на вершину горы,
і коли захотелось з неї спуститися, я не змогла з неї спуститися,
тому що там пограничники якісь, вони мені кажуть, що сиди на цій горе, не спускайся.
І вибранна сьогодні метафорічна карта – це пламя огня.
Вот цей старий телевізор – це то, о чому все старе, ненужне, то, що мені не служило.
Мой старий костюм, он как бы загорает,
і я себя сейчас ощущаю таким чистим, большим, ярким пламенем.
Ну, це про мою транспорт.
Гори-гори, ясно.
Я благодарю вас за все.
Класс, клас, очень рад.
Леночка, це ви пользователь Zoom?
А, нет, все, Леночка.
Хотела что сказать.
Я вообще вас не знала.
І зрозуміла, як, я просто знаюю Юлю Гончару, ми з нею маєшлися на одному пісі.
І я случайно, ви де-то були на якому-то мероприятиї, і она написала про це пост, і я решила перейти, посмотри.
І практично зразу після цього був перший вебинар про МСММ.
Бляха-муха, я всю ніч не спала.
Я думала, що ж я сразу не написала?
А тепер я тут треба дождати до утра, а вдруг вже місць не буде.
І я с утра прям сразу, я там, ну, думаю, так, надо в 7 утра писать,
писать как-то не очень, дождалась в 9, короче, там, можно, вот, я, я, я, я.
Вот, і, как бы, действительно, сомнений не було, що мені сюди дуже хочеться.
І реально, в сравнении, допустим, з другими моими обученнями,
ну, це такий уровень, высокий, я говорю, а мене мурашить.
просто всю привізаторі.
Действительно, таку планку по обученню,
що я тепер не знаю,
куди ще хотілося б мені пойти,
де мені б дали б настільки широченний
і щедрий во всіх відношеннях курс.
Більші, більші спасибо.
Скільки тепла у словах у всіх.
Також сидиш і також грузиш в це все.
Все. Класс. Спасибо вам. Хороший наш. Правда, спасибо.
Это же тоже для нас сейчас очень-очень все показательно.
Анечка.
Да, я хочу присоединиться к теплым словам моих коллег, моих одногрупников, так хочу сказать,
потому что действительно этот год вернул меня в студенчество.
Именно в студенчество не только в плане обучения преподавателей,
то есть такое как-то юношество, такое молодость,
А ще і що ком'юнити, т.е. там, де ми вистраємо дружбу, вистраємо близькі відношення, вистраємо підтримку друг к другу.
І ця дружба, я думаю, цена буде тим, що ми її пронесемо сквозь всю життя, яка в нас.
Хочу поблагодарити не тільки групу MCM и вас, як организаторів, але ще й все те поле, всі тих людей, всі те ком'юнити, які ми собрали.
Це дійсно ценно. В сьогоднішній епохи онлайн-общення і там, де люди не вміють общаться, це дуже ценно. Найти своїх людей.
Спасибо вам.
І скільки по времени я можу просити допомоги у ваших групи підтримки, в общем, у админів?
Пока ви студенти, солнішки маю.
Тобто саме год, да?
Нет, пока студенти, до 6-го іюня.
Як заканчивається курс «Все, ви випускники»?
А, тобто з цього року? Год у нас платформа открыта?
Платформа «Запись», «Запись», буде год.
На все, що ви проходили, ми зберігаємо, ми оплачуємо хранилище, то це все буде зберігатися у вас. МЧП ми даємо ще місяць після завершення екзамена, даємо, тому що у когось не було вимень, хтось спеш
ив, просто щоб ви могли хоча б в машині послушати, дослухати, взяти себе то, що ви хочете. Тоже продовжуємо вам ще на місяць. Дальше поддержка буде существувати тільки в цій групі MCMM-ПРО, то, о чому
ми говорили.
Все, там она буде, понятне дело, на постоянной основе, ко всей команде, все остаются, все остальное. А вы, как студенты, уже в целом, как група, мы завершаем 6 июня работу с вами і випускаем вас в
мир. Все, 6 июня мы завершили наше обязательство перед вами.
Я поняла, спасибо вам огромное. Будьте здоровы, живите все богато.
Спасибо большое, Солошки. Спасибо. Все, обняли, поцеловали.
А можна випуску по поводу ПРО?
Где-то була інформація, чи це тільки для...
Да, була, була, була, на старте сьогодні лекції.
А, все, я пропустила, хорошо.
Нічого, нічого страшного, там буквально 15 минут, у вас же є записи.
Понятне дело, текстово оно повториться.
Но я б порекомендовала включити 15 минут,
вы там просто быстро съедите эту інформацію, там недолгое вступление,
оно прямо со старта начинається без никакой воды,
и там очень быстро заканчивається, потому что мы вышли с Настей.
Вот, поэтому вы посмотрите, все, захотите, не захотите, там очень много предложений,
вы там внутри увидите все, потому что я думаю, что мы все равно большинство увидимся там дальше.
Все, спасибо большое.
Вот, поэтому все, Оксана, ну в любом случае мы еще раз все покажем, да,
вот какие-то решения принялись вообще сегодня, да, ну то есть МЧП мы продлили на месяц,
потому что вы спросили, да, там, или еще что-то, да, ну то есть какие-то решения,
они сейчас принимались вместе с групой, поэтому посмотрите, там все есть.
Все, просто чтобы группу не держать, я больше из-за этого.
Так могу повторити, щоб групу не задерживати.
Все, сонношки мої, обняли, поцеловали,
ви лучше всіх на світі.
Дякую!